foreign
Advanced python course where we will
delve into the world of Python
Programming and explore its vast and
Powerful landscape
if you have ever wondered how to unlock
Python's 2 potential this course is
Tailor Made For You in This thrilling
journey we'll start right at the
beginning ensuring everyone's on board
we'll cover the fundamental steps from
setting up your python environment with
ease including the installation of
python itself and the ideally integrated
development and learning environment
after all a smooth takeoff sets the
stage for an amazing coding Adventure
our journey commences with the classic
hello world program a rite of passage
for any aspiring programmer once you
have mastered that we'll delve head
first into Python's essential building
blocks input methods indentation and the
power of comments which help us Write
Clean and understandable code next up we
will get Hands-On with variables
exploring data types and the magic of
typecasting then brace yourself as you
demystify the world of operators those
little symbols that pack a big punch in
python as we progress we'll immerse
ourselves in the captivating world of
strings learning their manipulation and
Powerful methods like if Felts
conditions will be your trusty
companions as you make your code smarter
and more Dynamic Python's Loop will be
your steadfast allies as you tackle
repetitive tasks and create efficient
automated Solutions and talking about
automation will explore the magic of
python functions your go-to recipe for
organized and reusable code but we won't
stop here brace yourself for the beauty
of Python's Lambda functions concise and
Powerful tools for functional
programming and then we hold the
magnificence of classes and objects in
Python your gateway to object oriented
programming with object oriented
programming we will unravel the concept
of inheritance the pillar of code
reusability and will master iterators
and generators elegant pythonic
solutions for iterating over data
structures with ease as we continue our
exploration we will uncover the secrets
of pythons scopes and arguments and we
will demystify the concept of modules
your toolkit to organize your code into
manageable units next we'll work with
map filter and reduce functions powerful
functional programming tools that
elevate your coding progress and
speaking of elevating we'll tackle
exceptions with grace through Python's
exceptional exception handling
techniques as our journey nearsight Peak
we will venture into the world of file
handling mastering the art of reading
and writing data to files and if you
thought data manipulation was over think
again we will explore sorting techniques
that will make your data dance to your
tune but wait there's more we'll dive
into virtual environments a must for any
python developer to manage project
dependencies effectively before we wrap
up this incredible ride we will reveal
the top 10 python libraries in 2023 that
are revolutionizing the way AV code and
streamline development and as the cherry
on top we will introduce you numpy and
pandas the dynamic dual powering data
science and Analysis so if you are eager
to enhance your python skills and embark
on a journey to python Mastery don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
our Channel and hit that notification
Bell together let's unlock the Limitless
potential of python and become coding
Wizards I can't wait to see you in a
first exciting episode until then Happy
coding and if you are one of the
aspiring python enthusiasts looking for
online training and graduating from the
best universities or a professional
wholly sets to switch careers in Python
by learning from the experts then try
giving a shout to Simply Lynn's
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning in collaboration with IBM the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete audio of the program
being offered now let's take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers hey I'm Sharia Jaleel
Ontario Canada I have been in I.T sector
for the past 20 years I recently took
the professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning the course has changed the way
I look at things and helped me back some
amazing freelance projects I started my
career in 1999 and over the years I have
worked with many companies my last tenor
was with IBM Canada my aim was to
restart my career and learn something
that would help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
a course in artificial intelligence and
machine learning is provided by simply
learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome the quality of
interaction within the course was simply
amazing
course faculty was also very experienced
and knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects also I
am planning to start an AI based startup
with my friend where I feel that the
learning from the course to be very
helpful I am really delighted and happy
in my free time I try to create
meaningful content on YouTube and I talk
about new technologies and what kind of
courses professionals should be taking
along with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band now over to our training
experts
so we would be doing all our stuff
in a folder only and directly in an
ideally
so before that we will create a folder
and name it as
Python tutorial
and now
we will install the python for that you
guys have to visit the website
python.org
press enter
now you can see the downloads option
just click on that
and you will see the download python
3.11.0 version so just click on that and
it will start downloading for you I've
already downloaded it
so you just have to open this exe file
and just
and you have to select add python.exe to
path if you have
like if you haven't installed python on
your system first time you are
installing it you have to tick on this
checkbox else you don't have to
click on install now
and like I have already installed the
python on my system
and it's asking me username and password
so this setup has failed like I have
closed the setup so you just have to
progress with the setup click on the
next button and click on the check boxes
that asks you to agree some terms and
conditions and then the final setup
would be completed
and after this the the thing we need to
install is the python ideally
in which we would code and learn the
basics
so we would be using the visual studio
code so for that
you will visit the Wheel Studio code
website
and just click on the download button
you could select the windows Os or
Ubuntu in which
like in which operating system you're
working on just click on the
desired option you want to download okay
like if I am using the Windows operating
system I will click on Windows
and I will select the 64-bit so you can
see that the download has been started
so after downloading you just open the
exe file
and progress where it says the next and
the stuff
so after downloading we will open up
folder and inside that we will open the
command prompt
and letter Visual Studio code open
and if you want to learn how to
configure the visual studio code I will
Mark the python playlist that would be
the full flash playlist for all the
topics for the python installation then
the first program then the ideal
installation and all the things I will
pin the playlist in the I button so you
can check it out there okay
here we will name the file as tutorial
Dot py
and we'll start with our basics
so first we will write the basic hello
world program
for that we'll create a variable
and inside
all right hello world
and after that you will print the
statement using the print function
you will save the program and run it
so you can see the output that it has
printed hello world here
now the next thing we will learn is the
input method how to get the input from
the user so for that
first we will comment this down
and we'll start with the input method
and for that
we will input the name from the user for
that we have created a variable and I
will tell you what are the conditions to
create a variable
after this
so here we have created the variable and
use the input method and inside
what
you will write what is your name
so this text would be displayed to the
user and he would be knowing that he has
to enter his name
after that we will print his name
first we'll write a string welcome to
python
tutorial
and
to write the variable that has some
values in it we will use the addition
sign that is the plus sign and
then write the variable name
so we'll save this
and click on run so you can see that
it is asking us what is your name
so I will write a bissar Ahuja and press
enter
so you can see that it has maintained
welcome to Python tutorial episode
so if you want to add some space here
you could simply do that
by adding space in the inverted commas
we'll save this and run it again
so it's asking me what's your name I
will write this uhuja
so you could see that it has given us
the output welcome to Python tutorial
so moving on now we'll talk about some
indentation part like how we write code
in Python
so first okay we will comment it
afterwards
so
talking about the indentation
so in Python indentation is of three
types the simple statement empty
statement and the complex statements
if I let you see this is the simple
statement it starts just from the left
of the corner
and the empty statements we don't have
to do anything for that
for the complex statements like the FL
statements
so there are two portions in the complex
uh the indentation here means leaving a
tab space from margin and in Python it
is used to show that statements which
are indented belong to Upper statements
you would see in the loop section and
the IFL section that is the control
statements conditional statement section
so in statements like if else if L if
Etc views indentation because these are
old types of complex statements and they
have two parts that I already stated
that is header and the body
so we have to indent our body statements
to show that these are sub statements of
our main statement which is written in
header portion
and as I have showed you how to comment
foreign
the code
in our program
so we just
have to place the hash before
line of codes like if you want to just
comment down a single line of code
you could simply
just put a hash in front of the
line of code
and there are multi lines command also
we have seen the single line comment
that is using hash their multi-line
comments also so single line comment is
the command which are created in single
line only that is they occupy the space
of single line and then create it just
placing the hash before the code line if
you want to create a multi-line command
I will show you how you can create it
you just have to use
inverted commas but you should have
three inverted commas in that
inverted single commas three inverted
single commas
foreign
we have seen the multi-line comments how
to comment if there are more than one
line
and we want to comment it down so we
will use the single inverted commas for
that the three single inverter
and moving on now we'll start with
variables
so a variable is a name or an identifier
which is given to any storage area or
memory location it's a name of memory
location and there are some rules for
defining a variable in Python variable
name can contain alphabets digits and
underscore
second variable name can start with an
alphabet and underscore only it can't
start with a digit
no white space and reserved keywords are
allowed to use as a variable name and
the variables are case sensitive so
we'll see some examples how to create a
variable
like simply we can create a variable and
assign a value to it equal to 7 so a is
the variable here and we have assigned
a value to it
and
we can start with the variable name with
the underscore that is underscore
p80
and we can assign any value to it we
will assign an integer value to it that
would be a bisar
and if you want to use underscore in
between you can also use that so for
that we will write
a b underscore
bat
and that would be equal to
we'll assign any value to it that would
be Ahuja
so these are the variable names and if
you want to add any number to variable
you can edit a b underscore bat one so
we have added a number here also
so these are the methods how you can
create a variable
and just be remember of some basic rules
for that and now moving on to data types
you have seen that variables can store
data of different types and these
different types can do different things
python has the
built-in data types by default and those
are string in numeric types we have int
float and complex types in sequence
types we have list Tuple range in
mapping type we have dictionaries set
types we have set and Frozen set in
Boolean type we have Boolean binary
types we have bytes byte array
memory View
and
we would be using these data types in
the upcoming tutorial
so I'll simply comment this down
and now we will move to
type casting
so typecasting is defined as converting
one data type into another for smooth
functioning of program
and with type function we can find the
type of any variable
I will show you with a demo
so if you have created a variable and
stored a value in it
so to know the data type
we would simply write print
type
in bracket the variable in which the
value has been stored
so we'll just save this
and run the program
and you will see that it has stated the
class as in type so the integer value is
stored in the variable a
and if you store some
value as a float we will see
what does type function return to us
we have saved this and run this
so first
oh sorry
um
so you guys can see
that
we have entered the p in the type
function now we will run the program and
you can see that it has returned the
float class
that is stored in the variable B
so this is how typecasting works so you
could identify any data type using the
type method and type casting is done
when we want to perform arithmetic
operations on the variables of the same
data type
and moving on to operators
operators are used to perform operations
on variables and values python divides
the operators in the following Loops
there are arithmetic operators
assignment operators comparison
operators logical operators identity
operators membership operators and the
bitwise operators
the arithmetic operators are addition
subtraction multiplication division
modulus exponentiation and flow Division
I will show you some examples for it
I will comment this down
and start with operators
so we will
Define a value to a variable X
and Define a value to a variable by
and now our first arithmetic operation
that would be addition so for that we'll
simply write
print
X Plus y we will save this and run this
program
you could see that it has showed the
addition of both X and Y
and through subtraction you will simply
have to place the subtraction symbol
between both the variables
that is 15 and -1
and you could see that the other
operations can be done similarly
you just have to place the
arithmetic operation symbol between the
two variables
X
strip y that is a multiplication symbol
we'll save this and
run it and if you want to learn about
the variables
and the data types and the arithmetic
operations in a deep manner you could
just click on the I button and check out
the playlist of python
there you will get all the topics
discussed in a very vast way
so
we will see
other operators also
that is the division
let's save it and run it
you could see that it has given us the
output 0.875
and
the modulus operator
we'll save this
and run it you could see that it has
given us the output 7.
so modulus gives us the remainder
and now
we would be using the exponentiation
operator
so you'll be getting
the value of 7 raised to the power 8.
and for floor division you just simply
have to use
two slash symbols
you could see that it has given you zero
now moving on
we will see assignment operators that is
equal to plus equal to minus equal to S
trick equal to division equal to modulus
equal to flow division equal to and many
more
so now we'll start with the strings so
we have seen the operators and if you
want to
dig deep down into into the operators
you can simply click on the I button and
visit the playlist and you will get the
operators
tutorial there
now we'll start with
strings
so string literal in Python are enclosed
in either single quotes or the double
quotes it means hello
is same as hello I will show you what I
am trying to say
that is hello
in
single double quotes or
foreign double quotes that is similar
so this is how a string is represented
in a python
so we will get a single string printed
for that we'll write print
and
store this in a variable
x equal to hello
and get it printed
we'll save the program and run it you
can see that it has given the output as
hello
so we have seen how we declare the
string in Python
now moving on we move to list that is
the sequence types
and we'll start with the first sequence
type that is list
foreign
used to store multiple items in a single
variable and lists are one of four
built-in data types in Python that is
used to store collections of data and
the other three types are double set and
dictionaries they all have different
qualities and usage list items can be of
any data type they are created using
square brackets
so we will see a demo how a list
is created so we will name it as list
one that is equal to and inside square
brackets
we will list some cars that would be BMW
4D
and Mercedes
so you can see that in the square
brackets we have added some cars and in
the inverted commas
it has been stored in a variable list
one so this is the list and that is
stored in the variable list one
and the main point list items are
ordered
which means that the items have a
defined order and that order will not
change if you add new items to a list
the new items will be placed at the end
of the list
and the list items are changeable which
means that we can change add and remove
items in a list after it has been
created and this also allows duplicate
values
since lists are indexed lists can have
items with the same value
as you have indexes that are starting
from 0 BMW that
is based on the index 0.
and if you want to find the length of
the list you could just simply use the
length function
for that
we'll write
length of
list one
we'll save this
and click on the
run button you could see that it states
that there are three elements stored in
the list
no
moving on to tuples so tuples are used
to store multiple items in a single
variable antable is also one of the four
built-in data types in Python that is
used to store collections of data tuples
are written with round brackets
you'll see a demo
how tuples are created
before that we will create a variable
and
named as
to 1 and inside the
circular brackets
we will
insert some values
that would be the name of
some pass
then with the car brands BMW
OD
and Mercedes
and
then you can print this Tuple
and just save it
and click on the Run button you can see
that the Tuple is created and it has
given us the output three values that we
have stored in the topper
and some important facts about the
properties about the tuples that the
Tuple items are ordered it means that
the items have a defined order or that
order will not change
and the elements in the Tuple are
unchangeable that we cannot change add
or remove items after the Tuple has been
created
and it allows duplicate values since
tuples are indexed that is BMW is
indexed at index value 0 OD at 1 and
Mercedes at 2 so they can have items
with the same value
and if you want to find the length of
the Tuple you could use the length
method
for that we'll just write print
and inside print we'll use the length
function and
the name
of the double we'll save this
and run this
you could see that it has given us the
output 3 that is it has saved three
elements in the double
now
moving on to sets sets are used to store
multiple items in a single variable
and it is also one of the four built-in
data types that is used to store
collection data
and a set is a collection which is
unordered unchangeable and unindexed
so we'll see a demo for that
now we'll see the demo for sets
to create a set we just need to use
curly braces
so for that we will create a variable
set one and inside that
in curly braces
you would add the car brands that is PMW
then OD
once it is
and after that we will print
set one
and save this
and run the program you could see that
the set has been created
and uh set items are unordered you have
seen that the list and Tuple items are
ordered but in sets the items are
unordered
they do not have a defined order so the
items can appear in a different order
every time you use them and cannot be
referred to by any index or key value
and they are unchangeable that is we
cannot change the items after the set
has been created and it do not allow
duplicate values also
we have seen the sets and moving on
we'll see dictionaries
as the container values
so dictionaries are used to store data
values in key value pairs they are
written with curly braces and have keys
and values
and the collection is ordered and as of
python version 3.7 dictionaries are
ordered in Python version 3.6 and
earlier dictionaries are unordered
we will
see a small demo for dictionaries
now starting with dictionaries first we
will comment this set
we will create a dictionary
with the variable indict 1
that is equal to
curly braces and inside curly braces we
will
and option carbon and that
its value is BMW
and the second car
its value is
body
and we have to place a comma after every
item
spawn the car three
is Mercedes
so now we'll get this dictionary printed
print
indictment
so we'll save this
and click on the Run button so that the
dictionary
it created and
we also get the printed dictionary that
is carbon is associated with the value
BMW car 2 is associated with value only
car 3 is associated with value Mercedes
and in dictionaries the items are
changeable that is that means you can
change add or remove items after the
dictionary has been created and it does
not allow duplicate items that is
with the same key you can't have two
values
two same values
with the two different Keys you can't
have two same values so it does not
allow duplicate items
now moving on
you can see some effects conditions
so
that we will understand the effects
condition using
an example only
so first we will create a variable and
assign a value to it
and then
another variable
and assign value to it and now we'll use
if statement
and write if B is greater than
a
then
we will print
B is greater than
a okay
so we'll save this
and click on run you could see that the
condition is true that is B that stores
the value 9 is greater than a so it has
printed B greater than a
and if we reverse the condition if a is
greater than V
ENT B greater than a
and if we run this you can see you
didn't go to any value as the condition
is false so it won't run the print
statement here
so now moving on
now after
as you have seen that
if the condition is not true it will not
print the print statement
now we will also
use the LF statement here
so if the above condition is not true
it will move to the next statement that
would be and if and if B is greater than
a
it will print
p is greater than a okay so we'll save
this and click on run button
you could see that it has first
gone through this if statement and this
is not correct it has not printed this
print statement then it has moved to the
edif statement and it could be greater
than a
and it has printed B is greater than a
so you can use as many and if statement
as you want
and now we will be using the else
statement
the else keyword catches anything which
isn't code by the preceding conditions
so for the else statement
and if we
just
get this b equal to equal to a that is
if B value is equal to equal to a then
it should print B is greater than a
and if these both conditions are not
true then it would be shifted to add
statement
and
for and statement we will write
print
be equal to 9.
so we'll save this
then run it
so you could see that it has given us
the output as b equal to 9 as it has
gone through the if statement if a is
greater than V that is 7 is not greater
than 9 so
it has
augmented that statement then it has
moved to the next statement that is alif
statement that is b equal to equal to a
and 7 is not equal to 9 so it has
omitted that statement and move to next
statement that is else and it is printed
P equal to Knight in b equal to 9.
if the above statements mentioned above
the else statement are not true then the
else statement would be executed and it
will print what is inserted in the end
statement
so moving on
we will start with python loops and
python is two Loop commands that is two
primitive two commands while loop and
for Loop
and with the while loop we can execute a
set of statements as long as a condition
is true
we will see this with the help of an
example
first we'll comment this down
and here
see example of by Loop
if we start with i equal to 1
and while
i s
less than
it will print
I
and it will increment
I with
value one so I'll save this and run this
program
you can see that
the value while loop has been executed
and it has printed one two three four
five six seven eight
till ninety eight
while I is less than 99
if we put I is less than equal to
99 so it will
run the loop till 99.
you could see that the loop has been
executed till 99.
so this is how we use the while loop and
for for loops
the for Loop is used for iterating over
a sequence that is list double and
dictionaries
so I will show you an example for that
I will comment it down
foreign
Loop
I will create a list
and inside the list we will add the
brand names only that would be BMW
OD
and then Mercedes
and now
to print all these values we'll use the
for Loop
or I in
this one
print I
will save this
and click on run button
you could see that this Loop has printed
all the values one by one that is PMW OD
and Mercedes
this is how the loops are used
now moving on
will
see the python functions so a function
is a block of code which only runs when
it is called and you can pass any data
that is known as parameters into a
function
so we'll see
how we Define and call a function in
Python
that
we use the keyword DF and then the
function name
so we'll name the function hello
and after the colon
we will print
hello simply
learn
ers
and after that we'll call this function
that is hello
and we'll simply call this we'll save
this and run it
you can see that it has printed hello
simply eyeliner so we have defined the
function here and hold the function here
now
we'll see some functions with argument
so for that
you can just pass an argument in
this function only F name as an argument
so any information can be passed into
functions as arguments and arguments are
specified after the function name inside
the parenthesis you can add as many
arguments as you want just separate them
with a comma
so we have added a single argument here
and
here
we will do print hello simply learn
learners
and after that
just say hello and the name of the
person
with that we will write F name
now we will call the function with the
parameter
so we'll pass the parameter
first would be a Visa
second you pass
anurag
and the as James
so we will save this
and run it
you could see that it has given the
output as hello abysar hello anurag
hello James
so we have passed an argument here that
is f name and we have printed the
statement with a string that would be
constant that is hello and F name as we
will pass the parameter when we call the
function
so we have passed a bissar here so it
has printed first hello abisa then we
have called the function again and we
have passed the value anurag there the
name anurag there so it will display
hello anurag then hello James
so these are with the function now we
will move to python built-in math
functions so python has a set of
built-in math functions including an
extensive math module that we'll see in
the further tutorial
that will allow you to perform
mathematical tasks or number so we will
see a demo
using these functions
first we will see the built-in functions
and when we'll study about the module
then we'll
see some functions from the module also
so we'll start with minimum and maximum
functions
so for that first we'll create a
variable
and
apply the minimum function there so the
minimum and maximum functions they can
be used to find the lowest or highest
value in an I travel
so we will add some values that is 3 9 7
and another value that is B equal to Max
and then we'll pass values
2 9 8 8.
and
71.
now we'll get
printed print text
and then
print B
so we'll save this
and run it so you can see that it has
given us the output as 3 that is we have
used the minimum function so it has
get the minimum value from all the items
we have
passed in the minimum function that is
39719 the minimum value is 3 and in the
max function the max value that is 88.
so moving on now we have absolute
function
so first we'll comment down this
and moving on we'll use the absolute
function so the absolute function
Returns the absolute positive value of
the specified number
if we write a negative number
and we will use the absolute function
for that
inside absolute function write a
negative value that would be
um
99.75 okay
and after that
you have to print this value print X
and save this program
and run it
you could see that the value has been
turned into positive that is 99.75 so
absolute converts the negative value
into positive that's it it only prints
positive value but you pass whether it's
positive or negative
so we'll see another function that would
be the power function
so the power function
its syntax would be like this x comma y
so I will show you
with the help of a demo with the help of
an example so
for that we write x equal to
file function and inside will pass
comma 3 that is 4 raised to power 3 and
then we will print its value
now I'll save this program and run it
so you could see that it has given us
the value as 64. so 4 4 is a 16 16 4 64.
oh
raised to the power 3.
so we have seen another built-in
function that is Spa
now
moving on
we have python Lambda function
now moving on
so a Lambda function is a small
Anonymous function and it can take any
number of admits but can only have one
expression so we'll see an example
first we'll commend this down
and for Lambda function
we will create a variable and inside we
will Lambda
variable
X
and we will
Define an expression for that that would
be X
multiplication operator into 10
and then we will
print it
X
no r
function name is a and inside we will
pass
5.
so 5 would be placed in place of X that
would be
it will return the value as 50. so you
could see that we have created a Lambda
function in a variable a and we have
defined the expression that is we have
used the variable X for the expression
and we have defined the expression as X
using the multiplication operator into
10 and then we have printed it let us
print the name of the Lambda function
and the value we have passed that would
be replacing X
so now
moving on to the next item
python iterator but before python 8
return I am going to tell you one thing
that in Python we do not have arrays
like we do not have built-in support for
arrays but python lists they can be used
as arrays
so for that you can just click on the I
button then you would get the playlist
and there is a video particularly in
list apple and dictionaries so there you
will be getting all the details about
the list and how you can use them as
array
so moving on we would
start with python iterator so an
iterator is an object that can be
iterated upon meaning that you can
Traverse through all the values which
consist of the methods
I will show you two methods
that is underscore underscore
ITR
and its current score
and the second method is next
so these are the two methods that we
used in a nitrator
so
I will make you understand with the help
of an example
so first we will create a tuple and name
it as
top one
and inside the circular brackets
we'll write the brand name of the cars
so that would be PMW
the next is OD
d
and the next is
Mercedes
and now
we will create a variable
my
Tuple equal to
height weight of function
and inside we will pass the name of the
variable
that we have created as a tuple
and now to iterate this double we will
write print
and using the next function
inside
we will just write the name of the
variable in which we have passed the
Tuple here
that is
my
Tuple
and again
we will print this statement
now we'll save this and run the program
you could see that it has printed
the first value in the Tuple one
that is PMW and then OD so we have
created it upper and store three items
in that and then we have created a
variable and use the iterator function
and pass the Tuple in that and after
that we have created
print statement inside we have passed my
top variable inside the next function so
it has printed the value BMW then OD and
if we
print this value again and save this and
run this
you could see all the three values that
are stored in the topper they have been
printed
so we have seen the iterator
pythonitrator now moving on to the next
topic
that is python modules
so a module
a python module is same as a code
library that is a file containing a set
of functions that you want to include in
your applications so we have some
modules that are
repeat yeah
so we have some modules that have
already been defined that is pandas
matplotlip and beautiful soup and Mac
module so there are so many modules
that have been defined
and you can also create a module of your
own and you can import it into another
program so you just have to save the
file with the extension Dot py and you
can use that file into another file just
using the word import using the word
import statement or import then the name
of the file that you have created with
the py extension
so here
you would see a module that have been
created
earlier
and that module would be math
so password import that module that is
import math
that is the built-in module and it has
named as math which will extend the list
of mathematical functions in the python
and to use it we have use the import
keyword and after that we have written
the name of the module
and when you have imported the math
module you can start using methods and
constants of the module that is math
so first we'll start with the square
root method
for that we'll create a variable and
inside
write math Dot
sqrt and inside we will pass
91.
and then we will print the variable
we will save this
so we'll save this
and run it so you could see that the
square root of 91 is
9.5393920 and it goes on
so this is one of the methods that is
stored in the math module and we have
other methods also
I will see another method that is
ceiling and ceiling method rounds a
number of words to its nearest integer
and there's another method that is flow
that rounds the number downwards to its
nearest integer and Returns the result
so for that we'll write a variable x
equal to
and to use these functions we will write
math Dot
scene function
and
will write the value 5.4
and in another variable that is y equal
to we'll use the math
module and here we will use the method
floor
and inside will pass
5.4 only
and then we will print both these
variables it is print X
and
print y now we'll save this
and run the program you could see that
it has returned the value as 6 that it
Returns the value that is upwards to its
nearest integer that is
above the 5.4 that is 5 that is integer
5 and integer 6 we have the value 5.4 in
between and the upward value which
corresponds to 5.4 is 6 so it has
written the value of 6 and with the flow
function it would return the value that
is downward
to 5.4 that is 5. try giving a shout to
Simply lens postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning in collaboration
with the IBM the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete audio
of the program being offered
so let's start with lists and python
imagine
you have different values you have
numbers you have strings now if you want
to group them together you can do this
job in Python with the help of lists or
you have worked with arrays in any other
language like C plus plus or Java this
is the similar stuff in here which is
list
a list can be defined as a collection of
objects values or items of different
types and these collections are enclosed
within the square brackets and are
separated by commas let's understand
this with the help of an example
we will create a list and name it as
list one and insert the elements in
square brackets and separate them with
the help of commas
list 1 equal to square packets 1 comma
Adam
107 coma USA
and unless we have our first element at
zeroth indexed and we have one at zero
index Adam at one index 107 at second
index USA at third index and talking
about the reverse index it starts with
-1 index value we have USA at -1 index
value 107 at minus 2 index value atom at
minus 3 index value and 1 at minus 4
index value
we will explore the list with various
examples in Jupiter notebook in a while
till then let's look at the
characteristics of list
first the lists are ordered when we say
that lists are ordered it means that the
items have a defined order and that
order will not change if you add new
items to a list the new items will be
placed at the end of the list
second elements of the list can be
accessed by index values third list can
store various types of elements for
example numbers strings or lists itself
fourth lists are mutable the list is
changeable meaning that we can change
add and remove items in a list after it
has been created
lists allow duplicate elements since
lists are indexed list can have items
with the same value let's have a look at
some methods of list in Python
the first one is append it adds an
element at the end of the list
for syntax we can write list 1 dot
append and in round brackets we have to
write the element which we want to
append
the next is insert it adds an element at
the specified position its syntax is
name of the list dot insert and in round
brackets we'll write the index at which
we want to insert the element and comma
and after that the element which we want
to insert
third is extend
it adds the element of a list to the end
of the current list
its syntax is list 1 dot extend and in
noun brackets we will add the element
like list 2 which we want to extend in
the list the next is index it Returns
the index of the first element with the
specified value
and its syntax is list 1 dot index and
the element which we want to fetch the
index
the next is remove it removes the item
with the specified value
its syntax is list 1 dot remove and in
node brackets we write the element which
we want to remove from the list
the next is sort
this method is used to sort the list its
syntax is list one dot sort
the next is reverse it reverses the
order of the list its syntax is list 1
dot reverse
let's move to Jupiter notebook to
explore these methods
let's start with creating a list we'll
name the list as list one
and we will create
equal to
and we'll start with square brackets
and we'll write our first element that
would be apple
comma space next element
Orange
comma space the next element
banana
kiwi
now we will get this list printed for
that we will write the syntax
print and in round brackets you will
write the list name that would be list
one and run the command you can see here
that the list is printed
now let's create a different list with
some different elements
list 2 equal to
and in square brackets we'll write
Apple
now we will insert a list in a list
for that
we will write a list in square brackets
8 comma 4 comma 6.
and comma the next element that will
write Orange
the next element banana
now print this list
to print this we'll write print round
brackets will write list 2.
and run the command here we will get the
list to print it
we can access any element in the list so
for that we'll write the syntax print
we want to access the second element
that will be the third element from the
last one for that you will write the
syntax print
list 1 and in square brackets we'll
write the index 2 and run the command we
will get the third element from the list
one that is banana
now we will access an element from the
list two for that we'll write the
command print
list two
and in square bracket we will write 1
and in square bracket we'll write 2 and
run the command what we get is 6.
so to access an element from a list that
is already inserted in and list we have
to write the syntax
so this syntax tells us that we will
first access the first index element
that is 846 the list and in that we will
access the second index value that would
be 0 1 and 2 that is 6. so this is the
syntax to access an element in a list
that is already inserted in a list
now we'll see a reverse index order for
that we'll write the command print
list one and in square brackets we'll
write the index minus 1.
and we'll run this command and we get tv
as output
now we'll see slicing in Python we can
access a range of items in a list by
using the slicing operator
now we will see an example
to see the slicing operator work in
Python for that we will write the syntax
print
last one
and in square brackets we'll write one
slicing operator 3 and run the command
what we see is orange and banana as an
output from the list one
when you write 1 ratio 3 that is one
slicing operator 3 it gives you the
elements at index 1. 2 and node 3. so we
get the output as orange comma banana
now we will
see another example for the slicing
operator we'll write print
list one
and in square brackets we'll write 3
and slicing operator
run the command here we can get only TV
when we write a single number before
slicing operator it would print the
value at that index value and all the
other elements that are present in the
list but in this list we have only QV as
the last element so it would print third
index value and note more than that
now we'll see a band function for that
we'll write the syntax list 1 Dot
append and in round brackets we will
write the element which we want to
insert at the last of the list
we'll write quava and
run it and now we will print the list to
see the result
here we can see that guava is added at
the last of the list
now we'll see extend function for that
we'll write the index list 1 Dot
extend and in round brackets
we will write
in square brackets the particular
elements we want to insert in the list
so we will write watermelon
and the next time when we want to insert
would be musk melon
that would be in inverted commas
and we also want this list to be printed
so we'll write print list one and
execute this command here
we can get watermelon and musk melon add
it just after the list just add the last
elements of the list
now if you want to delete a particular
element from the list you can delete it
with the syntax
DL
space
the list name you want to delete the
element
and in square brackets you will write
the index for the element you want to
delete
we have written the fifth index value so
we'll run this command and we'll get the
list printed
we can see that the fifth index value
that is watermelon is not there in list
one it's been deleted
now
you can also do this with another method
that is removed for that we will write
list one dot
remove and in round brackets we'll write
the particular element we want to remove
we'll write that that is kiwi and we
also want the list to be printed so
we'll write print in noun brackets list
one
and run this command
we get that the Kiwi is been removed
from the list one
now there is another method that is pop
we'll write the command print
in round brackets you will write list
one dot
pop
and you will write the index value
but we want to remove from the list that
is one
and we also want the list to be printed
so for that we will write the command
print
list one
and we'll run this command
okay we have not written the name of the
list correctly so now list one
now
so at the one index that was orange that
has been removed from the list
and now this is the new list
now we will can see another method that
is clear that removes all the elements
from the list so this we would reply on
the list to list 2 dot clear method
and we will also write another command
that would be print list to
and execute this command we can see that
the list 2 is empty now all the elements
from the list 2 have been removed now
we'll see another method that is reverse
for that we'll write the command list
one so reverse
and round brackets and we also want the
list one to be printed for that we will
write the command
print list one and execute this command
here we can see that the list one has
been reversed muskmelon guava banana
apple
now if you want a particular index
element to be accessed you can
have the Syntax for that you can write
that print
list one dot index
and in round brackets you just need to
write the element for what you want to
get the index
and just run this command you will get
the index of the element
guava that is one
we have another method in list that is
count so count is used to give the
number of times the particular element
is present in the list so for that we
will write the syntax print
sorry print
and in round brackets you will write the
list name list one dot count and round
brackets you will write the particular
element for which we want to get the
number of times that has been present in
the list
write musk melon
and run this command it would give us
the value 1 because it's been present in
the list for only a single time now
let's move to the tuples so Tuple Tuple
is almost same as list we can have
different types of values in tuples the
difference in list
is we can change value because list is
mutable and Tuple is immutable that
means you cannot change the value
a tuple can be defined as a collection
of objects values or items of different
types and these collections are enclosed
within the circle brackets and separated
by commas let's understand this with the
help of an example we will create a
tuple and name it as tough one and
insert the elements in round brackets
and separate them with the help of
commas so depth 1 equal to round
brackets the first element is 1 comma
and the second element is atom third
element is 107 and the fourth element is
USA
now interpols we have our first element
at zeroth index and we have one at zero
index and atom at one index and 107 at
second index and USA at third index and
for the reverse index it starts with -1
index value we have USA at -1 value 107
at minus 2 say index value and atom at
-3 index value and 1 at minus 4 index
value
we will explore the tuples with various
examples in Jupiter notebook but till
then let's look at the characteristics
of double
so the first is the tuples are ordered
when we say that tuples are ordered it
means that the items have a defined
order and that order will not change
elements of the tuples can be accessed
by index Tuple items are indexed the
first item has index 0 the second index
has 1. third apples can store various
type of elements that is strings arrays
and many other elements
the next is tuples are immutable doubles
are unchangeable meaning that we cannot
change add or remove items after the
Tuple has been created
next is tuples allow duplicate elements
since tuples are indexed they can have
items with the same value
let's have a look at some methods of
tuples in Python
first that is index we can use the index
operator to access an item in a tuple
with the index starts from 0. its
syntaxes the name of the Tuple node
index and in noun brackets will write
the element for which we want to access
the index
the second is slicing we can access a
range of items in a tuple by using the
slicing operator for that we'll write
the syntax top 1 and the range for which
we want to slice the Tuple
the third is concatenation here we will
add two tuples that is we just have to
write the name of the tuples to add them
and we'll place the plus Operator just
between them
the next is repetition we can have the
same item multiple times in a tuple for
that we'll just have to write the syntax
the name of the Tuple and the
multiplication operator into the times
we want that value to be present in the
Tuple
the next is count it Returns the number
of items a specified value occurs in a
tuple
so for that we have the syntax Step 1
dot count and in rhyme brackets we will
just write the element for which we want
to count the number of times that
specified value has been occurred
we also have another method that is
indexed it searches the Tuple for a
specified value and Returns the position
of
that where it was found
now let's move to Jupiter notebook to
explore these methods so let's start
first we will comment
that will be the pulse
and we'll
go to the next column and first we'll
create a tuple
for that we'll write the command to P1
that would be the name of the Tuple and
in round brackets we'll
insert the elements that would be
Apple
comma
Orange
banana
comma
KV
now we'll print this Tuple
we'll just have to write print and in
round brackets the name of the topper
and run the command
will get the Tuple
printed
now if you just want to insert a single
element in a tuple for that you will
write the command tab 2. equal to in
round brackets you will write a single
element that would be apple
and run that command
the Tuple has been created but this
Tuple has not been considered as Tuple
in Python it's been considered as string
so let's check the type of this double
for that we will write print
type
and noun brackets we'll write the name
of the Tuple we want to check and run
this command here we can see that it is
showing a string so a single element is
been shown as string
in Python if you want that it should be
Tuple for that you just have to
insert a single comma in the Tuple and
now run this command you will get this
type estable
now if you want to access any element in
a Tupper for that you just have to write
the command print
top one and in square brackets the index
value that is zero and here you quote
the value Apple that is at zeroth index
value and top one
now you can also access the element in
the reverse order for that we'll write
the command print
F1
and in square brackets we'll write the
index value -1
and run the command here you can get the
value key V from the reverse index
folder
now we also have the slicing operator in
tuples also
for that we'll write the command print
F1 in square brackets
the index values will
run this command print tab 1 index value
1 slicing operator 3. so it has printed
orange and banana
so what does it means it prints the
index value 1 and 2 and node 3.
you also have a repetition method in
tuples for that we just have to write a
simple syntax
like print
in square brackets the element you want
to repeat
they will write the element as repeat
only
and
comma to just consider as Tuple and just
after the bracket we would have to write
the multiply operator and the number of
times the element should be repeated in
the Tuple now we'll run this command
you can see that the Tuple has been
created with the element repeat and the
number of times is 3 that we have
written just after the element
so the Tuple has been created now we'll
see the count method for that we'll
write the command print
the name of the Tuple dot count
and in round brackets we will write the
element for which we want to
know the number of times between present
in the Tuple
and we'll execute the command it gives
us zero as our top 1 doesn't consist
guava as an element
so it gives us the count as 0. now you
see another method that would be index
for that we'll write the command print
top one dot index
and in down brackets we'll write the
element for which we want to fetch the
index of that element
banana and we'll run this command we
will get the index of the element banana
that is to
0 1 2.
so we get the index of the element
banana
now if we want to use the append method
in tuples we have to first create the
Tuple into the list for that we will
write the command y equal to list
and in down brackets we will write
the name of the Tuple
which we want to convert in the list now
we'll use the append method
to the list that is why
dot append
and will insert an element that would be
guava
and now
we would just assign
the Y list to a variable top one
we have now converted
the Y list to the Tuple with this syntax
that is
Double Y and we have assigned it to the
top one value
now we will print this Tuple
and execute the command here we can see
that we have used the append method
in the Tuple
first we have changed the Tuple to the
list by this command y equal to list tab
1 then we have used the append method y
node append and appended the element
guava then we have changed the Y list to
the Tuple that is Step 1 equal to Tuple
the name of the list and then we have
printed the Tuple
we can also add two doubles by another
method for that
we will
write another Tuple that would be top
three
equal to we will insert an element that
would be cherry
and now
we want it to be added in top one so
we'll write
top one plus equal to
top three
and now we will print
the final Tuple that would be top one
and run the command here we can see that
we have added
two tuples that is double one and double
three which consists of cherry and here
we get the whole Tuple as double one now
to execute Loops interples we'll write
the command
for that we will write the Syntax for
space
a variable X and
the name of the Tuple
colon
and then we will print
the particular element one by one and
we'll run this command here we can see
that all the elements have been printed
from the Tuple
now let's understand dictionaries in
Python
unless you can fetch the elements with
the help of index numbers but if you
want to specify a different type of
index for it example if you have a list
of 8 values and you want to fetch the
fifth one you will use the index but if
you have key for each element then you
can use the key to access that element
example phone book if you want to fetch
a number you will use a name and you get
a number and officially if we talk about
dictionary if you want to understand the
meaning of a word you go to that page
and you look at the word and understand
the meaning of it so this type of
concept where you have a key and
corresponding to that you have a value
we can achieve this with the help of
dictionaries
python dictionary can be defined as a
collection of objects values or items of
different types stored in key value pair
format these multiple key value pairs
created are enclosed within the curly
braces and each key is separated from
its value by the colon let's understand
this with the help of an example
dict1 equal to curly braces the first
key is a and corresponding to that we
have value and that is separated by
colon and after the key value pair that
is separated by a comma the next is b
key and that has a corresponding value
too after that we have inserted a comma
to separate it from other values now we
have a third key that is C and
corresponding to that we have a value 3.
let's see some characteristics of
dictionaries
the dictionaries are ordered from python
version 3.7 when we say that
dictionaries are ordered it means that
the items have a defined order and that
order will not change
second that is elements of the
dictionaries cannot be accessed by index
third dictionaries can store various
types of elements fourth dictionaries
are mutable dictionaries are changeable
meaning that we can change add or remove
items after the dictionary has been
created
fifth one is dictionaries doesn't allow
duplicate elements dictionaries cannot
have two items with the same key
now let's see some methods in
dictionaries the first is clear method
it removes all the elements from the
dictionary and its syntax is the name of
the dictionary dot clear
the second is get it Returns the value
of the specified key
the syntax is dict1 dot key and in
square brackets we have to write the key
name
the third is case it returns a list
containing the dictionary's key its
syntax is indict1 dot Keys the next is
pop it removes the element with the
specified key its syntax is dict1 dot
pop and in round brackets you would
write the particular key name
and the next method is Pope item it
removes the last inserted key value pair
from the dictionary and it syntax is
dict1.pop item let's move to the Jupiter
notebook and execute these methods
first we will add a comment that would
be dictionaries
and now we'll create
a dictionary
for that we will write the syntax name
of the dictionary
equal to
curly braces
first we'll write the key value
then colon
and the value corresponding to it
will write Apple
then separated by comma
and then the second key value colon
and the value corresponding to that key
that would be orange
when it would be separated by comma then
we'll assign another key value that
would be 3 colon
and
the value corresponding to that would be
banana
comma
next put
the key value would be 4 colon and in
inverted commas we'll write the value
corresponding to it
and to print this dictionary
print take one and execute this command
here we can see that the dictionary is
printed
with one key value we have the
corresponding value apple with two key
value we have the corresponding value
orange with three key value as the
corresponding value banana and with four
key value we have the corresponding
value
now to access a particular element
we can't do that in dictionary but we
can access a particular value with the
help of key we can do that in dictionary
for that we would write the syntax print
the name of the dictionary
and in
square brackets we'll write the key
value that would be one and run the
command would get the value
corresponding to the key value
that is Apple that is corresponding to
the key value 1.
now we will see a get method in
dictionary for that we'll write the
command print
name of the dictionary dot get
and in round brackets we'll just write
the key value
and run this command we'll get the
corresponding value to the key value
that is Apple
now we will use another method that
would be pop for that we'll write the
command print
dick1 dot pop and in round brackets
we'll write the key value
for the value
we want the element to be removed from
the dictionary
we will execute this command and we get
query as the output now if you print the
dictionary
print deck 1
we can see that the fourth key value and
the value corresponding to that key
value has been removed by the Poke
method
now
we can also print the length of the
dictionary for that we'll write the
command print
Len
and in round brackets we'll write the
name of the dictionary
and just execute the command you will
get 3 as the output as it has been
considered one unit second unit and
third unit so the length is 3. and we
have another method that is sorted for
that to write the command print
sorted and the name of the dictionary
next one will execute this command
it would give us all the key values in a
sorted manner
when executed with this command
now we can see another method that is
case for that we have to write the
command print
round brackets name of the dictionary
Dot
keys
round brackets and we'll run this
command and we'll get all the keys that
are present in dictionary
there is another method that is values
for that we'll write the command print
dick one dot values
round brackets and we'll execute this
command we'll get all the values that
are present in the dictionary now we'll
see another method that is update that
is used to update the particular value
corresponding to the key value or update
the dictionary with more values to be
inserted in the dictionary for that
we'll write the command dict1 Dot
update
in round brackets first we will write
the curly braces
the key value
semicolon colon
and corresponding to that we'll write
its value which you want to update
watermelon
and will also
print the dictionary
you will execute this command
we will get that the second value that
is watermelon that's been updated
previously it was orange and now it's
watermelon
so it's been updated by this command and
we can also use this command to add more
elements to the dictionary
for that we'll write the syntax dict1
dot update
round brackets curly braces and the key
value colon and corresponding to that we
will write the value
musk melon
and we will print the dictionary
and we'll execute this command
sorry we just
commented the name of the dictionary
date one dot update now we'll execute
this command
here we can see that the value has been
added to the dictionary
now we'll see another method that is pop
for that we'll write the command Direct
One Dot pop and in round brackets the
key value
for which we want the value to be
removed from the dictionary and we will
print the dictionary
and execute this command here we can see
that the second key value has been
removed from the dictionary
and we will see another method that
would be ticked one
dot pop item
and then we will print the dictionary
and execute the command here we can see
that the pope item has removed the last
element from the dictionary and we are
left with only two elements in the
dictionary
now we will see some Loops in the
for that we'll write the command for
X in the name of the dictionary that is
State One colon
and then we will write print
date one
and in square brackets
the variable X and we'll execute this
command
so with this Loop we can print all the
values corresponding to the key values
in the dictionary now to print both the
key and values corresponding to it we
can run a loop for that we'll write the
command for x comma y
n
dict1
dot items
colon
print
X comma y
and run this command we can get the key
and the values corresponding to it
now if you want to copy the particular
dictionary in another dictionary you can
write the command
first you will name the dictionary you
want to create and copy the elements we
will name it as mydect
equal to
now we'll write the command dict one dot
copy
and then
we will print the new dictionary
that is
my date
and we'll run this command
okay we have not inserted the wrong
bracket here now then this command here
we can see that we have printed the
mydic dictionary and it has the same
values as stick to one
now we'll see another method
to delete
the whole dictionary
for that we'll write
one
Dot clear
it would remove all the values from the
dictionary and also
print the dictionary after that
run this command here we can see all the
elements from the dictionary have been
removed try giving a short to Simply
lens postgraduate program in Ai and
machine learning in collaboration with
the IBM the course link is mentioned in
the description box below that will
navigate you to the course page where
you can find a complete audio of the
program being offered
okay so I'm on my jupyter notebook first
of all let's rename our notebook to
looping techniques
okay
I'll just increase the
size all right
okay so let's see how you can arrange
the values in a list using for loops
with python sorted function so I'll
create a variable called num
and
I'll assign a list let's say it has
values to 5 10
I'm taking just random values
let's say 36
50 and 49.
so this is my list now I want to arrange
the
items in this list
in either ascending or descending order
so for that I can use a for Loop I'll
say for I which is my iterator variable
in
and after this I'm going to use the
python sorted function
and inside the function I'll pass in my
variable which is num
then I'll give a colon and say print I
so let's
hit shift enter to run it okay
you can see here
so python by default
has sorted the elements in the list in
ascending order so we have 2 4 5 10 10
36 49 50 and 50.
now let's learn how you can sort the
values in a list using a for Loop in
descending order
so
I'll just
copy my above cell of code we'll paste
it here it will help
save us some time
so I'll say for I
insorted
I have given my variable num
after this
I'm going to pass in another parameter
called reverse
equal to I'll say true
the reverse equal to True will make sure
python will sort the list in descending
order
if I run it you can see the difference
we have
sorted the elements in the list num in
descending order now so we have 50 50 49
36 10 5 4 and 2.
okay so this is one of the techniques
that you can use to sort the elements in
a list using a for Loop
now similarly you can also sort string
elements alphabetically in the list and
ascending a descending order
so for that I'll create a variable
called players let me just scroll down
then I'll create a list
which will have the names of football
players let's say we have Messi
then let's say we have
Ronaldo
then we have
Salah
and then we have let's say Harry
okay
I'm gonna say for I in
my function sorted
I'll say players
I'll give a comma and again use reverse
equal to true
so this is going to sort the items in my
list players in descending order of
the alphabets
then I'll give a colon and say
print I
let me run it you can see here
the names of the different football
players have been sorted in descending
order of alphabets so we have S
appearing first then R M and H so Salah
Ronaldo Messi and Harry
all right now let's move ahead
now we are going to create a dictionary
of key value Pairs and sort it
so I'll create a dictionary called d
which will have
a few key value pairs so my first key is
f and the value is let's say 1. then my
second key let's say is B
and the value is 4
give a comma
my next key is a and the value is let's
say three
after that my next key is e
and the value is let's say nine
and finally we have our last key which
is C and the value is 2.
now to sort this dictionary I'll say for
I in
sorted
I'm going to use the items method I'll
say sorted D dot items
and then we'll print I
let me run it and show you the result
you can see it here
our dictionary has been sorted in
ascending order of the dictionary keys
so we have a b then C there is no D here
after that we have e and then f
cool
now you can also sort the
keys and values separately let me just
copy this and I'll show you
I'll paste it here and instead of d dot
items I'll just say d dot keys
if I run it you can see here we have
sorted only the
keys in my dictionary
now to sort the values instead of items
you can just write values
and here you can see we have
sorted the values in the dictionary D in
ascending order again so we have one two
three four and nine
all right
now we will understand how to use the
reverse function in Loops to reverse the
item seller list
so I'll again
create my
list called players which will have
messy
let's say again the next pair is Ronaldo
and then we have
Salah and then we have Harry
okay
now to
reverse the elements in this list called
players I'll say for I in
then I'll use the Reversed function and
pass in my list called players
give a colon and then say print I
let's run it here you can see
we have reversed the
elements in my list called players so we
have Harry first then Salah Ronaldo and
Messi in the end cool
now moving ahead
we'll see how to use the filter function
in Loop and filter specific elements in
a list based on some conditions now to
give the condition we'll be using an
anonymous function in Python that is
often called as the Lambda function
to do this I am going to create a list
called Animals
I'll give my square brackets and inside
the square brackets
I am going to
passing the elements in the form of a
dictionary
so to pass in a dictionary we need to
have key value pairs
so my first key is name
let's see
my animal is
dogs
I'll give a comma
then my next key is the age let's say
dog's age is 11.
so this is my first
list element which has been passed in
the form of a dictionary
I'll create another curly bracket and
will have the same keys this time let's
see
my animal is lion
let's make it dog instead of dogs
okay
give a comma and then say
each
let's see the age of the line is 30.
we'll give a comma
we'll go to the next line
and this time
we are going to have another animal
I'll see
elephant
give a comma
let's see the edges
I'll give a comma
then we'll have our final
element in the list
let's say the name of the
animal is leopard
give a comma
then we'll have the ease of the leopard
let's say
the age is 18.
so we have our list ready
now
using a for Loop
will filter
the elements in the list giving a
specific condition let me show you
so I'll write for animals in I'm going
to use the filter function
and inside the filter function I'll
give
an anonymous function called Lambda
I'll say Lambda I colon
I of
h
if it is divisible by 2
so I'll say each
divided by 2 equal to equal to 0
give a comma
then we will
print that animal
give a colon
I'll say print animals
so what I am doing here is
I'm using the filter function and
passing my condition that is if the age
of the animal is divisible by 2 then
print the animal
or just print the list rest
we don't need
all right
now let me run it
it says there is an
invalid syntax let me debug it
okay there is a spelling mistake here in
Lambda this would be
mbda okay now we'll run it there you go
so here
in the list that we had created
only the age of lion and leopard were
divisible by 2 so 30 and 18 by divisible
by 2
so python printed us only those two
elements in the list the rest it ignored
11 and 63 are not divided by 2 so we did
not get dog and elephant cool
so this is another interesting looping
technique where you can use filter as
well as an anonymous Lambda function
all right
now in the next example we'll see how to
remove items in a list using a while
loop so so far we have been using only
four Loops now we are going to see a few
examples
using while loop okay
I'm going to create a variable called
country so this variable will hold a
list of elements of the different
country names I'll say India
let's see my second country is
Canada
and let's see my third country I have is
Brazil
my
fourth country I have is Japan
and then we have let's say Israel
okay
now
I'll use a while loop so I'll say while
my list that is country
then
to remove the elements in the list I am
going to use the pop function so I'll
say
print country
dot I'll say pop and I'll pass
-1 as the parameter so that
it removes the elements
from the
end of the list if I
run it you can see here we have Israel
Japan Brazil Canada and India now you
can just print country
you can see here since we have removed
all the elements from
my list country there is no element left
here so it gives us an empty list
cool
now let me show you how you can use
while Loops in just one line
so for that I'll create a variable
called num
and I'll assign a value of 10.
I'll say while
num is
greater than 0
I'll say num
equal to num minus 1
I'll give a
semicolon this time and then I'll say
print num let's run it you can see it
here we have printed nine eight seven
six up to zero
so in the first iteration my num value
was 10
so 10 greater than 0 was true so we
decrease the value of num by 1 so num
became 9 and we printed nine in the
second iteration num which was 9
was greater than 0 then we decreased or
reduced num by 1 again so it became 8
then we printed it
and the loop continued till we reached
zero cool
now had this condition been num
equal to num plus 1 or num plus equal to
1 the loop would have run for infinite
number of times
all right
now I'll
show you an example how to run an
infinite Loop
so I'll say while
true
I'll create a variable called num
now this num would be a user input a
user integer input actually
I'll pass in the message as enter and
integer
give a colon followed by a space
and then we'll see
print
the
product
of
I'll give a comma say num
I'll give another comma
I'll say
is
now we'll pass in our
multiplication I want to
multiply any user given number by 5. so
I'll say 5 multiplied by
num
okay let's run it and see here enter
integer if I say let's say 3 so 3
multiplied by 5 is 15 the product of 3
here I can change the message as
multiplied
by 5
you can say is
okay now let's run it
okay so let's say I enter my integer as
3 I have the message the product of 3
multiplied by 5 is 15.
let's enter another value 10
the product is 50 let's say I have 20
the product is 100. let's see I am
taking
35 multiplied by 5 is 175 so this Loop
will continue until and unless you don't
interrupt it
so I'm going to interrupt my
kernel
to stop executing this Loop
okay now we are going to explore the
enumerate function in Python but before
that let me tell you what enumerate
function is
so the enumerate method or the function
in Python allows us to number list
indices of the items as they are coming
out of the array python will
automatically put this indices into a
tuple let me show you how it works
so I'll directly start with my for Loop
I'll say for I in
I'll use the enumerate keyword
and within
brackets I'll pass in my
elements in the form of list I'll say
the let's say then we have
Brown
the next word I have is for
let's see then we have jumped this is
basically a sentence broken down into
different words and those words we have
put
as elements in the list
the next word I have is the
give a comma I'll say
lazy
then we have
dog
give a comma
and finally we will have our full stop
or the period
okay then I'll give a colon and I'll say
print
I
now let me run it you can see here using
the enumerate function we have
given
the indices to the different items in my
list so it starts from 0 and goes till 8
so there are total nine elements in my
list
okay
now you can see here the result has been
printed in the form of a tuple or Tuple
I'll just copy the above code and paste
it here
now I'm going to replace IE with
key
and value
and
print also I'll see key comma value
let me show you the result you can see
here this time
it is no more a tuple
and here we have the indices and then we
have the
items so basically these indices have
now become the keys and
the items are the values
okay
now you can print
the different elements in the form of a
sentence let me show you how to do it
I'll just paste it here
and
instead of key I'll say value
and I'll use
the end parameter in the print statement
I'll say end equal to
give us peace
let's run it you can see here
okay this should be brown fox and not
for let's run it again
so we have the sentence the brown fox
jumped over the lazy dog okay
so similarly you can iterate through the
letters in a word or a string and print
the letters along with the indices
I'll declare a variable called company
and
this will have a value let's say simply
learn
I'll say for I comma J in
I'll use the
enumerate function
within brackets I'll say company
give a colon
then I'll say print
I comma G
let's see the result there you go so
here we have
indices assigned to the different
letters
in my word simply learn
okay
now moving ahead
so by default the index position starts
at 0 as I told you
now you can also mention the starting
index position using the start parameter
so what I'll do is
I'll copy my
above code
repeat it here now we are going to make
some changes I'll say for I in
enumerate company and then I'm going to
give my start parameter let's say I want
to start the index position at 10.
now if I print it
okay let's say print I
there you go here you can see
my first letter starts at index 10 then
we have 11. I'm at 12 P at 13 and
finally we have
the last letter which is n in simply
learn is that the 20th index cool okay
so now let's explore the zip function in
Python and how you can use it to Loop it
through two arrays at once
so the zip function returns a zip object
which is an iterator of tuples where the
first item in each past iterator is
paired together and then the second item
in each past iterator is paired together
and so on and so forth
so if the past iterators have different
lengths they iterated with the least
items decides the length of the new
iterator
let me
show you the first example that will
help you understand how the zip function
works so I have a list called first and
I have a
names of you
football players we have Lionel
then we have Cristiano
leave a comma and let's say we have
Muhammad
I'll declare another list called last
which will have
values like Messi then we have
Ronaldo basically the
surnames
of Lionel Cristiano and Muhammad then we
have Salah
I'll write my for Loop I'll say for I in
my zip function or the method I'll pass
in first comma last which are my
List names I'll say print
I
let me run it you can see here using the
zip function we have
I treat it through both the less so we
have Lionel Messi Cristiano Ronaldo and
then Mohamed Salah
all right
now you can combine the elements of
three lists as well
so I'll just paste the code here and
we'll create another list called num
and this is going to be a list of
numbers
let's say 7 and 8 okay
now here I'll say for I
IN Zip first last and num print I
if I run it you see the result here it
has zipped only the
first three items in the list first last
and num so we have
three items printed
okay
now coming to the final section of this
demo on looping techniques in Python
we'll explore about
zip underscore longest
so Python's iterator tool or iter tool
is a module that provides various
functions that work on iterators to
produce complex iterators so iterators
in Python is an object that can iterate
through sequence data types such as list
Tuple string and so on
so the zip underscore longest iterator
falls under terminating iterators it
prints the values of the eye tables
alternatively in sequence if one of the
iterables is printed fully the remaining
values are filled with the values
assigned in the fill value parameter
so to use this function called zip
underscore longest we need to
import zip longest from the IIT tools
module so I'll say from
either tools import
zip underscore longest
okay
then I'll
create my
first list
I'll say
let me go to the top and copy the
elements because we are going to use the
same elements again
I'll paste it here
okay
and let's say I'll give a comma and we
are going to
and I'm again going to use the
three elements okay
now I'll create another list called last
and we're going to copy the items from
the top
paste it here
and now I'll say for let me just scroll
down
I in
zip underscore
longest
within brackets I'll say first comma
last
we are going to print I
let me run it and show you the result
this should be zip underscore longest
okay you can see the result here
for the first
three items it has printed Lionel Messi
Cristiano Ronaldo and Mohamed Salah
which you can see here but for the last
three items in the first list it has
given us because there were no values
now to overcome this problem you can use
a parameter called fill value
let me just copy this
and I'll paste it here
and the only change that I'm going to do
here is
I'm going to say
we'll give a comma
I'll use the parameter called fill value
equal to I'll say any
if I run it you can see here
for the last three now we have whatever
we have defined within field value
parameter you can change this to let's
say
not defined
there you go
all right
so these were some of the interesting
examples that we implemented using
looping techniques in Python
so we are going to look at what is the
function in Python then we'll see the
different types of python functions
then we will understand the various
advantages of using python functions and
finally we'll head out to our jupyter
notebook to understand python functions
in detail with Hands-On demonstrations
okay
so what is the function in Python
so a function is a bunch of statements
that are defined to perform specific
operations a function in Python helps to
divide your program into smaller and
modular chunks thus allowing you to make
extensive programs more organized and
manageable it also avoids repetition and
makes the code reusable
so let's understand the types of python
functions first we have built-in
functions so these are the functions
that are built into python
so by default the inbuilt functions are
available in Python then we have user
defined functions so functions defined
by users to carry out certain tasks are
called user defined functions they don't
have a fixed name
so here on this slide you can see the
different built-in python functions that
are available so you have power length
next Max absolute we have print range
slice sorted Round And there are many
more so these we will explore in our
demo session
so wait for a while
now
let's understand about the user defined
functions so these functions are defined
by users to perform specific tasks
and these are the steps that you need
to create a user defined function so
first you need to create the function
and then call the function
now moving to the next slide so here you
can see the syntax of writing a user
defined function so we use the def
keyword to define the function followed
by the function name and within brackets
you have the parameters or the arguments
of the function then you have the
function block and if you want to return
a value from the function you can use
the return function followed by the
expression
so here is an example where we are just
printing hello python using a user
defined function and in this case my
function name is called my underscore
function if I call my underscore
function it will return me hello python
cool
okay now let's understand the advantages
of using
python functions
so with the help of functions you can
avoid rewriting the same logic or code
again and again in a program
so in Python you can call functions
anywhere multiple times in a single
program
you can also track an extensive Python
program easily when it is divided into
multiple functions
and the most crucial feature or the
advantages of python functions is that
of its reusability
cool now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll explore the inbuilt
and user defined functions in detail
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook
first I'll go ahead and rename my
notebook as functions in
python
I click on rename okay
first of all let me just increase the
size
okay
I'll give my comment as
built-in functions
okay
so we'll start by looking at the
absolute function in Python
so absolute or ABS function Returns the
absolute value of a number
so I'll say let's say e equal to
I'll use the absolute
function which is represented as ABS in
Python suppose I write abs of let's say
10.75
and if I print a it gives me 10.75 which
is fair enough
let me just copy this code I'll paste it
here
I'll say b equal to APS
this time I am going to use the
negative symbol or the negative sign
I'll say minus 10.75 and will print B
let me run it you can see here python is
automatically removed the negative sign
and it has just given us 10.75 so this
is how the absolute function works so
ABS Returns the absolute value of a
number which is always positive
now let's see another inbuilt function
very popular which is called the length
function or Len just give a comment
saying Len
above also let me just give a comment as
APS
okay
so later we can have a track of whatever
functions we have learned in the demo
so the length function Returns the
length of an object it could be an eye
table such as a list it could be a tuple
or even a dictionary let me show you how
it works I'll say list one equal to
I'll create a list within square
brackets let's say
I have
a few letters
let's say
i n then I have d
I again
and a so I have
all the letters in my word India now if
I say x equal to
Len of list one
then I'll print X it gives me 5 because
the length of all the characters in my e
list is five You Can Count here I and d
i a
so there are only five elements and
hence it is written as five
now we'll explore another function which
is called as all
so the all function returns true if any
item in an I triple object is true
so I'll say
my underscore list equal to let's say I
have 0 1 and 0.
I'll say x equal to then I'll use the
all function
and inside the function I'll pass in my
list which is my underscore list and
will print X
hold on for a second and can you please
guess what this
X will be
it gives us false the reason being
we have
two false values 0 and 0 here and there
is only one true value which is one
suppose I had one one and one
if I run this it would have given us
true because all the elements in my list
or the I triple are true
if any one of the elements is false it
will give us false
okay
now moving to our next function which is
called sum
so python sum function is used to get
the sum of numbers of an iterable
let's say I have
s equal to
I'm using the function sum and inside
the sum function I am going to declare a
list of numbers let's say we have 20 35
and let's say 70
let me create another
list called S1
I'll say sum
and now
let's see we'll pass in a tuple now so I
am using another bracket we have let's
say 7 5 and 9. now if I write print
s and let's say I want to print S1
you can see here my sum function has
returned the sum of all the numbers in
the I triple the first one was a list
and next we have a tuple so 20 plus 35
plus 70 is 125 and then 7 plus 5 plus 9
is 21. so this is how the sum function
works
now moving ahead we have the Max
function next
as well as the mean function
so as the name suggests the max function
will return the maximum number of an eye
table
so I'll create a variable called M1
and I'll use the max function
let's say we have a few values 7 10
3 12 61 and
now let's go ahead and print M1
now if I run it
it returns me the maximum number that is
present inside my list of numbers or the
Tuple that I have passed in
here you have the maximum number as 61.
now let's use the max function over a
dictionary so I'll create another
variable called M2 and I'll say Max
and inside the max function I'm going to
pass in my values in the form of a
dictionary so I'm using curly brackets
or braces I'll say let's say 7 90 we
have three let's say 150
67 and 44. okay
now let me go ahead and print M2
if I run it you can see it here it has
given us 50 which is the highest element
in my
dictionary
okay
now similarly you can use the main
function let me just copy this
and I'll paste it here
I'll say M3 instead of Max function we
are going to use the mean function so
the mean function will return the
minimum number in an iterable
let's see I'll pass in
M3 as a
list this time and if I say print M3 it
gives me 3 which is the lowest number of
the lowest value in my list
and similarly you can
have the lowest value printed from a
dictionary I'll just change the variable
to M4 and instead of Max we'll use the
Min function
and here also I'll use the
variable as M4 if I run it you can see
here
we have printed the minimum value in my
dictionary which is 3.
okay now moving ahead we'll explore
another function called
iter
so python iter function returns an
iterator for the given object so the
iter function creates an object which
can be iterated one element at a time
and the next function Returns the next
item in an iterator let's use both iter
and next function in our next example
so I'll create a list called my list
and as equal to
followed by using the iter function and
inside the item function I'm going to
pass in a list which will have letters
of India
I have n
d
I and then I have a
now I'll create another variable called
X
and then I'll pass in the next function
and inside the next function I'll pass
in my list and we'll go ahead and print
X
so it will print the first element in my
itable that is I here
and if I copy this
and I'll
paste it here if I run it again
you can see it here the iter function
Returns the
second I triple which is n in my list i
n d i a
I'll paste it again if I run it we have
the
third item in the list which is d
ok
now coming to using the
power function in Python so python pow
or the power function Returns the power
of the given numbers let's say x raised
to the power 3.
so I'll
declare a variable X1 and say pow
let's say I want
the value of 3 raised to the power 3
and let's say I have another variable
called X2
I'll use the pow function and this time
I want to know what is 2 raised to power
4.
we'll go ahead and print X1 and X2
and as you guessed it 3 raised to the
power 3 or 3 cube is 27 and 2 raised to
the power 4 is 16.
cool
now coming to using the range function
so the python range function returns a
sequence of numbers starting from 0 and
increments by 1 so this is by default
and stops before the given number
so let me show you
if I say x equal to I'll use the range
function and inside the range function
I'll have my value as 6. then I'll say
for n
now here n is my iterator variable I'll
say for n in x
print n
let's run it and we'll see the result
you can see here the range function as
returned as the
number starting from 0 and it has
gradually incremented the iterator by 1
so we have from 0 till 5.
now I'll show you another example
I want to change
the default starting value that is 0 so
I'll save x equal to range I'm going to
start from 40
till 50
with a step size of 2 so you can pass it
as the third argument so it will Skip
One value and print the next value so
then I'll say for n
in X I'll give a colon
let's print n and we'll see the result
you can see here it starts with 40 and
has a step size of 2 so we have 40
42 44 46 and 48 cool
now let's move ahead and we'll explore
the round function in Python so the
round function rounds off a number to
the given number of digits
let's say I have x equal to I'll use the
round function
and then I'll have a decimal value let's
say
8.624
and I want to round it to two decimal
places
let's print X
if I run it you can see here my python
has returned a rounded up value to two
decimal places so we have
8.62 and the rest it has just skipped
foreign
moving ahead we'll explore the
sorted function in Python so the sorted
function returns a sorted list of the
specified either object you can specify
ascending or descending order
so I'll create a list called a
and we have
the elements let's say again India so I
have I
n
d
I
and I have a again
if I say x equal to
sorted a and
if I print X
you can see it here python has sorted
the elements in the list in
ascending order of the letters so we
have a appearing first then D again I
and I and then finally we have n now
suppose you wanted to print the letters
in descending order you can use another
argument here I'll give a comma and say
reverse
equal to true
so this
line will ensure
my list is sorted in descending order
you can see it here it has just reversed
the above result so we have n appearing
first and I I D and E
you can do the same for a list of
numbers let's say we have 12 50
let's say 27
80 and 5.
I'll say x equal to
sorted a and will print X
if I run it you see it here we have
sorted the numbers in the list in
ascending order now if you want to
sort it in descending order just add
reverse equal to true
there you go here
my list has now been sorted in
descending order of elements
now we are going to look at the final
built-in python function which is slice
so the slice function returns a portion
of an iterable as an object of the slice
class based on the specified range
suppose I have
a list called a
okay let's not Define a list we'll
Define our Tuple
so this has
the letters
in the word simply load
so I have s i m
p
l
I
again l
I have e
comma I have a
then we have R and finally I have n
so these are the letters which have been
represented as a tuple
simply loan then I'll use the slice
function
and
I'll give my range as 5 and will print
a of x
let's run it you see it here
the slice function has sliced the first
five elements in my Tuple so we have s i
m p and l
cool
so we have explored
all the important
built-in python functions now let's head
over to using
user defined functions or learning user
defined functions in Python I'll give a
comment first user defined functions
cool
so as we had learned in our slides
to define a user defined function we
will use the def keyword
and
a function name this should be a valid
python name so I'm using func one
followed by parenthesis and then we'll
have a colon
and now we'll Define the body of the
function I'll say
print
hello world this is the same example
that we had
C in in our
slide
now I am going to call the function
using the function name which is
fun C1 if I run it you can see it here I
have my message printed hello world so
this is a very simple user defined
function and it does not
carry any arguments or parameters
now let me show you another
user defined function I'll say def
hello
again we are not giving any parameter to
this function or arguments to this
function
I'll say name equal to
Str this time we are going to take the
input from the user so I am using the
input function I'll say
enter your
country name
I'll give a
colon and a space
and then we'll say
print
I'll print the message hello
followed by a space
give a plus sign
and we are going to convert our name to
string
so this is my function let me run it now
I'll call hello
it is asking me for
entering country name I'll say Japan
if I hit enter it says hello then my
country name which is Japan so hello
Japan
let me run it again this time I'll say
USA
I'll hit enter you can see here my
message is hello USA
cool
now moving ahead to our next example
where we'll see
using functions with different
parameters
so we'll start with a very simple
example
I'll say
def I want to convert
feet to centimeter
I'll see my function name as FD
underscore 2 underscore CM so I'll pass
in a
value for feed and that feed will be
converted to centimeters
and this time inside parenthesis I'm
going to pass in
my parameter as ft
I'll use the formula for centimeter I'll
see
my variable centimeter equal to
feet
multiplied by
30.48
so 1 feet is actually
30.48 centimeters so centimeter becomes
feet into 30.48
then we are going to use the return
keyword and I am going to return the
output which is
centimeter
let's run it
now to call the function I'll use my
function name which is Ft underscore 2
underscore CM this is my function name
and then I am going to pass in a
value for feed let's say I want to
convert 6 feet into centimeters if I run
it there you go you can see it here six
feet is actually
182.88 centimeters let's say
5.8
if I run it it is
176.784 centimeters
so here you saw how to pass in arguments
to a user defined function
again you can pass in multiple arguments
let's say
I am going to find the sum of two values
for that I'll create a function called
EF
my function name is ADD I'm going to add
two values X and Y
so I am passing in two parameters X
comma y
I'll create a variable called sum that
will store the value of x plus y
and then let's print some
okay let me just scroll down
I'll hit shift enter to run it okay we
have created my function
that is ADD now let's add 40 and
50.
you have to pass in two arguments
because we have declared
X and Y in the function so it needs at
least two arguments if I run it you have
the sum of 40 and 50 which is 90.
let's say I have
minus 20 and
30. if I run it you have the result
minus 20 plus 30 is 10.
all right
now similarly you can also multiply two
numbers let me just
copy this
I'll
paste it here
and instead of ADD
I'll give my user defined function name
as
multiply
I'll say
product equal to X
asterisks Y and I'll print
product let's run it
I'll call my function using the function
name multiply let's say 4
multiplied by 6.
so the result is 24. cool
now moving ahead
we'll explore another example let's say
I want to print the absolute value of a
number
so I am creating a function called def
my function name is absolute and I'll
pass in
one parameter which is X
I'm going to use
ifel's statement I'll say if x is
greater than or equal to 0
we'll give a colon
then I'll say return X
else
give a colon
and say return
minus X
and run it
now if I print
absolute
of let's say
the result is as expected since 56 is
greater than 0 we have just returned 56
let me just copy this
I'll paste it here let's say absolute of
minus 56 is again 56 because we are
returning minus X so minus of minus 56
becomes plus 56 now if you wanted to
return minus 56 you need to
make some modifications I'll put another
minus and keep this within brackets let
me run the function again
and now if I print absolute of minus 56
you have the result as minus 56.
okay
now let's see another example how to
find the factorial of a number using
a user defined function so we'll Define
our function as def I'll use the
function name as factorial
I am going to pass in a
parameter called X I'll say if x is
equal to equal to 0
then we'll just return X or return one
I'll say else
give a colon
return
I'll say X
asterisks are multiplied by I'll use the
function name factorial
I'll say x minus 1.
now let's run it
I'll call my function
factorial
let's say I want to find the factorial
of 5 the result is 120 let's say the
factorial of 10 the result is
36 lakhs 28 800
cool
now let's see how you can pass in
default arguments to your function or
default parameters
okay
suppose I have
a function defined called welcome
here I am going to pass my argument
as name and
in the argument itself I'll pass in the
value or default value let's say Paul
give a colon and I'll print
hello
this would be within quotes
and the name
cool let me just run it
now I'm going to call the function
welcome
this time I'm not giving any value to my
function if I run it it has
automatically taken the default argument
which was Paul so my message becomes
hello Paul
now
let's say I'll pass in a value
welcome
and within quotes I'll say receipt
now the message becomes hello racy so if
you pass in a value to your
function welcome explicitly it will take
that value instead of the default
argument
cool
now you can also have multiple arguments
in your
function as we saw above
for the addition and multiplication
functions
I'll create a function called
message
and we'll have
the arguments as name one name to and
name three
give a colon
I'll say print
a message that is
hello
you give us peace give a comma
we have name one
give a comma and then I'll say
comma please
tell
Q another comma
I'll have my name to
give a comma
followed by the message that
I have name three this should be a comma
instead of a period
then I'll see is waiting
make sure this is within quotations
again
just give a exclamation mark
okay
so I have my message let's run it
now I'll call my function
message
we need the arguments now so I'll pass
in three names let's say my first name
is Gilly
my second name is Rachel
and my third name is let's say Shaw
I'll run it and you can see here we have
my message printed hello followed by
name one which is Kelly so hello Gilly
please tell name two which is Rachel so
please tell Rachel that name 3 which is
sure that saw is waiting cool
now we'll understand about
scope of variables in a function
now your scope could be a global scope
or a local scope
let's define a function called funk
.
inside the function I am going to create
a variable called Z which has a value of
7. now I'll just print
Z and I'll call in my function
if I run it you have the value printed
of Z that is 7 now if I want to access
my variable that is z outside the
function if I run this it throws me an
error because this variable Z was
defined locally that is inside the
function and you cannot access Z outside
the function
now to overcome this issue let me just
copy this
we are going to declare Z as a global
variable
so I'll have Z outside the function I'll
say
Z equal to 7 and then I have
my function defined I just change the
name of the function to
function 4 and then we'll
print Z and I'll call the function
function 4 if I run it
you can see it here I have the value of
Z printed that is 7 now if I want to
access Z outside the function then also
it's fine because we have defined Z
outside the function that is z is now a
global variable so its scope is
throughout the function
now another thing to note here is you
can't change the value from inside a
local scope
so if I say Z equal to 7
and then I'll Define my function f u and
C let's say 5.
I'll give a colon and I'll see let's see
I want to alter the value of Z to let's
say Z Plus 7.
I'll print Z
and let me now call
Fu and C5
if I
run this it throws me an error as I said
it says local variable Z referenced
before assignment so you can't change
its value from inside a local scope for
that you're going to explicitly Define
the variable Z AS Global let me show you
how to do it I've just copied this code
and paste it here I'll say Z equal to 7
I'll Define my function let's say f u
and C 6
here I am going to say
global
C
so I have explicitly defined my Z as a
global variable now if I
call the function six you can see here
we have altered the value of Z from 7 to
Z plus 1 that is 7 plus 1 which is 8.
okay
now Asterix arcs in function definitions
in Python are used to pass a variable
number of arguments to a function
suppose you don't know the exact number
of arguments you need so you can use
the argument with an asterisk symbol let
me show you how to do it
I'll say Def
welcome
and here I am going to pass in asterisks
followed by the
name of my argument which is names
I'll say print
I'll print my message as hello
comma
then I am going to say
names
the first name
which is with
index value of 0
comma followed by your space
then I have
name
one
I'll give a
comma followed by a space and then we'll
have names
two
they should be names
okay
let me run this now I'll call my
function welcome
now you can see here I have passed in my
argument that is names three times so
let's
call
three names Let's see we have Steve then
we have
Bill and then we have let's say yes
now if I run this
there you go we have a message printed
hello Steve Bill yes
okay now coming to the final section of
our demo here we are going to find out
the area of a circle and a spear so we
are going to Define two functions one
for Circle and another for spear so
first of all let me Define the value of
pi which is 3.14
I'll start
with def I'll
give my
function name as circle area
and inside that I'll pass in my argument
that is radius
I'll give a colon and we are going to
return the area of a circle which is pi
R square so I'll have
radius
again an asterisk symbol and then radius
so this becomes Pi into radius into
radius which is pi R square
okay now let's define another function
called EF I'll say
spear
area
I'll have my
argument as radius
and give a colon and say
return
4 Pi R square which is the area of a
sphere so I'll have 4 multiplied by pi
multiplied by
radius multiplied by radius so this
becomes 4 Pi R square
now we are going to Define
the mean function so I'll say define
mean
where we'll just have
a print statement so I'll say print
Circle
area
with
radius
15.
I'll give a comma
and see
circle area
which is my function name
and we'll pass in the value of the
radius which is 15
I'll just copy this message
and we'll print it here I'll see
spear area
with radius 15 is
I'll just change this to spear
and let's say we'll have radius for 10
instead of 15
okay
finally I am going to call my main
function so I'll just say
mean
now let's run it
okay there is one error here
is an indentation problem now we'll run
it again there you go so the circle area
with radius 15 is
3.14 which is the pi value multiplied by
radius into radius that is 15 into 15 so
the value is
706.5 and similarly the sphere area with
radius 10 is 4 into 3.14 into 10 into 10
that is
all right
so what is the Lambda function
a Lambda function is one of the simplest
ways to define a function in Python a
Lambda function is an anonymous function
defined without a name and does not have
the def keyword
it can accept any number of arguments
but can only have one expression so the
function is always defined using the
Lambda keyword which you can see it here
so here we have the Syntax for Lambda
function we use the Lambda keyword
followed by the arguments and then we
have a colon after that we have the
expression that we want to evaluate
cool
now moving ahead let's look at an
example of using Lambda function in
Python
now if you were to add two numbers in
Python using a function you would
ideally use the def keyword followed by
the function name and then pass in the
arguments you can see the arguments here
A and B
then
use the return statement to get the
value of the addition so we have written
a plus b
and finally you will call the add
function and pass the argument values to
get the result
now this operation can be done using the
Lambda function as shown here so we have
defined a variable called add which is
equal to and then we have used the
Lambda function followed by the two
parameters or arguments so here A and B
are the arguments and then I have my
Expression A plus b see all this you can
do it in one line
and then to call the function you use
print
followed by the variable which is ADD
and then you have the arguments 3 comma
8 so the addition of 3 plus 8 would be
11. now you can see that instead of
using the DF keyword we have used the
Lambda keyword and there is no
parenthesis required anything after the
Lambda keyword is treated as a parameter
or argument
so
we use a colon to separate parameters
and the expression in our case the
expression is a plus b
now moving ahead we'll look at
the pros and cons of
Lambda functions so Lambda functions are
suitable for simple logical operations
so when we want one expression in return
we can use the Lambda function now
Lambda function is used as a parameter
to different functions such as map
filter reduce we will see all this in
our demo session
now coming to the cons of using a Lambda
function so Lambda functions can only
evaluate one expression as I told you
earlier
you cannot write a doc string to explain
all the inputs operations and outputs as
you would do in a normal user defined
function that uses the DF keyword and
finally Lambda functions are generally
not preferred when you have to declare a
function with multiple lines of code
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook where we will learn about
Lambda functions and how to use it in
different ways
so I am on my jupyter notebook let me
just go ahead and will
rename the notebook as
Lambda
functions in Python
okay I'll just click on rename
cool first of all I'll write a
General user defined function using the
def keyword let's say I want to add two
numbers
so this example we have already seen in
our slide
so the way to do is I'll use the DF
keyword followed by the function name
and then I'm giving my arguments or the
parameters after that
let's say I want to store
the addition of a plus b in a variable
called result so I'll say result equal
to e plus p
and then
I want to return my output that is
result so I'll say return result
so this is how you'll normally create a
function in Python
if I run it and then
I'm going to call my function using the
function name that is ADD and then I'll
pass in
my parameters A and B let's say my e is
3 and B is 4.
if I run this
I will get the result 7 which is fair
enough
now if I want to
do the same operation using
a Lambda function I would do something
like this let's say I'll create a
variable called add and then I'm going
to use the
Lambda function
followed by the arguments a comma p
then I'll give a colon and say A Plus P
after that I'll just say add
and then pass in my parameters
3 comma 4 if I run it you have the same
result that is 7.
now let's see another example using
Lambda functions to add a number this
time I am going to pass in only one
argument
so I'll say add equal to
Lambda
my argument is X I'll say x colon X Plus
let's say I want to add x width 100.
I'll say
print
add let's say I want to add 50 with 100
if I run it I have the result 150.
all right
now in Python there is no need to assign
a Lambda to a variable you can directly
call it let me show you how to do it
I'll say
Lambda
a comma B which are my arguments
again
this time I'm going to use
a multiplication
operator
since I want to do a product of A and B
and after that
using another parenthesis you can
directly pass in the arguments so there
is
no need to explicitly assign a Lambda to
a variable
so if I want to find the product of
let's say 15 comma 30
if I run it I have the result 40.
let's change the arguments let's say I
want to find the product of 5 comma 7.
the answer is 35.
so this is known as an immediately
invoked function expression or iife
which is often pronounced as if he
you can also use keyword arguments using
Lambda functions let me show you what I
mean
I'll create
my Lambda function and assign it to a
variable called Product I'll say
Lambda
let's say my arguments are x y and z
after that I'll give a colon and say X
multiplied by y multiplied by Z
next I'll see print
my variable that is product
and here I am going to use keyword
arguments so I'll say let's say
Z equal to 5.
x equal to 10 and y equal to 4.
you can see here
this need not be in an order as you have
defined the arguments
if I run this I have the result the
product of 5 multiplied by 10 multiplied
by 4 is 200.
now you can also
use default arguments
suppose I say add equal to I'll use the
Lambda function
and say x comma
why I am assigning a default
value of let's say 15 and Z let's say
I'll assign a default value of 24. then
I'll give my colon followed by the
expression that is X Plus y plus Z
now I'll say print
add
now here I am going to only pass in my
value for x since I've already given a
default value for argument y and z so my
function only needs
one argument that is X so let's say I
want X to be
20.
if I run this you see the result here so
20 plus 15 plus 24 is 59
now you can also use the asterisks
args parameter or args
so this allows you to Define as many
arguments as you want
so I'll say addition
equal to
Lambda
then I'll say asterisk ergs so this will
allow us to pass in as many arguments as
you want and I want to find the sum of
arcs so I'm using the inbuilt sum
function in Python
now I'll say print
my variable name that is addition
and let's say I want to find the sum for
four values or four arguments let's say
40 and let's say 50.
if I run it so the value is 112 So 20
plus 2 plus 40 plus 50 is 112.
cool
now Lambda functions are also used with
higher order functions which take one or
more functions as arguments
or return one or more functions let me
show you
so I'll Define a variable
called higher underscore ORD underscore
fun which stands for function and ORD
stands for order
so I'll declare my Lambda function
suppose the parameters are X
and then I have a
function
Then followed by a colon I have
expression as X Plus
function of x
now I'll see
higher underscore ORD underscore
f u n
and I'll pass in my two
arguments let's say my X is 20 and for
this
function
I'll have
a Lambda function defined I'll say
Lambda X colon
X multiplied by X
now
let me just run this and I'll show you
the result okay so what it did was
it added
my value of x that is
20 with
function of X or f u n of X what is f u
n of x f u n of X is
X multiplied by X so 20 multiplied by 20
is 400 so this becomes 400 plus X
which is 400 plus 20 hence the result is
420.
so this is known as a higher order
function
now let me show you another example
let's say I want to display order even
by
taking the value of x
I'll say Lambda X colon
here I am going to pass in my expression
if x
mod 2
give a space here
I'll say and
odd
or
even
now I'll give my
argument value let's say 30
the result is even because 30 is
divisible by 2
I'll just change this to let's say 15.
if I run it the answer is odd because 15
is not divisible by 2
let's say I have 150 the answer is even
now moving ahead
so let's write a Lambda function that
checks if a string is a substring of the
given string
so I'll create a variable called sub
underscore string
now I'll assign this variable with a
Lambda function I'll say Lambda
my
argument let's say string
I'll give the colon and pass in my
expression string in
let's say my string
has this message welcome to
python
functions tutorial
okay
so we are going to check
of a string let's say in two welcome
python Java anything whether it's
present inside the string which is
welcome to python functions tutorial
now let me go to the next line
I'm
going to print
sub underscore string
and let's say I want to check for my
string
let's say Java
if I run it it gives me false because
the word Java is not present inside my
string welcome to python functions
tutorial
suppose I write
python
now one thing to note here is
p is small and here the p is in capital
letter
if I run it it again gives me false
because
python is case sensitive now if I make
this as capital P it will result in
true
let's say I want to see
instead of tutorial let's say I have
training
if I run it it tells me false because
the support training is not there in the
string welcome to python functions
tutorial I'll change this to tutorial
you see here I have my result as true
all right
now let's see how to use Lambda
functions using filter function so we
are going to filter a list of numbers
using a specific condition
so I'll create a list called num
let's say it has values 40
10 40
then we have 56 27 let's say 33 59 and
70.
so this is my list now I am going to use
my Lambda function
along with the filter function
so I'll pass in my variable as greater
I'll say list
then
I'm going to
pass in the filter function and inside
the filter function I'll use the Lambda
function
and I'll have my
argument as num and my expression let's
say I want to filter only those values
which are greater than 30. so I'll say
num greater than 30 this is my
expression
or the condition that we want to check
I'll give a comma and
I'll have my next argument as num
and let's go ahead and print the
variable greater
if I run this there you go you can see
here we have all the values from the
list or the numbers from the list that
are greater than 30 so we have 40 56 33
and 70. so
27 and 15 are less than 30 and hence
those three values were not printed
now let's say you want to filter a list
of numbers that are divisible by 4.
so I'll create another list called list
one
and
let's say I'll have the
same values in the list so I'll just
copy it and I'll paste it here
and I'll create my variable let's say
divide
I'll say divide equal to
list one
use the filter function followed by
the Lambda function
I'll say X
colon
then I'll have my expression X
mod 4 should be equal to equal to zero
I'll give a comma and pass in my
next argument as my list one
now
I'm going to
say print
divide
okay
okay I'll remove the bracket here there
is no need of a bracket here cool
and we'll delete here as well
now let's run it
okay there is one error here this should
be list one
let's run it again
okay there is some error let's debug it
okay so this should be the function list
cool
there you go so here you can see we have
two numbers
40 and 56 that are divisible by 4.
the remaining numbers are not divised by
4 and hence were not printed
all right
now let's go ahead and explore how you
can use the map function along with the
Lambda function so the map function
accepts two arguments a function and a
list it takes that function and applies
it to every element of the list and
Returns the modified list
so we'll create a list called
list two
I'll say equal to
and again we are going to have the same
values in the list as above
so I'll just
copy those values
or the numbers
and I'll paste it here
okay
now
let's say
I want to find
the value of a number multiplied by 2 so
I'll say
let's say the variable name is double
the num or double the number
I'm going to use the list function
followed by the map function this time
and then we'll have our
Lambda function
I'll pass in my argument as X
colon
followed by the expression so X
multiplied by 2
I'll give a comma and then we'll have
the list that is list two
there is a spelling mistake here this
should be list two all right
now
I'm going to say print
double underscore the
underscore num
make sure there is no space
in the variable name
now if I run it
you can see here we have multiplied
every number in the list by 2 so
10 multiplied by 2 is 20. 40 multiplied
by 2 is 80 similarly 30 multiplied by 2
is 66 15 multiplies by 2 is 30 and again
we have 70 multiplied by 2 is 140.
so this is how you can use
map function with
Lambda functions
now suppose you want to find the power
of a number let's say I want to find the
power of a number raised to 3.
so I'll create a list called list three
let's say I have values 2 comma 5 comma
10 comma 6 comma 4 and then let's see we
have 12.
I'll say
Cube
so I want to find
the value of a number raised to the
power 3
so for that I am going to use the map
function followed by the
Lambda function
I'll pass in my argument X
and then
here I am going to use the inbuilt power
function in Python so pow
my
argument X
and this x I want to raise it to the
power of 3
and then I'll have my
next argument which is
list underscore 3
or list three
okay
now
let's
print the list so I'll say list of cube
I'll run it you can see here so 2 raised
to the power 3 or 2 cube is 8 5 cube is
125 10 cube is thousand six cube is 216
4 cube is 64 and 12 cube is
now coming to the final section of the
demo where we'll see how to use
the reduce function in Python along with
the Lambda function and then we'll use
the Lambda function within a user
defined function
so first let's look at how to use reduce
in Python so reduce applies a rolling
calculation to all items in a list you
can use it to calculate the total sum or
to multiply all the numbers together so
reduce function is a part of func tools
module so to use the
reduce function you need to import the
func tools module first so I'll say from
Funk tools
import
my function that is
reduce
and then I'll say
let's say I have my list 4 this time
I'll create a list
I'm going to take the same values as
above
and I'll pass in within a list
and now
I want to find the sum of all the
numbers that are present inside this
list called list four
so I'll do that using my reduce function
followed by the Lambda function
so I'll say x comma
and I'll give my expression as
y colon X
plus y
to give a comma and pass in my last
argument which is my list itself which
is list four
all right and then I'll say print
sum
let's run it there you go so 2 plus 5
plus 10 plus 6 plus 4 plus 12 is 39. so
this is how you can use the
reduce function in Python suppose you
wanted to find the product of all the
numbers present inside the list so you
can just
use the
Asterix instead of the addition operator
now if I run this you have the product
of all the numbers that were present
inside the list that is list four we
have 28 800.
now
let me show you the final demo that is
using a Lambda function in a user
defined function so first of all I'll
create a
foreign function to calculate the value
of a quadratic equation
so
for some of you who don't know the
formula of quadratic equation it is a x
square plus BX plus C so we are going to
use that formula in our function and
find the value using Lambda function
so I'll create a user defined function
called quadratic
and it will have
three arguments a comma B comma C
I'll say
return
and here in the return expression I am
going to pass in my Lambda function I
will say Lambda X Which is my
argument I'll say x colon
then I'll have my equation which is a
x square so I am saying a multiplied by
X
raised to the power 2 so I am using
double
asterisks
Plus
B
multiplied by X so this becomes ax
square plus BX
Plus
I have my constant that is C
now
just go to the next line
I'm going to create a variable let's say
f
I'll have my
user defined function name quadratic
I'll pass in the values for a b and c
let's say a is 2 B is 3. and C is let's
say 5
and I'll call a of one the value of x is
the value of a is 2
the value of B is 3 and the value of C
is 5. now let's run it and see the
result so
ax square plus BX plus C for
equal to 2 b equal to 3 and c equal to
5 the result is 10.
now let's change it to let's say I want
the value of x as 2 if I run it
you have the
equation evaluated and the result is 19.
all right
so what is the class in Python a class
is a virtual entity or a blueprint for
creating objects
a class in Python provides a means of
bundling data and functionality together
you can think of a class
as a school so here School becomes your
class a school has attributes about the
students classrooms Labs playgrounds Etc
hence the school can be called a class
and classrooms Labs desks playground
assembly are the attributes or objects
of a class
a class comes into existence when it is
instantiated or initiated
we can create as many objects as
possible in a class now in Python a
class is created using the keyword
called class followed by the class name
the first string inside the class is
called doc string and has a brief
description of the class below you can
see the syntax of creating a class in
Python we have the class keyword
followed by the class name this should
be a valid python name and then you have
a colon
below that you have the statements that
should be present inside the class now
let's look at an example of a class in
Python so
here you can see we have created a class
called student and we have two variables
the student ID and the name of the
student
and after that we have created a
function using the def keyword so this
is a user defined function and the name
of the function is called display
and inside the display function we are
giving a parameter called self so here
the self parameter refers to the current
class object and accesses the class
variables we can use anything instead of
self but
it must be the first parameter of any
function which belongs to the class
now moving ahead
so let's look at what is an object in
Python
so an object is also called an instance
of a class and the process of creating
this object is called instantiation
now you need to create an object of the
class if you want to use the class
attributes in another class or method
now the procedure to create an object is
similar to a function call So Below you
can see we have created a object called
Stu and we have called the class student
using parenthesis so this is how you
create a class and after that we are
displaying
the message to be printed by calling the
class name followed by the function
which is present inside the class
so this example will create a new object
instance named Stu
we can access the attributes of the
objects using the object name prefix
now moving ahead let's understand the
initialization or init method in a
python class
the init method is similar to
Constructors since C plus plus and Java
all classes in Python have an init
function it is always executed when the
class is being initiated you can use the
init function to assign values to object
Properties or other operations that are
necessary to do when the object has been
created
so the unit function is called
automatically every time the class is
being used to create a new object so
here you can see we have used
the init method we have
defined using the def keyword then we
have parameter self name and age so we
are calling
the class using this object called S1
and then we have passed in the values
for Neiman H that is delay and his age
is 27 years and after that we are
printing the age and the name as well
all right now let's get started with our
demo on classes and objects in Python on
the Jupiter notebook
so I am on my jupyter notebook let me
first go ahead and rename my notebook to
classes and objects in Python
all right I'll click on rename
first of all
let me show you how to create a simple
class
so I'm creating a new class
using the class keyword so this is
the keyword class and
followed by the keyword I have my class
name called new class
one thing to note here is the class name
should always be a valid python name
I'll give a colon and in the next line
I'll just say
x equal to 50 so this x is a variable
which is present inside my class called
new class now if I run it
I have my new class created now if you
want to display the
value of x you can just say new class
dot X now if I run this you can see here
I have my value printed which is 50.
now
we'll see another simple example to
create a class and to call that class
using
an object
so I'll say class
then I'll say
new class let's say one
give a colon and I'll create a variable
called x equal to 100 so my X is a
variable which is present inside new
class 1 and holds a value 100
now I'll give a comment
create object
so to create object I'll
Define a variable called R let's say R
stands for result and then I'll say new
class 1 so I'm calling my class and then
I'll say print
R which is my new object dot X
let's run it you see here I have my
value printed of X which is 100 so this
is how you can
create or initiate a class using an
object
now let's see how you can use the self
parameter in a class
so I'll go ahead and create a class
called
student
give a colon
then I'll have some variables
or the
attributes of a student let's say the
student ID is 10 and the name is
Anderson
now
inside the class I am going to
create a user defined function called
display
so I've used my DF keyword followed by
the function name that is display and
inside the display function I'll use
self as my parameter
and then I am going to say
print
self dot ID I'll give a comma and I'm
going to print
my name so I have written self.name
so I'll run this and then
we're going to create an object called s
and we'll call our class
where is student and LCS dot display
now let's run it and see the result you
can see it here we have called the
class using this object called s so it's
displaying
the ID that is 10 and the name that is
Anderson
cool
now we are going to see an example where
we'll pass a doc string so in the slide
we discussed that the first
string inside the class is called a dog
string and has a brief description of
the class
so let me show you an example how to
pass in a dark string I'll create a
class again let's say called student
give a colon
and then we'll have our message which is
essentially a doc string I'll say this
is a student class
then I'll create a variable called each
let's say the student's age is 14. and
then
I'll create a user defined function
called welcome
and have myself
parameter after that I'll say print
my message let's say hi
comma
welcome to
section
let's say B
and then
I'll come out of the class and we are
going to
print
class name that is student I'll say
student dot each
and then I'll say print I'll just scroll
down
student Dot
then I'm going to use the
function name that is welcome
and after that to print the docstring
message I'm going to say
my class name that is student
dot I'm going to use underscore
underscore doc underscore underscore
now we have created a class called
student that has a variable called each
so we are going to display the age of
the student and then
we are going to display the doc string
so here we are not going to print the
message which is present inside the
function called welcome
let's run it you can see it here
we
have the message printed so first we are
printing the age of the student and then
we have the doc string message that is
this is a student class
all right
now let's move ahead we are going to see
how to use the init function
in a class
so I'll say my comment init function
all right I'll scroll down
we'll create another
class called student
this time we are going to use the init
function so I am writing def space
underscore underscore init underscore
underscore then we'll have our cell
parameter let's say the next parameter
is name and then we have the date of
birth of the student
I'll say self dot name equal to
name
then I'll say self Dot
dob or D to both equal to
a parameter that is DOB
and then
I'll say
my object let's say S1
I'm going to call my class student
and it will have
values of name and D to birth let's say
the name of the student is Harry
and
the date of birth let's say it is
29th
October 1992.
all right
and finally we are going to print
s1.name and then I'll say print
S1 Dot
date of birth
let's run it
you can see it here we have the name and
the date of birth of the student printed
cool now you can also modify the objects
that you have created suppose I want to
change the name from Harry to Virat
because my object was S1 dot name
Harry I want to change this to Virat let
me show you how to do it
this is very simple I'll just give a
comment that is modify objects
the way to do is you just
see the object name that is S1 followed
by the parameter that is name equal to
let's say Virat
now if I print
S1 dot name
I'll have Virat instead of
Harry
okay
now
if you want to delete the object
properties let's say I want to delete
one of the properties let's say I want
to delete name property of the student
to do that
I can use the Del keyword followed by
the object name that is S1 and say S1
dot name
now if I print
S1 dot name it will throw an error
saying student object has no attribute
name because we are first deleting it
and then we are trying to print it and
hence
python cannot recognize this attribute
name
now you can also delete objects that is
all the objects using the DL keyword
so this means we can delete both the
objects that we created above which is
name and date of birth
so the way to do is I'll just say DL S1
so it will delete all the objects
that is S1 in this case
I'll run this and then let's say I want
to print S1 Dot date of birth
you see it here
python says name S1 is not defined
because we deleted it
cool
now coming to the final section of the
demo we're going to create a simple
class with init method again
so this time my class name is let's say
animal
give a colon and then I'll write my
init method using the DF keyword
I'll say self comma
name that is the name of the animal as
the parameter I'll say self dot name
equal to name
and then
I'm going to create another function
called TF
which is essentially a welcome or a grid
message
and that has a parameter that is self
I'm going to print the grid message or
the greeting I'll say hi
my name is
give a comma and then say self dot name
now I am going to create
my object E1 to
initiate my class
so I'll say animal which is the class
name let's say the name of the animal is
puppy
then I am going to say E1 Dot
greet
I'll use parenthesis let's run it there
you go you see here we have a message
printed hi my name is then using the
self dot name argument of the parameter
we are passing in the value that is
puppy all right so
that was a demo session on python
classes and objects so we saw how to
create a simple class in Python and then
we saw how to create objects to
call it class
and then
we
saw how to use the self parameter after
that we saw how to
print a message that is present in the
dark string of a class
and then we
checked a few examples on using the init
method in a class then we learned how to
modify objects and delete objects in a
class and finally we saw another example
on init method
all right
let's glance at the topics
object oriented programming in Python
some major principles of object oriented
programming and then we will touch upon
topics like class in Python objects
methods inheritance uh the concepts of
inheritance the different type of
inheritance then the definition and
examples of polymorphism encapsulation
and abstraction so all these topics will
be supported with examples and the
relevant
terminologies and definitions
now what is object oriented programming
python is an object-oriented language
like any other programming language like
Java C plus plus and the object oriented
programming language concept is not new
and each and every mature programming
language
has these Concepts imbibed in it now the
concept of object oriented programming
in Python focuses primarily on creating
project objects and making reusable
codes so whenever we start programming
at a large scale or for a big project it
is very important to identify the
objects within that particular project
which you want to Define
now for example in this in this uh
presentation what you are seeing is that
we are covered with full of objects like
car dog tiger tree or a balloon so these
are typical examples of objects which
you encounter in day to day life
now what are the major principles of
object-oriented programming so these are
the different kind of uh you know
terminologies classes are there there
are objects there are methods then on
these classes and objects you apply
inheritance polymorphism
encapsulation and abstraction
now what is a class
is nothing but a collection of objects
or we can say a user-defined data type
right so basically it's a complex data
type which has a collection of objects
and within the objects you have
primitive data types like in string uh
float
Etc so a class also holds the methods
the functions which basically perform
operations on these objects
right and also it also holds on to the
attributes of the objects so let's see
with an example right
so if you have an employee class then it
would contain attributes and methods
such as email ID name age salary these
are the attributes and other methods
like you know perform tasks give
presentation increase salary
etc etc these are will be the methods
now let's talk about what are objects in
Python
now object is known as instantiation of
a class right an object is a group of
interrelated variables and methods so
when a class is defined only the
description for the object is defined
therefore no memory or storage is
allocated at that point so for example
if you see in this motorbike is a class
but the different objects of the class
are different kind of bikes by different
brands like BMW Suzuki Royal Enfield so
they all have inherited the attributes
of the class motorbike and then on top
of it Define certain variables
additional variables and methods on top
of it to enhance the motorbike and make
it look different or our function
differently
look at that
now what are methods in Python methods
are functions defined inside the body of
a class right so basically methods are
something which like which you are which
you perform on a uh attributes of a
class right method is a function that is
that is associated with an object so you
create an object of a class and on that
object then you can execute those
functions
in Python a method is not unique to
class instances any object type can have
methods
and the methods Define the behavior of
an object so that's why a BMW motorbike
will be different from Royal Enfield
because the behavior is different the
methods are different
so if you see the example over here you
have a class bike and in that there is
an init function which will get invoked
when you initialize the object of class
bike and then you can set the brand name
and the year of manufacturing for that
particular object thank you
now inheritance what is inheritance
inheritance is something which you
derive from a parent so inheritance is
like creating a new class that uses all
the properties and behavior of another
class
now the new class is called the derived
class or the child class and the
existing class whose properties are
inherited is known as a base class or
parent class it provides and the basic
functionality the usage of inheritance
is the reusability of code so if
anything is defined in the parent class
then you don't need to rewrite that
particular code in the child you can
just inherit it
so as I mentioned let's take a look at
the different types of inheritance which
are available you have single level in
which only one child is narrating uh the
properties and the attributes from the
parent then you have multi-level in
which
first child has generated from the class
A Class B as inherited and then you have
another class C which is narrating from
class B so this is an example of
multi-level and we will be supporting
all these concepts with an example in
our python notebook
then there is a hierarchical then there
are two different classes which are uh
inheriting from a single class and then
multiple inheritance that single class
is inheriting from two different parents
so these are different set varieties of
inheritance bases what is the demand
what is the business requirement you can
Define
now what is polymorphism polymorphism in
Python
what does it means polymorphism consists
of two words poly and moths poly means
many and morph means shape so basically
it means a many shapes so it is it means
using a familiar interface for multiple
forms right so you can use a single name
of the method and which can perform
different Behavior based on the object
in which it is invoked so in simple
terms we understand that a task can be
performed in various ways
let's support it with an example like
you have a plus operator now the plus
operator can be used for integer data
types to perform arithmetic operations
whereas when you use plus operator to in
string data types it can be used for
concatenation so it's a very typical
example very good example in terms of
how an uh same operator can behave
differently bases what data types are
being used
okay
now let's talk about encapsulation
using oops in Python we can restrict
access to methods and variables so
basically in in Python you can you can
create something like as private
variables but of course you can't use a
private keyword unlike Java so in in
Python we use underscore or double
underscore in order to Define private
attribute so basically these attributes
can be only used within the class and
cannot be exposed outside a particular
class
so we will see this with an example
now what is abstraction data abstraction
in capsule encapsulation are often used
as synonyms abstraction is used to hide
internal details and show only
functionalities
for example you know how to turn on or
off a light using a switch but you don't
know what is happening behind socket
similarly an abstract class can not be
instantiated
which means you cannot create objects
for this class you can only Define the
methods which have to be implemented by
the classes which are inheriting the
abstract class
so basically abstract class provide only
the method signatures and rest the other
functionalities and the implementation
has to be done by the child classes
so let's now move to the
our Jupiter notebook and we will
start performing certain examples
now as we are saying like python has
objects so let's create a object
we will create a class bikes over here
and within the class
we will Define the init method
and in the init
we will
instantiate two variables brand name and
here
now
we will create an object
of bike
which we will we are calling as BMW and
another via will create an object called
Ducati so what we are doing in this two
scenarios is that we are just
instantiating the byte of bike object
with variable BMW and Ducati we are
instantiating
now let's
print
the year in manufacturing here the brand
name and the year
for BMW and for Ducati and let's see
right so what we have done is we have
created an object for bikes one we are
calling BMW and one we are calling
Ducati and how we are differentiating
between these two bikes is Basis the
brand name and the year of manufacturing
now let's take a look at the example of
methods
I'm gonna rewrite my init method
and now I am
creating an
function a method of top speed
and
a function of type
now I'm gonna create an object of bike
now this
method this object bike
can invoke methods top speed and type
because they belong to the same class
bikes
so initially when I created my object
bytes I'm instantiating it with BMW and
the ear
and then
I am making a call to the method top
speed
and then I'm making a call to the method
type
and printing so basically I'm printing
the output of the function top speed and
output of the function BMW
form the object BMW which is of class
bikes
now let's take a look at an example of
single level inheritance
let's create a parent class called
Animal
and create a
method called sound
let's create a child class
cat which inherits animal
and let me just put a method over here
is the indentation
okay so now I have
object parent class animal child class
cat which has inherited animal
and the parent class method is sound and
the child class method is meow so now
I'll create an object called cat
and with this object I'll be able to
invoke both child class method and the
parent class method
and as you can see uh the child class
has inherited both uh parent and child
class
functions methods
now let's take a look at
multi-level inheritance example
I'll start off with creating exactly the
same parent class called Animal
then I am I'm already created another
class I'll create
same child class cat
and now I'll create another class which
will inherit cat class
so cat has inherited animal and Cat
child has generated cat
let's validate its syntax
and similarly now I'll create an object
for cat child
and this catch child now
can invoke the same methods
which are in child parent and the super
parent
s
so this is an example of multi-level
this is an example of
single level inheritance
now
let's take an example of polymorphism
we are going to click create a class
parrot
and Define the function fly
and
swim
now we are going to create another class
mind you there is no inheritance here we
are just creating an independent class
called penguin
and same methods now the same name
fly
and
swim
foreign
now let's make a
function
in which we will pass
an object
and bases
that what is the instance of the
particular object burn it the
corresponding method will get invoked
so let's see in the method flying test
whatever instance of the bird object
will be the corresponding of method will
be called
so now let's create a object of parrot
class and then let's create a object of
penguin class
now in my flying test method first I'll
send a object of instance parrot
and then
I'll
send the object of instance penguin so
now base is the instance type when this
bird dot fly method will be called it
will be called basis the instance so in
the first case the parrot it will call
this method and in case of penguin it
will call this method fly
so please note what is the output the
output is a parrot can fly but a penguin
cannot fly
and it has been decided by the python
at the runtime that which particular
method to be invoked bases the instance
so it's a very important concept
now let's take an example of
encapsulation
I'll make up Class Cars
Define its init method
now within that init method I have
created a private variable with
underscore underscore Max price and
given a value of
9 lakh
now I am creating another
function called cell and in that I am
printing the
Max price
and then
I am creating another function in which
I am modifying the private variable set
max price so I will pass any value in
the set max price and it will replace
the max price which I have set during
the initialization at this point
now let's create an object of Class Cars
and
see if I sell this then the selling
price is
9 lakh what I had in the set at the time
of initialization
now what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to modify a private variable directly C
underscore underscore Max price and I I
want to check if I am trying to create a
modify a private variable will it still
show me 9 lakh or 10 lakh value and it's
still showing me the 9 lakh value it
means that I can't directly
approach or access the private variable
I can only modify it if I access it
through a method which is set max price
in this now I am setting the max price
to thousand and now if I print what is
my Max price it will print as
1000.
so this is the concept of encapsulation
you have a private variable which is
accessible within only the methods of
the class you can't access it directly
now let's take a look at hierarchical
inheritance
I'll create a class employee
and
create an init method
within that you have
three variables name Agent salary
so an employee with has name Agent
salary
now
I'm going to create a class
child class called child employee one
which is inherited from employee
and child embroid2
which is also inherited from
employee
so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
create a object per child class
and print
foreign
so this is a typical example in which
you have two child
classes which have inherited from the
single parent
s
now let's take a look at our last
concept which is abstraction
so now I'll create a class car
and Define a method
mileage but I am not
giving any definition to it I'm just
giving a signature mileage
the child classes which will inherit
abstract class will be giving the
definition
so I am giving creating a class BMW
which will again
which has inherited the car ABC car but
given the definition now
similarly I am creating another class
Jaguar which has inherited the class car
but now it is giving a different
definition
it's printing mileage 25 kilometer per
hour
and
another class
Range Rover
and another class
Renault
okay so four classes
which have implemented the abstract
class method mileage in a different way
now I'll create an object of first
BMW
and
invoke method mileage
so it has method invoke the method
mileage and BMW car and printed mileage
is 30 kilometer
similarly I'll do for Renault
Jaguar
and
Range Rover
so if you see the parent class abstract
parent class has not implemented the
method but just given the signature of
the method and all other classes have
implemented it and that's the concept of
abstraction
we're going to talk about the concept of
inheritance the types of narratives
which are applicable so the different
kind of inheritance which we are going
to talk about are single level
inheritance multi-level hierarchical and
multiple inheritance and we're going to
support each concept with an example
before we begin this session I just want
to highlight that inheritance Is Not A
New Concept in any of the programming
languages just like in Python this
concept is applicable across multiple
programming languages like Java C plus
plus Etc
now what is inheritance inheritance
provides the reusability of a code it
allows you to inherit what you have
written in a particular class or a piece
of code and you don't need to rewrite it
you can inherit it so that is the main
purpose of inheritance it is creating a
new class that utilizes the properties
and behavior of an existing class so we
will support this with an example so if
you take a look at the syntax the sample
syntax over here you have a base class
and you have certain attributes
functions associated with the base class
and then you have a derived class in
which you extend basically you inherit
the base class and you inherit the
properties of the base class
now the new class formed is called the
derived class or the child class you can
call it anything derived child or
subclass and the existing class whose
properties are inherited is known as The
Base Class parent or super class these
are synonymous so any where you hear
that okay you know you're working on a
child class or derived class you can
easily figure out that you're talking
about a derived class and whenever there
is a reference to a parent or a super
class it means we are talking about the
base class right now
with this concept with this idea let's
move ahead and look at the different
types of inheritance which are possible
in Python
now here we are trying to display
pictographically diagrammatically the
different kinds of inheritance and this
will make understanding more clear
now let's talk about first single level
inheritance you have a class A and you
have a class B so basically only till
class B only single level child is
inheriting the attributes the properties
of classes so that is what we call as
single level inheritance multi-level is
you have multiple level of inheritance
in for example Class B here in edits
Class A Properties and Class C in edits
Class B properties so ultimately you can
see that the the properties gets
trickled down till class C right so that
is the example of a multi-level
right
next is hierarchical in which two
classes are narrating from a single
class class B is also narrating from
class A and Class C is also narrating
from class A so both class B and Class C
are kind of siblings to the parent Class
A right
multiple inheritance it means that a
child class in is inheriting properties
from two parent classes so in this
example the class C is inherited the
properties of Class A also and Class B
also so we will be looking at these
examples
when we will be running in Python
now let's
take this example with a real world
object right let's first try to give you
a view of how we are going to how what
we want to explain in The Inheritance
with Real World objects right now here
we are taking an example of a black and
white TV and a color TV now single level
inheritance in this type of inheritance
there is only one single derived class
from a single Base Class as I mentioned
earlier so for example you can assume
there is a class called black and white
TV and what are the attributes of a
simple black and white TB it has a
regulator it has a sound adjustment now
there is a child class called color TV
which inherits the basic attributes of
course a color TV also has a regulator a
sound adjustment but additional play on
top of it it also provides new features
like color picture and cable connection
so now what do you understand by this is
that the child inherits the basic
properties from the parent class but it
also adds on the new additional features
so the color TV does not need to rewrite
or the functionality of a regulator and
the sound adjustment it has inherited
multi-level very similar to single level
but now we are adding more features so
like in the previous example color TV
inherited the features of black from
black and white TV now we move a step
ahead now there is another
classification another advancement of
Wi-Fi LED TV so that has also inherited
the features from color TV right so it's
a multi-level inheritance
so just to reiterate the black and white
TV had Channel regulator dish antenna
the color TV added additional features
of color picture quality and cable
connection and the Wi-Fi enabled TV
added the new smart features to the TV
which it inherited from the color TV
multiple inheritance now in multiple
inheritance the derived class is
inherited from more than one base class
right so now for example over here you
have a class called Android which is an
Android operating system based class and
one is the Wi-Fi LED class which has the
Wi-Fi features of like sound picture
Wi-Fi enablement and if you combine all
these features and bring it into another
child class that class is the Smart TV
class which has the features of Android
and the features of Wi-Fi LED TV and
then you call it as a smart TV it has
all the Android applications it has the
Wi-Fi features and Etc so this is the
example of multiple inheritance getting
the best of all the parents
foreign
if more than one class is inherited from
the base class right so now if we just
tweak our prior example and you know
just rephrase it what we are saying is
now from the black and white TV you can
also make a color TV you can also make a
smart TV or you can also make a Wi-Fi
LED TV right so there is no restriction
as such so basically the color TV is
also inheriting the features of a black
and white TV smart TV is also inheriting
the features of a black and white TV and
the Wi-Fi LED TV also is inheriting the
features from black and white TV so it's
a very typical example of a arq in
inheritance
so now let's quickly look at the
examples
okay so let's start off
with a very simple single level
inheritance
let's make a class
and create a function
called speak
and print something
okay
now let's make another class
so what we did was we created a class
called Homo sapiens and in the and now
we are creating a class called man which
inherits
uh the attributes of homo sapiens
and we say
create a function which is specific to
man so almost recipients has a function
which called speak and man has a
function called Talk
and let's print it
now let's create an object of man now
what does this signify the man class is
also inheriting whatever is there in
Homo sapiens so man can even talk and he
can even speak right
so what we are going to do is
first we are going to execute the
function
Peak
so the
The Base Class function got called speak
and it is printing Homo sapiens speaking
and also we can call the child function
okay so so if you see this is the basic
difference which we want to highlight
that just you have created the object
only for the child class not the parent
so now making by making the object of
the child class
you can invoke the parent class function
as well as the child because the child
has inherited the parent features
now let's take an example of
multi-level
so we will
continue from our previous example we
will create class homo sapiens
Define in
function speak
and
print
now we will make another class
man
now we are saying
man can walk
so we are saying man walking
now this is the third level this is the
multi-level
command Choi
and
we are saying that a man child can eat
so ultimately a man child can speak can
walk can eat all three operations can be
performing
so we are going to make a object of man
child
and now
python will allow us invoke walk
function
speak function
and eat function
perfect so this is our typical example
of multi-level hierarchy
now
moving to our next type of inheritance
which is the multiple inheritance where
the child is deriving
attributes properties from
two parents
so we will now create a class called
calculation one
in our example
and let's make a function sum
and it will return
calculation X Plus y
second
calculation 2
and
let's create operation subtraction
and it will return x minus y
okay
now
we will create the derived class which
is in editing both calculation 1 and
calculation 2.
and
create
its own function called multiplication
okay so derived class now has a sum
function subtraction function and
multiplication okay
so let's create an object for derived
and
now let's invoke the relevant functions
so some
subtraction
it should say minus 40
and
multiplication
thousand
so if you see it's it's a different from
multi-level it's multiple it means that
the child class has inherited from two
parents it's relevant functions right
and that's how we are able to call them
in the derived class
foreign
inheritance
okay so in hierarchical in inheritance
let's go back to our example of
first we have the black and white TV and
we will create a function called
antenna
print channels are telecasted through
then we will create
color TV
we will Define its own function called
cable connection plus it has an edited
the function called antenna from black
and white TV
here it is okay
now we are going to create another class
called as
foreign
TV which is also in editing from black
and white
now in this we are defining bluetooth
tethering function
[Applause]
okay
and let's make another Smart TV
okay and then we are gonna
you can watch
Android applications on Ott platform
right so this is the class of smart TV
okay so what we have done eventually
over here is we have created a black and
white TV color TV also inherits from
black and white TV Wi-Fi LED also in
edits from black and white TV smart TV
also inherits from black and white TV
okay now
let's try to create the
relevant objects
we will first create an object of color
TV
then we will create
Wi-Fi LED TV
and then we will create
Smart TV
okay now we will have the relevant
functions available to invoke
so both all the child all the children
objects now will have an antenna
function A1
A2
and A3
all three are having the antenna
function so we can just try to print it
okay
and then
we can invoke the relevant
child functions A1
cable connection
Bluetooth triggering
and Android applications
so if you see this is an example of AR
key you have color Wi-Fi LED in Smart TV
all inheriting the black and white TV
features and its own
its own feature
[Music]
okay
now along with this concept let me just
also introduce
some relevant Concepts which are
applicable along with the inheritance
concept which will be helpful
I also want to show you the example of
init function unit function
is a Constructor in Python language and
it is called by default whenever you
instantiate an object
so let me give you an example over here
so here you have a class person and you
have we are just defining the init
function The Constructor
okay and we are just
defining certain attributes
instantiating certain attributes in the
person first name and the last name
another function which I am calling is
the
print name
foreign
function
okay so what I'm doing is I am creating
a child class now
called as student which is inherited uh
the features attributes of the person
Base Class
and
I'm also making a Constructor for
student
and from student I am invoking the
Constructor of the person class right
so now if you see I'm gonna make an
object of student
and initialize it with
the self the first name and the last
name
and in eventually
the
parent class init function is being
called first name and the last name and
this function diff print name it will
print James Anderson right as I have
already initiated the
parameters
okay so if you see now what have I done
I have the attribute values in the
parent class are getting printed by
invoking The Constructor of the child
class
so what happened when you invoke student
by default this init function got
invoked the parameters of James and
Anderson got passed then from person you
invoke The Constructor in it and here
now the first name and last name got
initialized and then it got printed
so this is the basic feature of a init
function
now like the way I have called person
dot init over here I I can also make a
call to Super there is a keyword called
super keyword
so let's just take an example of super
keyword
okay let me have my shared class like
the previous one parent class the person
class
and
I'll have to just make a change in my
student class
in the init function instead of parent
dot in it I will call
Uber dot in it
this is the keyword
super function
which will always invoke the parent
class
gives you the handle to the parent class
and then you can invoke the relevant
method
and the invocation methodology will be
the same and you can
check the output it's going to be the
same but it's that the syntax is
different there is another keyword which
is available for you to invoke the
parent so you don't need to know the
class
of the parent you can just make a call
to the super
now let's also take a look at another
utility utility function called is
subclass right
so
what we are going to do is
we are going to create a function
calculation 1
calculation two okay so we have created
two classes calculation one calculation
two independent classes no one
inheriting each other now we are going
to create a derived class
now this is the example what we have
done earlier very similar to multiple
inheritance so we are just actually
recreating a
multiple inheritance example
okay so you have a derived class which
has multiple inheritance from
calculation one and calculation two
summation multiplication and divide
relevant functions are there now we will
check
which class is a sub class of which one
right so let's create an object of
derived
now what we want to print is that
whether derived
is a sub class of calculation 2
and it should return true
and let's see
another is calculation one a sub class
of calculation two it should return
false right because these two are
independent classes so a subclass is
another function which is available in
Python which helps you
decide you know you can check whether
which is a derived class and which is
not a direct class
thank you
next let's take an example of another
function called is instance okay
we will take the same
set of functions
create an object of derived
and check
whether the object D is of which
is it is it of a instance of class
derived or not it's true so instead of
derived if I make it as calculation 2
for example now if I say c equal to
calculation 1
and say c
is instance of derived it should say
false but if I say calculation 1 it
should say true
and if I say calculation 2 should say
false because calculation class is an
independent class D is a derived class
from calculation 1 and calculation 2 so
basically D is in is instance of both
calculation 1 calculation two so it will
always return true
we are going to talk about what is a
python hydrator what are iterables right
what are the iterable objects how an
iterator works and then we will also
discuss about how to throw a stop
iteration exception basically when you
reach the end of a list then you can
throw a stop iteration exception and we
will see that with an example
now what is a python iterator
pythonitrator is an object that can
Traverse through iterable objects in
Python like lists tuples dictionaries
sets and returns data one element at a
time so basically you can Traverse
through these lists one at a time and
then you can use it as per your custom
requirement but iterator as an object is
available to you is a tool available to
you in order to Traverse through each
and every element
now they are implemented within for
Loops comprehensions generators in
Python implicitly they are not visible
up front but they are hidden in plain
sight so basically when you're using
Loops when you're using generators
comprehensions implicitly python is
actually converting them in the back end
in an iterator object and giving you the
results
now what are iterables on which you can
iterate list tuples dictionaries sets as
I mentioned are all iterables or
iterable objects other than these you
can't perform any iteration if you have
not created an object of list Tuple or
dictionary or set then of course your
writerable will not be of any use
and these objects internally possess an
item method i t e r method which is used
to get an iterator A handle to an
iterator and then you can start looping
it or you can start accessing the
elements of the iterator
now how iterator Works python iterator
implements internally
these two methods which you are seeing
on the screen underscore underscore item
underscore underscore brackets and
underscore underscore next underscore
underscore strategy now these two
methods are implicitly implemented by
python for any internal implicit
iterator object but if you have to write
your own custom iterator then you need
to override these methods and I'll show
you in my examples in jupyter Notebook
the iterator object is initialized using
the iter method so basically whenever
you have to create an iterator object
you need to initialize it with ITA and
then use next method in order to
Traverse through it
now stop iteration exception so as I
mentioned when we reach the end of an
iterable right like suppose you have a
list or a set which has a length of four
when you have ended the fourth element
and you're trying to access something
Beyond fourth element which is fifth
then of course you can implicitly raise
a stop iteration exception or python
will throw it so we will see that with
an example but you will get a stop
iteration exception
you know so to prevent in order to
handle it or manage it in your code we
use top iteration statement to raise an
error you can raise your custom error so
you can catch this exception and then
raise your custom error in the
underscore underscore next method
so now let's uh support everything with
our examples
let's start with a very basic example of
an iterator now let me create a list
with just four numbers and as I said I'm
gonna initialize my iterator with item
method so now I have created a list and
now I am initializing it with item okay
Now using next I'm gonna print my first
element four okay so it means the iter
internally has given me handle to the
first element
and now as many times I move print next
I am moving to the next element
so now I'm also going to show you a
different syntax this is a syntax but
the output will be same it's a different
syntax to invoke underscore next so its
output is going to be same but the
syntax is only the difference over here
so you're going to get access to the
next element
and then
my fourth element which is 33 now I have
traversed through all my four elements
now what will happen if I again do next
I have ended I am at the end of my list
so I'll get an exception of stock price
iteration right and this is thrown by
python
now let's take another interesting
example if I want to perform iteration
on strings
so I have created a variable and I have
initialized it with geeks and now I have
created an iterator on top of this
string variable and I'm going to
Traverse it till the time I and reach
the end of my string so let me
hydrate it and I'm gonna iterate till
the time I get the stop iteration
exception
so also I'm actually explaining here how
to cleanly handle the exception
except
and then break if I get the exception
I'll break out of this program
and here you get the result all the
letters of my string Geeks has been
printed individually
and I think it's a very important
example interesting example that how a
string has been converted now point to
be noted over here is that python has
internally invoked underscore underscore
iter and underscore underscore next
methods which it has implicitly
implemented for string iterator so you
don't need to do anything
now let's take another example to how to
Traverse through a list using for
Loop
so I'm gonna leave for object in list
and just print the list this is
without an iterator I'm just printing my
list so I'm just trying to show the
difference that if you use an iterator
or you do not but how you can access the
elements in the list
now let's take an example of how I can
write my own custom iterator
okay so I'm creating a class where I am
overriding the init method basically
initializing in his initialization of my
class where I'm gonna initialize a
variable Max with 0
and then I am overriding this is the
most important point over here I am
overriding iter method
and then
I am writing another overriding the
underscore underscore next method where
I am adding 6 to my number and then
incrementing my Loop so that
I can move further so in this underscore
next method I am just moving beyond
adding 6 and till the time I reach the
max variable so when I'll invoke my
class
I am passing 9 so it means that I should
not
go beyond
uh 10 basically I should start my
iteration from 6 and will not go beyond
ten nine plus one so I should get
numbers which are between 6 to 10 as per
my expectation
now before we diagnose the output most
important point is that how you have
converted your class to an iterator over
here you in order to invoke make a class
in iterator it is mandatory you override
I take AR and next methods which you
have done over here
together
so now let's print
okay so six so my number started with 0
initialized with 0 and I added 6 to 8 so
my first result is six and now if I keep
printing I will get one value
incremented
seven
eight
until
nine
and
10 right so this is the expected output
right
now another example on the same lines
I'm gonna print the first 20 numbers
using my iterator so I am
gonna override the iter method and
underscore underscore next method my
numbers now in this
underscore underscore next method I'm
just incrementing my number y 1 not by 6
and I'm gonna stop at the limit 20.
so like I showed in my previous example
I'm gonna initialize first my class
and then
initialize my iterator and just then
gonna run a for Loop onward
and here is the response output I have
printed the first 20 numbers because I
have created this limit so I'm
initializing with one and going till the
max 20 number
but the point is it's not the output
which is more important over here the
most important concept over here is that
you have created your own iterator
we will talk about what is a generator
in Python we will talk about the
advantages of using generators
and the utility of the next function
which allows us to operate with
generators and print the values within
the generator so we will see these all
these concepts with an example
now what is a generator in Python
python generators lets you create your
own iterative functions that return the
traversal object with a sequence of
values
so basically when with iterators you can
only work on list tuples or sets but
with generators you can convert your
functions into iterator functions itself
and we will see that when we will be
working on a jupyter notebook
now another important feature in a
generative function is that a yield
statement is used rather than a return
statement so basically
the return statement terminates a
function entirely if you use it within
the function and you know basically
return from the statement while the
yield statement pauses the function
there it is and holding all its states
all its variables the values in the
variables and then continue thereafter
on the successive calls so basically in
a generative function you use yield
functions and I will talk about the
utility of this yield
uh statement within the generator
function how it helps in generating
pipeline but just to hold a thought over
here and understand the concept the
yield statement basically holds the
processing of the function at that point
and if you make an invocation of that
generator function again it starts from
there itself where you left it
as compared to return statement return
is a general exit if you make an
invocation of the return statement from
a function it will restart again from
the beginning if you invoke it the next
time and that's the basic difference
so what are the advantages of using
generators it's very easy to implement
the code syntactically it's very simple
within the few line of codes you are
able to achieve the you know functions
and able to implement the logic you can
generate infinite sequence you don't
need to provide the range values the
starting and ending you can generate an
infinite value and I'll show you that
with an example
and
uh generators are very memory efficient
they are the most memory efficient ways
of processing huge data sets
they process the data incrementally and
do not allocate memory to all the
results at the same time they do that
incrementally
they really come in handy when
implementing data science pipelines for
huge data sets in a resource constraint
environment where you have uh you know
constraint on the RAM and the other
resources of the hardware
now another biggest Advantage is
pipelining with generators generator
pipelines are a great way to break apart
complex processing into smaller pieces
when processing list of items so
basically you can break your complex
code into smaller pieces and then
invoke them as a generator
recursively and we will see that how but
basically you are making the complex
code look simple and making it invoke in
a pipeline fashion
now the another most important function
in order to deal and operate with the
generator is the next function the next
function is used to retrieve elements
from a generator object and then print
it so that's how you basically interact
with your generate function you cannot
do that until unless you don't use next
function
so now let's quickly jump to our
examples
which we are going to support for each
of these Concepts now let's start by
basically creating our first generator
function
I'm gonna
create a variable and initialize it with
one
and I'm gonna do a print
this is just for my
login and showing on the console that
where we have reached and then
I'm gonna say yield n
okay
so now here we are not exiting the a
function we are just saying that just uh
you know this is the point if you invoke
the function again the function will
start from this point on
foreign
and again if this is the second
checkpoint in the code
and similarly
this is the we are going to have a last
checkpoint in the code
now in order to
create my generator now this is the
my generator initialization my gen
now if I use the next function and
invoke my generator
now my
generator has been executed till this
point right n equal to 1.
now if I make a second invocation
now it has moved ahead and printed the
second so it is behaving like a loop it
is now behaving like a loop it is
behaving like an iterator but I have not
created any list I have not created any
double but I am basically traversing
through the variables through the
sequence of the variables within my
generator
and if I again
print it
this is my last this is printed last so
all the checkpoints within my generator
have been executed
now the same example which I have over
here
let me call it in a loop
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
remove these invocations and just
replace it
with a loop call right so this generator
functions remain as is now instead of
writing my next
function
three times I am going to just invoke my
generator in the for Loop and this will
get invoked the number of times I have
yield in my generator
and my output should be
the you know the these logs which I have
created and of course the variables
yeah so see now what has happened is now
the output is all these three print
commands have been executed plus the
variable values of n has been imprinted
at each checkpoint one two and three
so when I initialize my item variable
during the for Loop this item consists
of the variable values which are there
in my generator
now I'm gonna show you
example of if I use a return statement
in my generator
so I am going to create another
generator
and provide a value
now in during this in middle of this
generator I'm just invoking return
and then I am
printing my second checkpoint
and then the
last checkpoint
now
I'm going to initialize my generator
now if I invoke my first element of the
generator I'll get it there's no problem
because I printed the first item I got
the value of my yield and then I
returned but now if I invoke my second
element in the generator but before
invoking second I have already given the
return statement my generator will exit
and I'll get the stop iteration error
now this is a python generated
exception which is denoting that you
have you cannot move beyond the first
item because you have returned from the
generator over here so that's the
difference if you just remove this
comment this out
and then run it
you will get your second item so it's
not X the code exits if you write return
over here
so I hope you are able to understand the
difference
now let's take another example now here
we are going to create a list and how
uh implicit list like the way Legacy way
we have been creating in Python
differentiates like the way we are
creating a generator
so what I'm doing is I'm creating a list
with random numbers
and then another list in which I am just
Square rooting the numbers in that list
and similarly I'm also creating a
generator which I am expecting the same
output in the new list as the generator
but I'm gonna show you different phase
of traversing the generator as compared
to a list
now if you see this list underscore if I
just make a print call to this list
it's gone straightforwardly uh square
root
uh the numbers and give me the output 4
9 64 and 100.
but if I print the generator
I will not get the expected output what
I'm expecting I will just get the
generator object which is not what I
desire so basically you can't just print
the generator like the list you have to
either use the next or you have to
use the for Loop which I had shown
earlier and print each and every item
within the generator
now this is the output which I was
expecting I was expecting the line by
line output of each and every element in
my generator 4 9 64 and 100.
okay
now this for Loop is taking care that it
is not exceeding the number of items the
length of the items and the generator so
this is automatically taken care by this
syntax
but if you don't take care of it then
you will get an exception let me show
you another example if I create a list
and now I'm creating a generator
which is square
of square of all my elements
so now one by one
instead of the loop I'm one by one
printing the output
second output
third element output
fourth element output
okay I have four now if I try to again
print
I'm exceeding the length of the uh list
I'm gonna get an exception stop
iteration exception because I am
exceeding the length right either I use
the four or if I'm using individual
print and next function then I have to
take care that okay how many elements
are there in the list and I cannot
exceed beyond that else the python will
raise an exception
okay
now I'll show another example of
highlighting the difference between next
and the for Loop printing I'm gonna
create a
uh generator for 2 to the power n so I'm
initializing n with 0 and then just
raising it
2 to the power n
now here I am initializing my generator
and printing it
and I am getting the expected output as
2 raised to the power 0 1 okay
now another way of doing this job is
I Loop over this
and I get the same output so if you see
it's only
I do not have only one element
so either you use for Loop or you print
using next the output is going to be
same
now another important concept which I
talked about if you want to print
infinite infinite numbers so
or you want to do some infinite
calculations I'm going to use print and
all even numbers
so I'm gonna write an generator which is
going to print infinite number of even
numbers
so I have created a generator
and now I'm gonna invoke this and mind
you I have to kill this job because it's
going to keep running
it's going to keep running keep running
because it's constantly generating the
numbers even numbers so I would have to
stop this
but if you see
otherwise this is not possible in any
for Loop the basic for Loop you have to
give a range start and end of the length
but using a generator you can do
infinite
looping
right because here I had to kill this
job I have to do a keyboard interrupt
now I'm going to show you an example of
how you can use generators for creating
a pipeline
so I'm going to take example of
Fibonacci series
create an example of Fibonacci two
variables initialized with zero and one
and now I'm gonna write the logic of
Fibonacci adding the two numbers
to itself
subsequently
and I'm gonna add yield now this is my
generator this is my one generator
and I'm gonna create second generator of
Square
so I'm gonna show you in Excel what
logic I'm going to apply and what will
be my expected output
so I am now squaring the numbers which
I'll get out as an output of Fibonacci
okay
now I'm gonna
I'm creating a pipeline
like this
first I'm gonna generate Fibonacci
series for the first 10 numbers
then I'm gonna find the square of each
of the Fibonacci numbers and add it
so if you see this representation in
Excel I'm going to generate these are
the two variables which I've already
initialized X and Y and from here on
these 10 are my first 10 Fibonacci
numbers
I'm going to find
calculate the square of these numbers 1
4 9 25 and till 55 the square of 3025
and then add these numbers and I should
get the output of 4895 so if you see one
function generator second generator and
the third calculation now this whole has
been done in one single line of code you
have generated created two generators
and just invoked them in a single line
pipeline so entire looping and you know
uh you don't have to write the looping
operators the for Loop and you do not
worry about writing all that complex
logic it is all encapsulated within this
now let me run and I'm going to expect
this output 4895
and here is my output right so in the
hindsight what python has done is it has
generated these Fibonacci numbers pound
the square of these numbers and then
added it in single line
and now this is the convenience
Simplicity which I was talking about
earlier
now let's take another example of
Fibonacci
I'm going to create a generator again
initializing A and B with 0 1
and this time I'm taking an example of
printing the Fibonacci in two different
ways
okay I'm gonna print the first
five Fibonacci series number
the first way I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
print the next function five times
because I'm generating five so let me
run this
these are the first five Fibonacci
number zero one one two and three and I
am also going to use a loop
in order to print
so now in the loop I am invoking the
five Fibonacci numbers
and run it
so either you can
make individual five individual calls or
you can use the for Loop but the output
is the same and you're using a generator
now let's learn about what is scope in
Python
so scope in Python is the area of the
region of a program where you can access
variables functions and objects declared
the scope defines the accessibility of
the Python object so the objects cannot
be accessed from anywhere in the program
variables are not visible to the entire
code so their visibility can be
restricted
now scope verifies which variable to be
accessed a variable declared inside a
function belongs to the local scope of
that function and can only be used
inside that function
now whenever you use a name such as a
variable name or a function name python
will search through different scope
levels or name spaces to determine
whether the name exists or not
so python resolves names using the legb
rule the legb stands for local enclosed
Global and built-in scope
now talking about local scope the
variables which are defined in the
function are called local scope of the
variable so these variables are defined
in the functions body
now talking about enclosing scope now
this scope only exists for nested
functions if the local scope is an inner
or nested function then the enclosing
scope is the scope of the outer or
enclosing function
coming to Global scope
the variable which can be accessed from
anywhere in the program is known as the
global scope such variables can be read
inside or outside the function
now the global scope is often
implemented when we want to use the same
variable name in the rest of the program
coming to the
final rule which is B that is built in
scope so if a variable is not defined in
local enclosed or Global scope then
python looks for it in the built-in
scope now this scope contains names such
as keywords functions exceptions and
other attributes that are built into
python
now if you define the same variable name
inside and outside of a function python
will treat them as separate variables so
two separate variables one available in
the global scope that is outside the
function and the other available in the
local slope that is inside the function
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll try
Scopes in Python with Hands-On
demonstrations
all right so I am on my jupyter notebook
let's start with our examples first we
look at
local scope in Python
for that I am going to create a function
called
f u n
and inside the function I'll create a
variable called
s which holds let's say an object called
simply loan and then
I'm going to
print
the variable that is s now in this case
I have defined my variable
inside the function so this becomes
accessible only
inside the function now if I call the
function using the function name that is
fun
and if we run it you can see we have the
message printed that is simply loan now
we'll see another example
so suppose
we'll try to access it outside the
function it will throw an error so I'll
just give a comment try
to access
it
outside the function
all right so again I'll create
a function called let's say
fun one
we'll give a colon and here I'll say
let's say S1 equal to
simply loan
and now
I'll give a comment here print S1
then I'll call my function f u N1
and
I'll try to
print
the variable S1
outside the function so here S1 has a
local scope since it is defined inside
the function but I'm trying to access
the variable outside the function let's
run it you can see the error here name
S1 not defined
now
if I give a
comment and run this
you see there is no message and let me
just remove this comment and print it
you can see we have the
S1 variable message printed that is
simply loan so this is how the
local scope of a function works
now let's see an example of enclosed
scope which is
function inside another function
so I'll create a function
let's say if you and C
and
I'll use the variable this time S2 equal
to
simply loan
and then
inside the func function I'll Define
another function let's say
i n f u n c which basically stands for
inside function
and then here I'll say print s
S2
and
we'll call the inner function that is in
Fu and C
and then I'll call the outer function
let's run it
and see the result
you can see here we have the message
printed
simply learn I'll just
edit this message let's see
welcome to Simply loan
now if I run this you can see we have
updated the message here
now for the enclosed scope you need to
Define an outer function in closing the
inner function like we did here and you
can also comment out the local variable
of the inner function and refer to the
variable using the non-local keyword let
me show you an example around this
suppose I have a
Global variable called MSG
I'll say this is a
global
scope
message
after that
I'll create a function so I'll Define a
function called
outer
and I'll use the same variable name that
is MSG
and my message would be this is an
outer variable
after that
I am going to Define another function
called
inner
and
this will have
the same variable that is MSG and my
message would be
inner
message
variable
now as I mentioned before I need to
comment out the local variable of the
inner function so I'll just
comment this out
and then
I'm going to say
non-local which is the keyboard
so I am referring to the variable using
the non-local keyword I'll say non-local
my variable name that is MSG
and now
I'll
print MSG
will come out of the function and we'll
call it
inner
after that we'll call the
outer function and then I am going to
print I'll just scroll this down and
we'll say MSG
so here what we are doing is so this is
an example of an enclosed scope so where
we have
defined the outer function including the
inner function and we have commented out
the local variable of the inner function
and we are referring to the variable
using the non-local keyword now let's
run it you see here I have my
to print statements working here the
first one is this is an outer variable
you can see here and then I have print
MSG so this is a global scope message
cool
now
we'll see an example of how the global
scope works though we have already seen
an example above so this was an example
of a global
scope
now we'll see a few more examples around
Global scope again
suppose I have a variable called S3
equal to I'll see
simply loan
and then I'll declare a function
f u n c 1
I give a colon and then say
print
S3
now I'll call the function f u n c one
and will print it
S3
if I run it you can see here I have
simply learned printed twice so I have
used the same variable name S3 inside
the function so
this simply learn is for the local scope
S3 that is this one and outside the
function we have printed S3 again so
simply learn twice
all right
now let me show you another example
about using the Global scope
create a variable MSG one
let's say my messages
welcome to
simply loan
python
programming
I'll Define the function f u and C 2 I
will give a colon
and I'll use the same variable that I
used
or declared above that is mst1
I'll say this is the
inner MSG one variable
then I'm going to print msg1
after that I'll call my function func2
and I'll print
MSG one
if I run this
you can see I have the two messages
printed first is this is the inner msg1
variable and the second print statement
will print the
Global variable
message that is welcome to Simply Learn
Python programming cool
now you can also
use the global keyword inside the
function to convert a local scope into
Global scope
now I'll just give a comment using
Global keyword
so I'll Define my function if you can
see let's say three
I'll give a colon
and using the global keyword
I'll say s
and I'll say s equal to
simply loan
now let me
call Fu and C3
and will print as outside the function
now one thing to remember here my
variable has been declared inside the
function but since before declaring the
variable I have assigned the global
keyword to S so this now becomes a
Global scope variable so you can access
it outside the function as well now if I
run it you can see it here I have my
message printed
simply learn if I say hello you can see
it hello printed
cool
now
we'll see another example of using the
global scope let's say I have a variable
called E1
which is
India
and then
I'll create a function called my country
and I'll use
the
Global keyword and say A1
and after that
I am going to
see E1 equal to
I'll change the country to let's say
France
now let me
call the function my country and will
print
A1
and you can
notice the difference in the result
so here initially I had defined India as
a global variable and after that I'm
assigning the
same variable name with a global keyword
and hence it will take the updated value
for E1 and you can see here the result
is friends
now finally let's look at
built-in scope in Python
this is the final example in the demo
session about Scopes and arguments in
Python
cool
so
this example is a bit different from the
previous few examples that we saw on
local scope enclosed scope and Global
scope so here I am going to
import
PI from the math
module so I'll say from math
import
pi
so this example includes Global scope
enclosed scope as well as local scope
and of course we have the built-in scope
as well
now what I'll do is first I'll
give a comment and
create a variable called
pi
equal to
I'll say
Global pi
variable
I'll say this is a global
Pi variable and then
what I'll do is I'll say
DF let's do one thing first of all we'll
remove
the comment
and now I'll create a
outer function
we'll give a colon and say
dividable pi
I'll say
outer
variable
pi
and then
I'll create
a nested function
with the name inner
and
I'll say pi equal to
inner
by
variable
now
I'm going to say
print
pi
and after that I'll call the
inner function
and
next
I'll also call the
outer function
now if I
run this
you can see the result
inner
Pi variable being printed which is this
print statement
now
what I'll do is
I'm going to comment out the
Global scope variable
and I'll also comment out
the first
outer function variable that I defined
I'll comment this out
and I'll also comment the inner
function y variable
now if I run this
you see the result here
it prints the value of pi that was
imported directly from the math module
or the math Library so here Pi is not
defined in either local
enclosed or
Global scope so the built-in scope is
looked up that is the pi value imported
from the math module so this is an
example of built-in scope in Python that
uses inbuilt
functions modules and objects that are
available in Python
we are going to discuss what are python
modules why do we need to use them what
are the different types of python
modules and how differently in different
ways we can import these modules in our
code
now a python module is nothing but a
simple python file with DOT py extension
including the statements and the
definitions so basically you need to
prepare a module file with all the
functions which you want to import into
your regular python code across all the
modules now it contains codes that you
can reuse in several programs so it's
like saying you write once a piece of
code like common utility methods
calculation methods rounding off
addition subtractions or some common
business rules which can be reused
across your project then you keep it at
one place now this helps in such a
scenario where you have a large team
different set of developers are working
on different different modules different
uh specifications but one single utility
module file dot py file will contains
all the common and reusable functions
which not each and every individual
developer can will go and change it's
only few set of Administrators or the
senior developers can maintain and pass
it on to the team
now for example a file containing python
code demo dot py is will be called as a
module and its module name would be demo
so you need to take care that whatever
the name of the file is that is what
will get imported in your python code so
we will see that with certain examples
on our jupyter notebook now why do we
need to use as I have reiterated it
provides flexibility to organize the
code in a logical way
and it enables reusability which is the
most important factor so one of course
you can organize the code you keep the
reusable code at one place or you can
keep a modular approach and also
reusable so no not all the developers
have to go and rewrite that code and it
is easy to maintain and helps in
debugging the code easily so if you know
that there is an error coming there is
an issue coming in one of the modules
which is imported or which is in line
lying in the common file then it becomes
easy to debug you just have to go and
check that particular function you don't
need to go and check in each and every
piece of code
now there are two types of python
modules definitely there are built-in
modules which python Library provides
which you don't need to import
explicitly but there are certain user
defined modules which you create on
yourself for your own custom development
for your own custom programming
so built-in modules are predefined
modules and are part of this python
standard library for example random date
time says so we will take a look at
these examples also and of course the
user defined modules which is the
primary objective of this session where
we're gonna show you how do you create
your own defined modules and then import
them
so the user creates the user defined
modules to ease complex tasks in a
project so you program The Complex piece
of the code in a common module and give
it to everyone you can Define your own
functions and classes
now what are the different ways there
are five different ways you can import
modules so you can just say import
module name and all the classes and
functions within that module will get
imported you can give an alias so they
basically giving an alias makes it
simple and you can refer that Alias
throughout your code
then if you want to import anything
specific from the entire module you
don't want to import all the functions
and classes then you can just import the
specific functions and classes and give
their name
then fourth is from module you want to
import any address as an alias you can
import and give an alias to the specific
uh function name or the class name
and then of course similar to the first
syntax you can module all everything so
first and the last syntax are almost
having the same meaning to module to
import everything in your module
so with this background uh uh let's
first take a look at the
python file so we have what we have done
is we have created a
module calculations dot py so just
please
focus on the part where the name of the
file is calculations and in this python
file dot py file we have created a
couple of functions and the relevant
logic related to those functions so very
simple functions like addition add you
pass two variables and you send the
result add the variables and send it
back basically we are overriding uh the
python internal operator add in our
python module and we will be invoking
this one so we'll show you how to invoke
then you will have I have written
multiplication
division
remainder so you do you pass two
variables divide them and find the
remainder
then now a custom function where I'm
adding 10 to both the variables which
are being passed to this function and
returning the result
then there is a function which checks
whether the number is a prime and if it
is not a prime number you will get this
output and if it is you will get a is a
prime number
okay
and then another function which says
check anagram
so we will just sort the two strings
which we will send and check both are
equal or not if both are equal then the
strings are anagrams otherwise they are
not
so these are the set of functions which
you have written now we will see how
will we use them in our code
now first syntax which I am writing is
import calculations so this is the name
of my DOT py file which is residing in
the same folder where I am writing this
piece of code
and now
if you see in my
dot py I have a variable y whose value
is 6 so I'm just using that value and
running it and printing it I'm just
gonna
show you how explicitly I am invoking
the functions in the calculations class
in the calculations dot py file okay
now
let's invoke another function remainder
passing 140
and then I should get 20 as an output
okay so this has gone back and executed
this particular function
now what I'm going to do is another
example of my addition I'm saying
calculations dot add
I'm going to initialize and pass two
variables
and my expected output is 35
okay so it has gone and executed
this function
now I'm gonna show you another syntax of
importing so from calculations I'm just
importing the add function
so I'll ask for user input to enter for
one and two numbers and then I'm just
gonna add it
foreign
now the difference to be noted over here
is that in the previous
syntax I was making a call like
calculations dot add but now I don't
need to make a calculations dot add
syntax uh invocation I just need to say
import add
and I just need to use the add function
that's all
now
let's use another syntax to import
modules so I'm using import calculations
as Cal so all the modules are imported
but the Alias uses scalp
and
similarly like the previous example I'm
going to take two inputs
and print the sum
now the difference in this syntax in
this syntax is I'm using the Alias Cal
dot add but my output should be seen
okay
similarly I can call
Prime
whether it's not a prime or prime number
I can call the check anagram using the
same alias
and I can call the remainder function
okay
so I hope you have noticed that the
difference
in importing the way of importing the
module makes a lot of difference right
now let's take another example of
importing some functions or variables
so I'm gonna explicitly I'm importing my
variable Y and functions multi Prime and
check anagram explicitly
and
I'm gonna print y
okay
and I'm gonna multiply two numbers
so if you see I'm using these aliases
over here okay I'm using these variables
directly as I've already imported
now I'm going to say Prime 9
now it's printing none if you see it's
because of the statements which are not
executed right so that's why you are
seeing now let's check anagram
and now another thing to be noted is I'm
trying to invoke a function remainder
which I have not imported over here so
let's see how what error python throws
okay so yeah so python is throws an
error that name remind remainder is not
defined because I have not imported it
over here
so now in order to import remainder what
I am now doing different is importing
all the functions
now if I use remainder it should run
okay
I am using divide
okay cool now
I'm gonna show you another function
which is a utility function directory
function which will show me all the
functions
variables as part of the Python file add
at 10 check in a gram divide multi Prime
remainder Y and of course these are some
inbuilt packages uh which are already
there in the python file as part of the
Python loader but these are the ones
which I have created so you can actually
see the list of all those uh functions
in one go
okay
now I'm gonna show you an example of
inbuilt
modules so this import math is an invent
module of python
and I'm gonna show you
how you can see all the relevant
functions within the math module all
these are the math module functions
which are available for you to use I'm
going to show you one or two
so like
print math 2 to the power 8
and you get the answer 256.
print math remainder so I'm not invoking
my module function and invoking the math
inbuilt Library function remainder
and the remainder is 0 40 divided by 2
remainder is 0. and square root of 81
then very important another very
interesting utilities of date time which
you can use and you can print today's
date and time
then another
utility is random utility
and I'm gonna create a list L1
write a piece of code which will choose
a random element from this list
and just print it
okay so if first time it has chosen Oppo
again if I run it it will choose one
plus if I again run it it might choose
something else so it will randomly pick
okay
okay so with this we have seen that you
can create your own utility functions
import it write it in a piece of code.py
file import it in your code as an alias
or all the modules and use them or you
can use the python inbuilt uh modules
right
today let's quickly take a glance we are
going to talk about map function filter
function and reduce function we're going
to see the syntax which are applicable
to these functions and what benefits
these functions bring for us
during the programming in Python so
we're going to see the syntax and we are
going to run certain examples for each
of these functions
so let me first just give you a brief of
what are the Syntax for these functions
what are the signatures what are the
input parameters required and then we
will jump into the jupyter notebook and
run some examples
so what is a map function the map
function takes another function as an
input and the second input is a sequence
of iterables it could be a list it could
be a set it could be an array or
anything you want and it Returns the
output after executing the function
which you have passed as a parameter on
each of the element of that iterable so
the function could add the values could
multiply could divide or any
mathematical operation you want to do or
even you can perform certain string
operations which we will take a look in
the examples but the idea is that you
want to apply the function on each and
every iterable item individually so the
map function helps you achieve that
also in our examples we will take a look
that you don't need to explicitly Define
a function you can also use Lambda
functions which are inline functions uh
so you don't need to increase the line
of code you can reduce the lines of Code
by just writing the function in line and
that way it will make it more simple
[Applause]
[Music]
the next function which we are going to
talk about is the filter function now
what is the purpose the purpose of the
filter function is to reduce the size of
the iterables based on the condition
which you will pass to the filter
function so syntactically it is very
similar to map function but the only
difference is that you need to pass a
function which carries a condition for
example you have a set of iterables one
two three four five six seven eight nine
and you want the function to return
values which are greater than 5. so your
filter function should have a condition
which says that the iterables greater
than 5 should only be returned by this
function so that's why you have to make
sure that a filter function always have
a condition which is either true or
false So based on whatever condition
matches as true the filter function will
only return those values as an output so
we will take a look and the same uh
concept applies either you can make a
explicit function or you can apply
Lambda function in line
the third function which we are going to
talk about is the reduce function the
only difference between reduce function
and the other functions which we talked
about uh the map and filter is that
reduce function always returns a single
value so it combines all the values in
the either able your list your array
your set and returns a single value so
you can apply the mathematical functions
like for example you want to add all the
values in your writerable or you want to
multiply so it will multiply
sequentially and give you the output
and the same
concept applies over here you can have
Lambda functions or explicit functions
also with one thing which you need to
remember is that you need to use
function tools module to to import the
reduce function
so we will take a look at that while we
will be running certain examples
foreign
so we will start by running our examples
so first we will start with map
so let's start by
defining a very simple function which
adds
two values
right and returns you the added value
right
so in the next step
we will Define a
list of iterables so here we have taken
an algebra list of four items four six
eight nine numbers
now in this step we will apply the map
function now please notice that we are
sending two parameters to this map
function one is the function name which
is ADD and the list which is numbers
okay now I'll print the out foreign
but it's an object so right it's not in
a readable format so I need to convert
the out object back to a list
and now I'll be able to print
and here is my expected output so I had
four numbers in my list which is 4 6 8 9
and the map function have has added the
numbers to itself four plus four six
plus six eight plus eight nine plus nine
and so that's how you're getting the
output as expected
[Music]
now let's take a look at another example
we're going to redefine our list and we
are going to use now a Lambda function
instead of an explicit function which is
going to multiply the numbers in my list
with it with themselves
and we're gonna
uh print my out object
convert it back to a list
and then I'll print my
converted list object
and here you go this is my output 4
multiplied by 4 6 multiplied by 6 8
multiplied by 8 and 9 multiplied by nine
okay so here in this example we have
seen about Lambda function now we have
you know performing mathematical
operation as I mentioned earlier we can
also perform certain string operations
so let's take an example
what I'm doing in this example is I'm
creating a map and I'm just converting
all my lowercase strings to uppercase
and I can just printing my list now
after conversion
so such kind of uh you know string
operations are also possible
let's take another example where we are
gonna print the length of each of the
string which is there in my list
and I'm using Lambda function
and here it is
so now you can see the list
the length of each and every string
variable Mill is 3 5 6 and 7.
okay so now these were the examples of
map object map function now we will talk
about
filter
so let's start with a simple example so
as I mentioned the filter function
should help always have a condition
so let's create a function which has a
condition saying if a is greater than 5
then return a it means that you need
to only return numbers which are greater
than 5 in my list
so now I'm gonna call this in my filter
function
so if you see the syntax here please
notice filter you pass the fill and the
list
and then you print the out object after
converting into the list
and only the numbers which are greater
than 5 are printed
now let's take a look at a Lambda
function example rather than an explicit
function
the same example but now instead I am
using a Lambda function
and I'm gonna print it output should be
the same
okay so the the only change is in the
syntax of the function definition here
we have explicit function and here we
have a Lambda function output is the
same
now let's take an example of
a string operation string filter what
kind of string filtering we can do so I
have an example over here
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
have a list of string arrays which is
going to return me only those strings
which have e in them occurrence of e
okay
so I've created a function veggies with
E and within this list of veggies peas
garlic ginger beetroot carrot I will
only get those string variate values
which have e in it
thank you
okay so I've got the result p is ginger
and beetroot right and garlic and carrot
have been discarded
now let's run this similar example with
Lambda function where I'm saying that
okay give me those vegetables which have
r in it so I'm just gonna run this
and print my map
[Music]
okay and here is my expected output
garlic ginger beetrooter carrot
so what have we noticed is that similar
to map filter function of course the
only difference is the function should
have a condition which should return a
true or false and based on that the
iterable list get filters out
now
let's talk about reduce
now as I mentioned the first important
thing is that we
import the reduce function from function
tools okay and then we apply a
Lambda function so we're going to start
off with just taking an example of
Lambda so here is my list of four
elements 10 35 50 and 20 and I'm adding
the numbers in this list okay so so the
map function is not gonna the reduce
function is not going to add the numbers
to itself but to the subsequent number
in the list right
so what is the expected output right the
expected output is 10 plus 35 45
plus 50 95 plus 20 115 so what the
reduce function has done is it has added
the numbers in the list amongst
themselves right in the orderly fashion
now let's take another example instead
of addition we'll do a multiplication
okay
so here what we have done is we have
multiplied 9 by into 7 into 23 into 4
and we've got this answer
so this is another way of doing it
now instead of Lambda function I'm just
going to show you a simple
um adding the numbers
Define a function where you add the
first and second number
and then
you pass the function name
to reduce so custom sum and the list
similar to what we have done for map and
filter
and now you can print the result
now one thing to notice is that this
result is a single number you don't need
to convert it back to a list so you
don't need to do that transformation you
just
simply print the result
and here it is 68 3 plus 4 plus 6 Plus 9
plus 34 Plus 12.
okay
we're gonna start with discussion of
need of exception handling what is
exception handling the types of Errors
you can handle in exception handling and
how exception handling works and in the
end certain points to be remembered and
also we will support our slides with a
python jupyter notebook examples
now what is the need for exception
handling any programming language or any
program you write there is definitely a
need in order to have a clean execution
of the program even if the program
throws errors so you need exception
handling for cleanly logging the
exceptions or throwing meaningful errors
to the users
so when does exception occurs right
whenever the program gets terminated
right the program terminates whenever an
error occurs right so it could happen
that an error could be a fatal error and
the program gets terminated in between
or there could be a certain termination
which can corrupt the program right so
you need to handle exceptions or they
may be they might be a data loss because
of those exceptions and you need to take
care that that doesn't occur or the data
loss does not happen or even if data
loss happens then you pass on a
meaningful message or you capture a
meaningful message in the logs at the
right point
now what is exception handling an
exception is a runtime error that
terminates the execution of a program
so basically whenever an exception
occurs the program gets terminated you
are thrown out of the running program
exception handling means you generate a
message in correspondence to the
occurrence of the error and take the
right step to handle it so now an
exception has occurred but you need to
handle it now by handling we mean that
you need to throw a meaningful message
as I said earlier and then you might
need to navigate the program into the
right direction or take some certain
corrective actions in order to handle
the error so all that comes under the
exception handling criteria
now in general there are three types of
Errors compile time errors logical
errors and runtime errors now compile
time errors are the errors which any
programming compiler or python compiler
will show you while you are compiling
your program so it could be because of
the syntax spacing
indentation or you would you you are
using wrong keywords all those will get
captured at the compile time logical
errors you know you have not used the
correct syntax around logical operators
like and or or your if else conditions
are incorrect and you are expecting an
output but it is not coming as per your
expectations so those are logical errors
and the most difficult ones to capture
and track and handle are the runtime
errors so imagine your program is
compiled and as per your expectation uh
you are expecting an output you have you
know written a logic but at the runtime
it does not gets executed it does not
run as per your expectation and the
program gets terminated unexpectedly so
the the runtime errors are the most
critical and important in order to
handle them and if you talk about
runtime errors handling in production
scenarios then it becomes very critical
that you have handled the exceptions
correctly and captured the logs
correctly so that the support team can
point out uh where the error has exactly
happened
now how exception handling works
there are certain syntaxes in Python
which you need to follow
now you generally put the uh exception
handling code the code for which you you
want to handle the exception under a try
block so you run that piece of code
under a try block and then you put an
accept keyword where you basically throw
an error message
and then if there is no exception right
then also you can handle the code okay
if there is no exception in my code then
how the code will behave yeah right so
it could be possible that there is a
runtime error but if there is no then
you might want to do some logical uh
calculations or you want to put
something over there you can put in the
else block and then finally now finally
is a code block which will always get
executed irrespective of you had an
exception in your code or not so
basically generally uh if you go by the
Legacy programming if you have opened a
database connection uh or if you have
opened a file and you it is essential to
close those connections uh from your
program then those close connection code
are written generally in the finally
block irrespective of the except
exception coming you need to close those
connections otherwise you will run out
of your connection pools
now it's a pretty straightforward
flowchart of an exception and handling
you start with a try block and then if
an exception occurs in your code then it
will go to the accept block otherwise it
will go in the else section and then
finally you have the finally block where
the code will finally get executed and
stop
so as I said you put that piece of code
in the finally block which is mandatory
and generally the block the code which
is essential to release the resources
which the program has consumed uh the
CPU resources the memory resources
Hardware Resources with the program is
using you have to release that in the
finale block accept block you have to
use for capturing the error and through
a meaningful message or
do any other logical operation and else
block if you want to continue your
program as is
now what are the points to remember
these are very important points which
you should consider you can write a try
block without any except block so it's
not essential that you put a accept
block always
or you can write several except blocks
for a single try you might be expecting
a null pointer exception or a divide by
zero exception or incorrect variable
naming exception so you can start off
with one try but you can have different
except blocks to capture these different
kind of exceptions and throw a relevant
meaningful error per accept block also
you can write multiple accept blocks to
handle multiple exceptions it's almost
the same thing and you can write
exception as an object you can also uh
print or capture an exception as an
object or you can write multiple
exceptions within a tuple you can
capture the multiple exceptions added to
a tuple and throw it away okay so now
let's take a look at uh certain examples
which we want to run in order for better
understanding of exception handling
now throughout my exercise I am gonna
focus on divide by zero error which we
are easily able to simulate so I'm gonna
mostly show you how we can capture a
divide by zero error
foreign
now I am trying to divide a by B now I'm
trying to divide a number with 0 so
ideally yes this is not a correct
mathematical operation divide by number
zero uh is not allowed
so I should get a zero division error
now
this is an unhandled exception my
program has not handled it properly so
that's why you're getting this error on
the uh trace of the Python Trace but
if I handle it properly
then I can very cleanly
throw this error and capture this error
so
I'm gonna take input in B enter A and B
and
I'm just gonna print a generic accept
block
so 10
and I have got an exception and I have
printed it now there is no stack Trace
there is no Trace but at least I am able
to cleanly throw an error a meaningful
error
now
again I'm definitely going to handle the
exception
I'm gonna create the same exception but
gonna handle it differently
now there's a try block
now I am
writing an accept block to capture
the specific exception zero division
error exception
in the earlier code block I had just
written except so any exception would
have come to this block but in this
except block only zero division error
will be captured
so as you can see uh I cleanly
uh handle the exception of course I gave
the names except zero division error and
then my code got executed
later on
now in another example
what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna show you that if my code runs
cleanly then it's not necessary my
except block will get executed
definitely because if there is no error
then the accept block will remain
redundant
all right
now here you see what I have done is
I've taken genuine two numbers
divided them printed a new line and then
completed so as there was no exception
the exception block did not got executed
foreign
to be highlighted over here is that it
is not essential that you know exception
block will get executed always it will
only come into picture when there is a
relevant exception getting generated
now let's take an example of how
Vivo can print an exception object
so I'm gonna take my previous code
and here I am
capturing the exception but also
printing the exception object
so what has happened is I have printed
the exception of a message a custom
message plus I have printed the
exception object
okay
now I'm gonna take the same example
but I'm not gonna generate an exception
thank you
so my exception block did not got
executed and I was able to Simply print
simply learn
now
let's take another example
where I am
capturing my exception in in a variable
so do not divide number by zero
in this x I have captured my exception
division by zero
so in the exception the python generated
exception name is this and I have
printed over here so division by zero is
the python generated exception which I
have appended in the print command
now I am going to take another example
where I'm saying is that I will print
exception as a plus I'm gonna also
capture another exception so it's like
one try and two exceptions
foreign
so one exception is do not divide number
by 0 and second exception is name Z is
not defined right
so I'm so as I said earlier you can have
one try but two accept blocks which is
permissible
now one thing is that you know you this
exception print a by Z
came uh went through both the accept
blocks except this exception and this
exception though this exception is not
divided by zero error so therefore
therefore in this a variable nothing
came in but in the B variable the name
error was definitely captured because
it's a name undefined name Z is not
defined error and that's why you can see
that do not divide number by zero up
after that we do not have any relevant
meaningful message
okay
now let's take another example where
we are going to have
two except blocks and out of these two
only one will get executed
okay so there is no type error exception
so that accept block did not got
executed but only zero division error is
there so only that got printed
now you can explicitly also raise an
exception it's not like you just have to
wait for a runtime exception you can
also raise your X raise an exception
from your code and execute it so if you
see this what we have done is just
created a variable with a negative value
and just checking that if the value is
less than zero then raise an exception
so that's what we have done
similarly you can also throw raise an
assertion error
it's it is called assert
and you can run
this message you can throw this message
compatible with Linux only
we will understand what is file handling
we will go through certain file handling
operations
then we will understand how to open a
file in Python using various modes which
are pretty important
and then we will discuss the file
handling process the different types of
files which we can create and advantages
of using files
now what is file handling
a file contains a collection of data and
information it is just like a data
storage
so the data can be updated and shared
through files with multiple stakeholders
now file handling in Python performs
functions such as creating reading
updating and deleting so you can perform
the basic crud operations using the file
handling functions and operators
now in Python file operation takes place
in the following model
in order to work on a file you have to
first open a file that is the first and
foremost step and then you can perform
an e-read or write operation and then
you have to close the file
so these three primary steps are
involved in order to do any operation on
a file
now in Python we can work with files
using the open function and it takes two
parameters the file name and the mode
so here you can see the syntax if you do
not give the mode parameter then it
takes the default values which we're
gonna see in our next slide
but at least you need to give the name
of the file with the extension now what
are the various modes in which you can
perform operations on a file let's go
through them one by one
you can open a file first of all in the
read mode which is the default mode
and it opens a file for reading
but if the file does not exist it throws
an error
right second is append a it opens a file
for appending creates the file if it
does not exist so in this mode if the
file does not exist exists it gets
created similarly in the right operation
it opens a file for writing and creates
the file if it does not exist so A and W
will create the file X it creates
specified file returns an error if the
file exists so you cannot create an
already existing file you need to give a
different name then the next mode is the
T mode the text mode which is the
default value so so by default when you
open a file in Python you are basically
opening it in default read text mode
and the next mode is the binary mode if
you specify B it means that you're
trying to open an image or any binary
mode related file which cannot be opened
in a text mode so we will see certain
examples of these modes in our Jupiter
notebook when we will run certain
examples on our sample file now what is
the file handling process right so in in
a plain vanilla process first of course
you will create a file and then you will
open a file update and close the file so
the first thing which you can do but in
the from the function standpoint like we
saw in our previous slide even if you
have to create a file you have to call
the function open then you have to read
it you write in it and then you close it
first thing which you have to do in
order to uh interact with the file is
always make a call to the open function
and then you pass the file name and the
mode as a parameter
now as we discussed there are two modes
there are two types of files in Python
text file and binary file so in text
file the data is stored in characters
and string and in binary file this data
is stored in the form of bytes but the
bytes file which you store you can store
in a different extension and it can be
read by other utilities or tools or
softwares which are meant for reading
the binary files but you can interact or
you can
performs certain functions using the
python operators and the open functions
which are available text file is a
simple uh concept you open the file you
can write append update the data and you
can open the file in your operating
system and see your changes so we are
going to perform our examples on a text
file where we will show you how you can
view your changes by opening a file real
time
now there are some preliminary
advantages basic advantages of using
files your this data is stored and is
permanent basically it resides in the
file and then it is up to you how do you
save the data in the file in the
operating system or you purchase the
data in some uh secure area and that is
up to you and the stored data can be
shared definitely you can mail the data
you can share it in your hard drive you
can share your network drive Etc and you
can update the data in the file so you
can append you can override you can
remove you can delete the file all those
operations all those possibilities are
there
so now let's
create our jupyter notebook
with certain examples
so what I have done here is I have
already created certain sample files
where I have some predefined context
there
so I have a
simply learn.text file in which I have
written today's Thursday in one line
tomorrow is Friday and I am waiting for
weekend
now I'm gonna read this file
I'll import the package in order to read
the file
I'll create the file object now in this
I have given the path where my file is
residing today.txt the same content is
there
and I'm going to be opening it in the
read mode so it's the default mode but
I'm calling it out explicitly for a
better understanding
now this is the read command file dot
read
this operator this will read the entire
file so if you see in my file all the
contents are printed
now
if I want to read
the first seven characters
foreign
so what will this do it will read the
first seven characters of the first line
of my file so in the First Command my
file.read printed all the contents
but here I have passed a parameter to
the read function to print only the
first character seven characters
so that's what it has done
now
I will
ask
my function
to read
line by line
so now what is the difference between
this and this the difference is that the
file dot read the entire file in one go
but here
it is allowing me to read only one line
at a time
okay
so this function of read line will only
go and read the
line
now
if I have to read all lines one by one
write down here I have printed one line
now I want to print all lines one by one
then there is a different
function
which is file dot read lines
and it will print an array
and of course you can see there's a
slash n operator because it's a
different line so it will print my diff
three different lines in an array
today's Thursday tomorrow is Friday and
I am waiting for weekend
now like I gave this example of file dot
read seven characters in the similar
fashion
I can also
provide how many characters to read
from the line
let's see
correct so from the first line it has
given me the first three characters and
here in the file dot read it was
starting to reading starting to read the
entire file but I only limited to the
seven characters
now let's take a look
at the
right function
write method
so now in my today.txt file I now pass
the mode w
and I'll
override it
with my new content which is the Sunday
and Monday
and see file.clues
and run it
now I can go
and check it's been overwritten
now
I'm gonna create a new file
let me
create a new file and
add contents to that
uh I'll create simply 2.txt and run
and a new file has got created with the
content sunshine
so here I have passed the mode as X
now
I want to delete a file
I will just simply pass
OS dot remove there is no open function
to be called and just give the name of
the file
and my 2d.txt file is got
even I can put a check before removing a
file whether the file exists or not
if it exists then remove
else print that the file does not exist
there is no file
foreign
by line I'll show you one in another
example if I want to print line by line
then the example is import
ant and file dot in the loop and
you print the output
so basically you can if you want to
print the lines in a loop then you need
to put the for command for Loop and put
the red lines call
we will discuss what is sorting in
Python what is the importance of sorting
we will discuss different sorting
algorithms like bubble sort insertion
sort merge sort and quick sort with
examples
what is sorting
sorting refers to arranging available
data in a particular format
so typically when you have data in a
non-sorted order generally there is a
requirement in any algorithm where you
would require the data to be organized
either in ascending or descending order
so if you take an example which is there
available on the presentation here you
have a list L1 where you have random
numbers which are unsorted and then you
have a sorted array which is in
descending order means highest number
First and the lowest later so generally
any algorithm which you implement for
sorting provides you a organized
sorted list either in descending or
ascending order
now why is sorting important
now you must have seen practically in
your day-to-day life whenever you are
navigating through a website or through
an application you generally tend to or
you want to see data in a sorted order
either alphabetically or numerically it
makes search faster and easier right
it's it becomes easy to search an item
benefit it is sorted alphabetically
sorting is also used to represent data
in more readable format so it allows you
to read the data which is sorted easily
it helps locate various patterns in the
data so for example if you have an
alphabetically sorted data then you can
easily compare if there is a difference
in pattern in the data which is lying in
an Excel sheet or which is shared with
you in any other data format
also and
another important point is duplicate
values you can easily find out if there
is an occurrence of a duplicate value
when the data is provided to you in a
sorted fashion so all the basic
utilities Standalone utilities
applications like Microsoft Excel or
other utilities provide you basic
functionality of sorting of data
alphabetically or numerically
now python has a built-in sorting method
which is called as sorted and it gives
you a data in ascending order whatever
input you provide the list it will give
you data in ascending order
and python uses a Time series sorting
algorithm in build
to
perform this sorting
so let's take a look of the inbuilt
Sorting algorithm which we have gonna
show you on my jupyter notebook
so it's gonna be very straightforward
what we are going to do is we are going
to create a list
and just
invoke the list dot sort method and
print it
and just with one line of function call
our list is sorted in
ascending order 12 15 27 33 62.
now
with this inbuilt function if you want
to
change the Sorting order right you want
to reverse it in descending order you
just have to pass a parameter saying
reverse equal to 2 true and print the
list so if You observe now you have your
output in the descending order
so this is an inbuilt function the
sorted method but we are here to discuss
custom sorting algorithm and we will
start with bubble sort
now what is bubble sort in bubble sort
algorithm the first element is compared
with the adjacent element and if the
adjacent element is smaller than the
first element the elements are swapped
basically bubble sort is a sorting
algorithm that compares two adjacent
elements and swaps them until they are
not in the intended order
so just like the movement of air bubbles
in the water that rise up to the surface
each element of the array move to the
end in each iteration therefore it is
called a bubble sort
it is the simplest sorting algorithm
that works by repeatedly swapping the
adjacent elements if they are in wrong
order
so we have to remember the point that
they the elements in the array are
swapped till the time the intended order
is reached and the
each element has reached to the last
iteration
so we will see this with an example
now here you have a sample list which
has unsorted data 9864.
now according to the bubble sort
algorithm what it will do is first it
will start from the zeroth element and
compare it with its next adjacent
element 8. now in this scenario
it is smaller than 9 so therefore we
will swap it so 8 and 9 will get swapped
and now you have 8964
now again 9 will be
compared with its adjacent 6 and now 6
is smaller than 9 it will be swapped
coming down 9 now compared with 4
is smaller than 9 it will be swapped so
till this point what has happened is 9
has been compared and
with each of its adjacent element and in
this iteration now 9 is at its correct
place it's at its last place now we
don't need to go to this iteration again
we will only go till the
second last iteration so now we will
start from the beginning we will compare
eight with six
okay and 6 is smaller than 8 we will
swap so now your output is six eight
four nine
again it is compared with four four is
smaller than 8 it is swapped now we will
not go further because now we know 9 is
at its correct position
it is at its correct position now only
we need to do one iteration of
comparison between six and four now four
is less than 6 we swap and this is the
final output of four six eight nine nine
so all the iterations depend on the size
of the list but the
in bubble sort the whole goal is that
you keep it iterating till the time each
and every element is compared with its
adjacent element now let's write a piece
of code in Jupiter in order to compare
our
algo what we have discussed
okay so what I'll do is I'll just create
a list of elements
now this is the list which I showed in
my example and I want to sort it
so I'll create a function
bubble sort
and I'll capture the length of the array
now
I need two Loops one Loop which will run
n number of times the length of the
array
so I'll create a loop
okay
and then there will be a second
iteration which will run
from the first element of the array to
the
last element okay
less one less than the last element till
the time
I have
placed my sorted last element in the
array so I'll show you that
now in my example I'll print
my
ji iterator and the adjacent element to
it
okay now
what we have to do is we just have to
write now the the condition that if
the element
to which my inner loop is pointing is
greater than the next element then we
will swap
now in Python it's there is a very easy
way to write the swap code
you
are swapping the two adjacent elements
with each other so you just have to
write this line
and now this piece of code will place at
J position the adjacent element of J
plus 1 and at the adjacent element it
will put the previous element
now just to
show you I'll print the array at
unsorted and sorted level so I'll print
the array over here and here so that you
can easily understand how the array has
been
sorted
okay so now you have a one Loop which is
running for the number of times the
length of the array and then the inner
loop which is running from every time
from the first element to the one less
element
length okay
now let me run this
okay
okay so now what we have done is
now I'll explain my example okay
so what we have done is we have 9864
okay now the length of this array is one
two three four so the element the length
will be n will be four
my outer loop will run from 0 to 4 from
4 times 1 2 3 4 and now my inner loop J
Will
run six times and I'll show you how so
now first J at 0 and its adjacent
element is at one so what we are doing
is we are comparing 9 with 8
and 8 is smaller than 9 9 is greater
than 8 we are swapping it so now this is
my unsorted array and this is my sorted
array so 9 and 8 are swapped you have
eight nine six four
now I move ahead
J is incremented to 1 and the adjacent
element is incremented to two so now I
am comparing 9 with 6 as 6 is smaller
than 9 I swap it so now my next set or
array is eight six nine four
now I go to J2 and adjacent 3 so 9 and 4
I compare nine and four four is smaller
than 9 I swap it now till this iteration
now 9 has reached its correct position
now I'll go back again and start
my iteration from j0 back again and go
only till this element 4 so again I am
comparing 8 with 6 6 is smaller I swap
then now I'm comparing 8 with 4 4 is
smaller I swap now 8 has reached its
correct position
again now
I am going back to zero and I will only
go to the point of 4 I compare 6 and 4 4
is smaller and I get my sorted list of
four six eight nine now if You observe
the number of iterations which have
happened are one two three four five six
it's because 9 has traversed three times
it has traversed two times and 6s
Travers one time three plus two plus one
six iterations so that's how you get
those iterations
so this was an example of bubble sort
now let's take example of insertion sort
now what is insertion sort let's talk
about that
insertion sort places a given element at
the right position in a sorted list
so in the beginning We compare the first
two elements and sort them by comparing
them
now let me show you
how what I mean by insertion sort
now in insertion sort whatever list you
have the first element is always
considered to be sorted and the rest of
the other elements are assumed to be
unsorted so you start your comparison of
first element with the
with its adjacent element right now just
to simplify things
insertion sort is like it's like playing
cards like you Shuffle the cards and
sort your cards playing cards uh in your
hand it's just like that okay so the
array is virtually split into sorted and
unsorted parts values from the unsorted
parts are picked and placed at the
correct position in the sorted part
so now in our example our sorted part is
8 and unsorted is 4 6 and 9. now in the
second iteration we will compare four
with eight now four is smaller than 8 we
will put it before 8 and now we have
sorted list of 4 and 8 and unsorted list
of six and nine
now in the next iteration we will
compare six with eight
okay and if 6 is smaller than 8 we will
insert it before 8 but and also we will
compare six with four but now 6 is
greater than 4 we will not swap it
now my list is four six eight nine
and four six eight is sorted and 9 is
unsorted now again I'll compare 9 with 8
and it's already greater than 8 I don't
need to swap it and I'll not go any
further and I'll stop it over here so
that's how my sorted list will get
created so my final list is four six
eight nine
and I'll we'll see that with an example
so now let's create our insertion sort
logic
so in my example I want to create an
array eight four six nine fifteen twelve
and I want to create a function called
insertion sort
okay
now it's pretty simple you want to
Traverse
through the entire length of the array
but you want to start from element one
not from 0 because 8 is your sorted
element you are already considering it
your sorted element
now
take a variable in which you capture the
outer array and now I'm putting a while
loop with two conditions one is
definitely the one which I explained
that you compare the unsorted element
with this sorted element so the previous
element and you go till the point on the
sorted side till the last element you
don't need to go beyond zero right you
need to only Traverse through the first
element which is as the zeroth index
and if you
then you of course
put the
swapping code
you swap
the unsorted
element with the sorted side and
you need to go
so from the right hand side you are
going towards the left hand side of the
array right from right towards left so
that's why you need to decrease the
number okay so what are we doing over
here what we are doing is we are
comparing 4 2 with 8 now if 8 is greater
than 4 you swap
and you only go to the point you have
index 0 okay like now if 4 and 8 will
get swapped now 6 will come 6 will
compare itself with eight
it is smaller it will swap 6 will
compare itself with four
and it will stop over there so let me
show you I'll put a print command
so that
it is easy to understand
so let me print the array
over here and see
okay so what I've done is I have to
print my array
okay
so this is my original array eight four
six nine fifteen twelve eleven now in
first time I compare 4 with 8 and swap
it
then I compare six with eight it's
smaller I swap it but 6 and also compare
six with four I don't swap it
then
I compare
9 with 8 it is not small I don't swap it
and I stop it over there
then I compare 12 with 9 it is not small
I stopped it over there then I compare
11 with 12 it is small I swap it right
and then of course 15 I compare with 12
I stop it because it's already bigger so
it is like you divide you always follow
the approach of sorted and unsorted like
I presented and you keep comparing with
the so unsorted a side element with the
sorted side element and keep moving
towards the left hand side
so now let's discuss another sorting
algorithm called merge sort
now merge sort is a divide and conquer
algorithm
so basically in merge sort you first
divide the list into equal parts and
then sort the parts and unite them as a
sorted list so basically you split the
list into halves and then keep
huffing them reducing each half till the
time there is a single element in each
half and then you start merging them
back in a sorted fashion
so we will discuss this with an example
over here
now is for an example we have our list
with unsorted numbers 8 4 6 and 9. now
as it is even number of items in this
list so they will get distributed into
two equal halves in the left half you
have eight and four and in the right
half you have six and nine
now again recursively you will split
each half the left half and the right
half again till the time you have single
elements so now you see eight and four
now again gets split into individual
element of 8 4 and 6 and 9 into 6 and 9.
now you start merging the individual
elements in a sorted fashion so first
you will compare 8 and 4 now 4 is less
than 8 so you swap and put 4 first and
eight at the second position
similarly when you compare 6 and 9 9 is
greater than 6 then the order of this
particular set remains as is 6 and 9 are
taken into the new array now you have
two merged halves which are in sorted
order four and eight and six and nine
now while merging you compare the left
most elements of each array so first you
will compare four and six
so four and six now six is greater than
4 you place four and six at their
correct positions
now you compare now eight with nine now
eight is the left most item in the array
and nine is the leftmost item in its own
array and both are in the sorted fashion
so that's why you put 8 and 9 at their
relevant position and this is your
sorted output
so definitely we will take a look at the
example with our implementation in
jupyter Notebook
okay so now let me take my list example
which had shown in the presentation
I want to perform a merge sort on this
list okay
okay so I'll create a function
merge sort
and I'll start off with checking
that the list length of my list is
greater than one if it is a single
element then I don't need any sorting
now
I'll find the midpoint of my list
and take
the left part of the array
list and the right part of the list
so the convention which I am using is
actually automatically taking means that
the list starts from 0 till the midpoint
and the list here will start from
midpoint to the length of my list it's
the same convention so you can keep zero
or not it's up to you
and the length of my list I have the
double slash 2 means that
if the list is of
odd number then it will divide by two
and round it up to the nearest integer
so you will not get the decimal output
so we will get a integer rounded mid
value
now after I have done this I will
recursively call the left array
and the right array
in my into this merge sort so using this
I'll be able to get the split value of
8469 and I'll you this with this
recursions I will reach to the point
where I'll get individual elements of 8
4 6 and 9.
now
I have two iterate through the left
array and the right array so I'll create
two variables which will help me iterate
through left and right
array
and I am also initializing a variable
which I'll keep as a counter
for populating a new array which will
comprise of my merged
list okay
so now
this is the logic I will loop from left
element
from 0
to index told the length of the left
array and zeroth index to the length of
the right array and I'll compare
if the left is less than equal to
the right it means I already have my
value in the sorted order I'll just add
it to my merged array and put it at the
kth position
and
increment my left array
further
else
else I have to pick up the right array
element so if the left array is smaller
and greater then right array then I put
it the left one in the merged list or if
the right one is smaller than the left
one then I merged put it in the merge
list and increment my
right list
now while after this conditions are done
I increment my
merged list incrementer okay I move
ahead
now there could be a possibility that
there might be some elements which might
remain
uncompared in the left list like for
example if this would have been an odd
number of uh elements then here would
have been three and two then one element
will remain uncompared so then I need to
iterate through the remaining left array
and just put them in my merge list
I and K by one
and same could be the possibility of the
right array that there might be some
Elements which might remain uncompared
or you know unsorted in the right array
so I'll put them back in my
merge list
so my list is my
list which I am
updating constantly
so now let me put some
prints when I'll run this
code I want to put some print out so
that I can explain
where my
list is now this is my merge sort and
I'm gonna run this
foreign
the list got split into eight and four
and nine and six
okay
now
okay sorry let me just make it similar
eight four and six nine
then in the second recursion I have
eight as a single element 4 as a signal
element and in the third recursion I
have six as in single element and nine
as a single element
now after that
my this logic gets executed where I
compare left and right elements and
emerge them okay so now I compare four
with eight and four is less than eight I
swap it move four to the left common
array and then eight then ins in this
case six and nine they're already in the
sorted fashion I just move it into my
common list my list and again now 4 8
and 6 and 9 are compared the leftmost
element is 4 compared with 6 it's
shorter smaller it is put it in the
common list eight and nine eight and
nine are smaller it is quoted in the
common list and you have the sorted
array
so this is the idea behind a merge sort
where you have divided the list to the
nth element to the zeroth element and
then you start merging it back by
comparing the leftmost elements now
let's take an example of another sorting
algorithm called quick sort
quick sort like merge sort is also a
divide and conquer algorithm but in a
different way
in quick sort first you choose a pivot
element in the array then store elements
less than the pivot in the left sub
array and greater than the pivot in the
right sub array and then keep doing this
activity recursively for each subsequent
left and right array which you have done
after that
we will call quick sort on the left sub
array and similarly we will call quick
sort on the right sub array so it's a
recursive algorithm based on the choice
of the pivot element which you have
taken on the array generally the pivot
element is generally taken as the right
most element of the array
now let me try to explain quick sort
with an example over here and then we
will look into the python code
now I have an array with six elements
where my last element is my Pivot
so now what I have to do is I have to
create a left array where all the
elements smaller than 34 should get
aligned and then I have to create a
right array which should be having
elements greater than 34
so in order to achieve that that is the
whole algorithm which you have to write
now I have taken two pointers the orange
colors and
the one on the left hand side and one on
the right hand side this is I and this
is J
now what is the job of eye pointer the
job of eye pointer is to find the
elements which are less than 34 and the
J pointer is to find the elements which
are greater than 34 okay so I will keep
on shifting towards the right until
unless it finds an element greater than
34 and in case of J element it will
shift towards the left until unless it
finds an element
less than 34 okay so we will see that
now I will start its Journey from the
zeroth element always and J will start
its Journey from the one element less
than the pivot always okay
now in this example I is already
pointing to a
element which is greater than 34
but J is pointing to an element which is
greater than 34 but it should move
towards the element which is less than
34 so now I will remain static and J
will move one element further which is
17 and that will check whether J is
less than 34 or not
if not then it will stop over here
correct and I is less than a pivot or
not if not then it will also stop over
here okay so J will check if it is
greater than 34 or not and I will check
if it is greater than 34 or not
now in this scenario 40 and 17 now are
meeting the condition that whether 40 is
greater than 34 and 17 is less than 34
we will make a swap of these elements so
17 will interchange with 40 and 40 will
interchangeable 17 and then now I and J
will continue their journey ahead
what will happen now I moves to 21 J is
at 40.
okay now 21 is less than 34 I will
continue further it will come to 8.
okay
8 is also less than 34 I has now moved
to 40 right now 40 is not less than 34 I
will stop over here
now J what happened with j j is greater
than 34 it will move further now J has
reached 8 and I has reached 40. now at
this point when J has crossed I then now
it is the point when you need to swap
the pivots you need to change the pivot
so at this point when J has crossed When
J is greater than I you need to swap the
pivots so in this case what will happen
is 40 will get swapped with 34 and 34
will come in place of 40 and 40 will go
to the end now with this whole exercise
what has happened now 34 has found its
correct position in this entire array
and if you monitor the all the elements
on the left hand side of 34 are smaller
234 and all the elements on the right
hand side are greater than 34.
and this is what we wanted to achieve
now the same logic will get applied to
left array and right array
in left array now 8 will be assumed as
the pivot and in the right array 40 will
be taken as the pivot
and applying the same logic now 8 is
taken as the pivot 17 and 21 I and J are
pointing now as there are only two
elements 21 is greater than 8 17 is also
greater than 8 so then automatically 21
will move ahead J will move ahead and I
will move ahead and then 21 and 17 will
swap each other so the final will become
8 17 21 here we only have one element of
okay 51 and 40 will swap amongst
themselves as pivot and they will align
themselves
so I know it's a little confusing and uh
complicated algorithm but I'll try to
explain this with my
example
now what I have to do is I have to
create my data
and I am
creating a quick sort
algorithm
now in order to start the quick sort I
need to send the zeroth index and the
length of the array minus 1
and of course if the
length of left is a bit less than right
means there is some data then only I'll
continue
now secondly what I have to do is I have
to find the index of the pivot element
and pass it recursively to the quick
sort
so now we will create another function
which is called Partition which
will encapsulate the entire logic
so I'll create my left pointer I which I
was explaining the right pointer J which
is one less than the right most element
which is my Pivot
and I'll capture my
pivot which is the rightmost element in
our example 34
and then
I'll run a while loop
for
the duration when I while I is less than
J right when I J becomes greater than
less than I means when they cross the
path then we will swap the pivot
now first
I will iterate move my
left iterator I
to the right hand side right when it is
less than the right and I'll check my
element on the ith index is less than
the pivot because this is my left sub
array
and
then I'll increment
similarly
I will move my J iterator
from right to left compare that the
element at the J pointer is greater than
the pivot so because I have to create my
right sub array
okay
now I am checking
if my I index is less than J
correct
then I'll
swap the elements
and let me print the array over here
now outside the while loop
I'll check my
arith array I index is greater than the
pivot
yes
then I'll I am now changing my Pivot
basically pivot value I am swapping the
pivot value and I'll print it here for
you
and I'll return
the I this is the index of the pivot
let me
indented correctly
and print it
okay let's see what has happened
now this is my original array where the
pivot
starting from 34
now
as I told my I did not move the head
because I is checking if my element of I
is less than pivot 40 is greater 40 so I
has not moved but J moved J moved from
starting from 51 till 71 till 17 and it
stopped over here
and at this point 17 and 40 got swapped
17 com came over here and 40 came over
here
now Hereafter I started moving forward I
21 is less than 34 okay 8 is less than
34 okay 40 is less than 34 no so I
stopped over here
my J was at 40 it moved further
8 8 is greater than 34 no so I and J
have crossed each other now this is the
point where we have to make a swap
between 40 and 34.
okay so 40 will move to the end and 34
will come in middle so now 34 has
reached its desired and actual position
and all elements left of 34 are smaller
than it and right of 34 are greater than
it
now
I am working on my left sub array where
8 is my Pivot
now I will start
from here
j i
so 17 it is greater than 8 it will not
move ahead 21 it is greater than a 8 it
moved ahead J and it reached 17. now 17
and 21 now J has crossed I they will
swap each other okay
and now my array position is 8 21 17 34
51 40. now my Pivot changes to 17 17
will be compared to 21 and this is the
swap happening over here
now coming to the right sub array my
Pivot is 40 only single element is there
40 and 51 the swap will happen over here
so as you understand
quick sort
you will better understand when you run
it with multiple examples try giving a
show to Simply lens postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with the IBM the course
link is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete audio of the program being
offered we are going to discuss an
essential tool for any developer or data
science that is virtual environment and
before proceeding I have an insight for
you guys if you are aiming to get
certified as an AI and ml engineer and
want to build a career in AI in that
case you can check the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning that is in collaboration with
IBM and Purdue University by simply
learn which will open the doors for the
best career opportunities and to find
the details of this professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning you can check the link in the
description box below and the print
coming and now let us have a simple
question to brush upon our knowledge
and your question is what command turns
on a virtual environment and your
options are the first option is Source
script slash activate and the second
option is python minus M way environment
virtual environment and the name of the
folder
and the third option is Source virtual
slash scripts slash activate OD all of
the work please answer in the comment
section below and we will update the
correct answer in the pin command you
can pause the video give it a thought
and answer in the comment section
now moving on to our topic that is
virtual environment most python projects
have dependencies that we installed and
use for example we use flask for web
applications and we use these libraries
returned and tested by many developers
so you don't have to write them again
these libraries change over time they
get new functionalities and Bug fixes
with some newer versions for example
let's say you are a python developer
working on two different projects and
each project has different package
requirements project a requires flask
2.0 version while Project B requires
flask version 2.2 you cannot have both
versions stored globally on your system
because they will conflict with each
other and you might break one or both of
these projects this is where virtual
environment comes in handy and now we'll
see what is a virtual environment
virtual environments are isolated
environments that allow developers to
work on multiple projects with different
dependencies without conflicts this is
crucial when working on multiple
projects simultaneously especially those
with different dependencies because the
virtual environment ensures that each
project has its own set of dependencies
that will not conflict with those of
other projects in Python virtual
environments are created using the
built-in virtual environment module
which creates a directory with a
specific structure that contains a copy
of the Python interpreter as well as
other necessary files every virtual
environment has a python version and a
folder of third-party libraries that you
will install for a particular project
python libraries are frequently updated
with new versions that include bug fixes
new features and performance
improvements upgrading a library to a
newer version can have various effects
on a virtual environment in general it
is a good practice to keep libraries
updated to the latest version but it is
also important to consider the impact on
the virtual environment and the
application before upgrading it is
recommended to test the upgraded library
in a separate environment before making
changes to the production environment
this can help to identify any potential
issues and ensure a smooth upgrade
process if we update the library maybe a
code should not work as the
functionalities would have been changed
with the update now we'll see why do you
need a virtual environment if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
when you installed packages globally you
run the risk of breaking other projects
or application that rely on the same
packages virtual environment provides a
solution to this problem by creating an
isolated environment for a project that
doesn't interfere with your system
environment now we'll see a Hands-On
demonstration to create a virtual
environment on our system so for that we
will go to our projects folder and
inside here we will create a folder and
name it as virtual environment
so inside this folder first we'll open
the command prompt
so creating a virtual environment is a
straightforward process will demonstrate
how to create a virtual environment
using Python's built-in module that is
virtual environment
and we have opened the command prompt
and navigate it into a folder that we
have created that is virtual environment
I will write a command that would be
python minus m
the name of the
module virtual environment and now we'll
write the name of a folder we want to
create
so we'll press enter and
now
we'll see that we have a directory here
that is with the name my environment
once the command gets executed
successfully we'll have a new directory
that is
my environment but we have made
now we have to activate our virtual
environment first we'll do that
but before that
what we can see is in the script section
we have
pip and the python files here that is
the python.exe file that is the
application file web file so we have
Python's version installed here
so if we ask
the command prompt what version is
installed in our virtual environment
we'll ask him
it says 3.10.2 but it's the global
python that is
command prompt is showing so first we
have to activate the virtual environment
and after that it will show us what
python version is installed into a
environment so to activate our virtual
environment we will write a command that
is the path we will write
and this is for the windows
for that we'll write
the name of the folder my environment
slash you have seen the scripts folder
slash and then we have
activate
and now we'll press enter
you can see my environment folder in
Brackets this shows that a virtual
environment is active now now if we ask
him what is the python version that is
installed inside our virtual environment
it says that is 3.10.2
so we have the global installed python
version that is 3.10.2 and in a virtual
environment it's also
3.10.2 and we have a command to
deactivate
our virtual environment that is
deactivate so it has been deactivated
that is you can see that my environment
from the circular brackets it has been
managed now we'll check what packages
are installed into our system
so now we are in the global system
for that we'll write pip
phrase and press enter
so you can see these old packages are
installed into a global environment
system
these are many packages
so you can see these are the packages
that are installed
we'll get back to a virtual environment
and activate it
so to activate it we will get into the
folder slash Scripts
slash activate
and press enter you can see that our
virtual environment is active now
and now in here write the command with
freeze and see what packages are
installed it says no packages are
installed into a
virtual environment
so here we will install
Django
web install Django and press enter
so you could see that it has started
installing it
when it is installing 4.1.7 version
now you have seen that Django is
installed into a system now you can work
on any Project without worrying about
any package that conflict with other
projects like if you name this as
project a then the Django is installed
into this project and if you want to
work on Project B then you need to
create another virtual environment for
it using the same virtual environment
command just above
and you can work on Project B without
worrying about any package conflicts or
breaking projecting to deactivate we
have seen that we can just write
deactivate and the virtual environment
would be deactivated so now if you want
to give a particular project to another
person for that you have to ask him to
install all the particular version of
the packages so to find all the packages
installed into an environment I've seen
the command pip freeze it has shown us
all the packages that were installed
into a the system environment or the
global environment now we'll write a
command to see what packages
are installed in our virtual environment
so for that you could use the previous
coin prompt or we could just have a new
command prompt here
and here we have two activate a virtual
environment again as we are not able to
see the name of the virtual environment
in circular brackets so for that we'll
write
the name of the
directory then scripts and then activate
now you can see
our virtual environment is active
now I'll write the command pip fees
and it has shared us all the
packages that are installed into our
system and these are the packages that
are installed with the Django
package
so now if you want to share a particular
project with another person then you
have to create a file that would be
requirements.txt file and you have to
write all the
projects with the version names
installed for your project so for that
we will write the Command Web freeze and
the greater than sign and then we'll
write
requirements Dot
txt and press enter
so what this will do is it will create a
file requirements.txt and it will get
filled with all the packages with the
particular and respective versions so
you can share this file
to a particular person and the
particular person can install all the
packages just by a single command so
what command he could write as pip
install minus r
then
the requirements
Dot txt
so it's Dot txt
and press enter
so you could see that the requirement is
already satisfied as in this virtual
environment we have the Django installed
and with the Django these are the other
packages that will be installed
automatically
so the particular person has to run the
Quant pip install minus r
requirements.txt and all the packages
with the particular versions that are
mentioned in the requirements.txt file
will be installed for him Master Python
and other core data science topics to
help you Kickstart your data Journey
with a professional certificate program
delivered in partnership with Purdue
University and IBM this data science
certification features master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts exclusive
hackathons and AMS sessions by IBM
experts this course covers tools and
techniques like numpy pandas Python and
sci-fi along with industry projects like
uber Transport service provider Amazon
e-commerce and Retail in Walmart
choosing this course can get you hired
in renowned companies like Netflix
Amazon Facebook Adobe and average salary
hike of 70 percent so what are you
waiting for join the data science
professional certificate program and
Excel your career in data science the
link is in the description box below if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
now before talking about top python
libraries let's take a look at what a
library is python has produced a number
of Open Source libraries each with its
own root Source a library is a
previously combined set of code scripts
that may be utilized iteratively to save
time now in contrast to languages such
as C plus plus or C python libraries are
not context specific now a library in
this context refers to a collection of
essential components a library is a
collection of modules that can be
installed with the help of a package
manager such as pip now that we know
what libraries are let's take a closer
look at some of the most popular
libraries in Python first on the list we
have numpy numpy is an open source
python Library used for scientific
Computing and data analysis it provides
powerful numerical and mathematical
functions that enable efficient
computation of large multi-dimensional
arrays and matrices
numpy is an essential library for data
manipulation and Analysis in fields such
as machine learning image processing and
scientific Computing now some of the key
features of numpy include
multi-dimensional arrays numpy provides
a powerful n-dimensional array object
that can be used to store and manipulate
large data sets mathematical functions
numpy provides a wide range of
mathematical functions that can be
applied to arrays and matrices as well
including linear algebra Fourier
transforms and random number generation
numpy is widely used library in the data
science and machine learning communities
and is often used in conjunction with
other libraries like pandas scikit-learn
and tensorflow second on the list we
have pandas pandas is an open source
data manipulation and Analysis library
for the Python programming language it
provides easy to use data structures and
data analysis tools for handling and
manipulating structured data panels
provides two main data structures one is
series and other one is data frame now a
series is a one dimensional label array
that can hold any data type while a data
frame is a two-dimensional label data
structure with columns and potential of
different data types some of the key
features of Partners include data
cleaning Partners provide tools for
cleaning filtering and transforming data
such as filling missing values removing
doing duplicates and replacing values
data manipulation pandas provide
powerful tools for manipulating data
such as grouping merging and reshaping
data integration with other libraries
pandas integrate with other popular
libraries such as numpy scipy and
scikit-learn to provide a complete data
analysis and machine learning
environment pandas is widely used in
data science and Analysis and are
particularly useful for working with
tabular data such as data in CSV and
Excel files next on the list we have
matplotlib matplotlib is a python
Library used for data visualization it
provides a wide range of tools for
creating graphs plots charts and other
visual representation of data it is a
highly customizable library that allows
you to control every aspect of
visualization you create you can
customize the style color size
appearance of elements such as lines
markers access titles and legends it
also offers several types of plots in
loading line plots Scatter Plots bar
plots histogram plots pie chart and many
more
matplotlib is built on top of numpy
which makes it easy to work with arrays
and other numerical data matplotlib also
integrates well with other python
libraries such as pandas for data
manipulation sci-fi for scientific
Computing and c-bond for statistical
data visualization
fourth on the list we have psychic learn
psychic learn also known as sklearn is a
popular open source machine learning
library for python it provides a wide
range of algorithms and tools for
building and evaluating machine learning
models scikit-learn is built on top of
numpy scipy and matplotlib which makes
it easy to integrate with other
scientific Computing libraries in Python
it provides a comprehensive set of tools
for various machine learning tasks such
as classification regression clustering
dimensionality reduction model selection
and pre-processing it also includes
popular algorithms such as decision
trees random Forest support Vector
machines logistic regression K nearest
neighbors and many more scikit-learn
provides a consistent API for all
algorithms making it easy to switch
between different models and algorithms
scikit-learn also provides a wide range
of pre-processing tools for cleaning and
transforming data such as scaling
normalization and feature extra action
fifth on the list we have Scrappy the
next one python libraries for data
science is Scrappy Scrappy is one of the
most popular fast open source web
crawling framework written in Python it
is commonly used to extract data from
web pages with the help of selectors
based on XPath and talking about its
application Scrappy helps in building
crawling programs that can retrieve
structured data from the web Scrappy is
also used to gather data from apis and
follow a don't repeat yourself principle
in the design of its interface
influencing users to write universal
codes that can be reused for building
and scaling large crawlers sixth on the
list we have Keras similar to tensorflow
Keras is another popular library that is
used extensively for deep learning and
neural network modules Kera supports
both tensorflow and piano backends so it
is a good option if you don't want to
dive into the details of tensorflow
talking about such features Keras
provides vast pre-labeled data sets
which can be used to directly import and
load it contains various implemented
layers and parameters that can be used
for construction configuration training
and evaluation of neural networks next
in the list of top python libraries for
data Sciences Pi torch which is a python
based scientific Computing package that
uses the power of Graphics processing
units pytorch is one of the most
commonly used preferred deep learning
research platforms built to provide
maximum flexibility and speed
talking about its application pytorch is
famous for providing two of the most
high level features first one is tensor
computations with strong GPU
acceleration support and building deep
neural networks on a tape based
autograph system eighth on the list we
have beautiful soup beautiful soup is
the next python library for data science
this is another popular python Library
most commonly known for web crawling and
data scraping users can collect data
that's available on some website without
a proper CSV or API and beautiful soup
can also help them scrape it and arrange
it into required format now beautiful
soup is widely used in web scraping
applications and is considered as one of
the most popular and Powerful web
scraping tool available in Python
ecosystem next on the list we have Pi
game pie game is a set of python modules
designed for writing video games it
provides functionality for working with
Graphics sound and user input as well as
tools for handling events and timing now
python game is built on top of the sdl
library which provides a low level
interface for accessing hardware and
input devices some of the features
provided by pi game include support for
2D Graphics rendering including image
loading and manipulation Sprite handling
and drawing Primitives support for
playing sounds and music including
playback control and volume adjustment
support for handling user input
including keyboard mouse and joystick
events Pi game is often used for
prototyping and developing small to
medium sized games as well as for
educational purposes its ease of use and
flexibility makes it a popular choice
for game development beginners and
hobbyists and finally on the list we
have piano Tiano is a python library for
numerical computation designed for deep
learning and machine learning
applications it allows users to Define
optimize and God's mathematical
Expressions which includes
multi-dimensional arrays the fundamental
building blocks of many machine learning
algorithms now talking about features
Tiano is designed to efficiently perform
numerical computations on both CPU and
GPU which can significantly speed up the
training and testing of machine learning
models Tino provides automatic
differentiation functionality making it
easy to compute gradients and optimize
parameters while training machine
learning models and some of its
applications are scientific Computing
simulation optimization and deep
learning in addition to these top 10
python libraries for 2023 there are many
other helpful python libraries ones that
deserve to be looked at if you are
interested in learning and mastering
data science with python head on to
Simply learns professional certificate
program in data science do explore the
frequently Asked data science interview
questions and unlock your career as a
data scientist
foreign
ER with the simply learned team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead what's in it for you and we're
going to go over what is numpy
installing an importing numpy numpy
array numpy array versus python list
basics of numpy finding size and shape
of any array range and arrange functions
numpy string functions and then in part
two I'll move on to cover axes array
manipulation and much more
try giving a shout to Simply Lynn's
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning in collaboration with IBM the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete audio of the program
being offered so let's start with what
is number numpy is the core library for
scientific and numerical Computing in
Python it provides high performance
multi-dimensional array object and tools
for working with arrays and I'll go a
step further and say there are so many
other modules in Python built on numpy
so the fundamentals of numpy are so
important to latch onto for the python
so that you can understand the other
modules and what they're doing numpy's
main object is a multi-dimensional array
it's a table of elements usually numbers
all of the same type indexed by a tuple
of position integers in numpy dimensions
are called axes take a one-dimensional
array or we have remember dimensions are
also called axes you can say this is the
first axis 0 1 2 3 4 5. and you can see
down here it has a shape of six why
because there's six different elements
in it in the one dimension array and
they usually denote that as six comma
with an empty note on there and then we
have a two dimensional array where you
can see zero one two three four five six
seven and in here we have two axes or
two dimensions and the shape is two four
so if you were looking at this as a
matrix or another mathematical functions
you can see there's all kinds of
importance on shape we're not going to
cover shape today but we will cover that
in part two did you know that numpy's
array class is called ND array for numpy
data array now we're going to take a
detour here because we're working in
Python and two of my favorite Tools in
Python is the Jupiter notebook and then
I like to use that sitting on top of
anaconda and if you flip over to
jupiter.org that's j u p e y t e r dot
org you can go in here you can install
it off of here if you don't want to use
the Anaconda notebook but this is the
Jupiter setup the documentation on the
Jupiter Jupiter opens up in your web
browser that's what makes it so nice is
this portable the files are saved on
your computer they do run an IPython or
iron Python and you can create all kinds
of different environments in there which
I'll show you in just a minute I myself
like to use Anaconda that's
www.anaconda.com if you install Anaconda
it will install the jupyter notebook
with the Anaconda separate and you can
install Jupiter notebook and it'll run
completely separate from anaconda's
Jupiter notebook and you can see here
I've now opened up my anaconda Navigator
what I like about the Navigator and this
is a fresh install on a new computer
which is always nice I can launch my
Jupiter notebook from in here I can
bring other tools so the Anaconda does a
lot more and under environments I only
have the one environment and I can open
up the terminal specific to this
environment this one happens to have
python 37 in it the most current version
as of this tutorial and then you open a
terminal if you're going to do your pip
installs and stuff like that for
different modules you can also create
different environments in here so maybe
you need a python36 python35 you can see
we're having a nice framework like
Anaconda really helps so you don't have
to chat track that on your own in the
Jupiter notebook in your different
Jupiter notebook setups we'll go ahead
and launch this Jupiter notebook and
then I've set my browser window for a
deep fault of chrome so it's going to
open up in Chrome and you can see here
this opens up a folder on my computer we
have a couple different options on here
remember I set the environment up as
python 3.7 you would install any
additional modules that aren't already
installed in your python on this and it
keeps them separate so you do have to
for each environment install the
separate modules so they match the
environment on there and in here we have
a couple things we can look up what's
running do you have your different
clusters again this is I just installed
this on a new machine so I just have the
one a couple things in here that were
run on here recently and what we go on
here is we then have on the upper right
new and from the pull down menu you'll
see python3 and this will open up a new
window
and now we're in Jupiter python so this
is a python window and we'll just do a
print
and this of course is also hello world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
Graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do is you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these we have a equals hello
world b equals goodbye world and you put
a b a then return B it'll only run the
last one but you can see here if you put
the variable down here it will show you
what's in that variable
and that has to do with the Jupiter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just jupyter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit so back to our numpy numpy
array versus python list python list
being the basic list in your python why
should we use numpy array when we have
python list well first it's fast the
numpy array has been optimized over
years and years by multiple programmers
and it's usually very quick compared to
the basic python list setup it's
convenient so it has a lot of
functionality in there that's not in the
basic python list and it also uses less
memory so it's optimized both for Speed
and memory use and let's go ahead and
jump into our Jupiter notebook since
we're coding best way to learn coding is
to code just like the best way to learn
how to write is write and the best way
to learn how to cook is cook so let's do
some coding here today and just like any
modules we have to import numpy we
almost always import it as NP that is
such a standard so you'll see that very
commonly we can just run that and now we
have access to our numpy module inside
our Python and then the most common
thing of course is to go and create a
number array
and in here we can send it a regular
list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array let's go one two three to
make it simple and then I'm just going
to type in a and we'll run this
and so you can see down here the output
is an array of one two three and we
could also do
print just a reminder that this is an
inline command so that wouldn't work if
you're using a different editor you can
see that it's an array one two three but
we'll go and leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook and just like all your
other standard arrays I can go a of zero
which is going to be a value of one of
course we do a of one you go all the way
through this
if one has a value of 2 in it so whether
using that numpy array or the basic
python list that's going to be the same
that should all look pretty familiar and
be pretty straightforward remember the
first value is always zero
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like and what we want to
look at is the fact that it's fast
convenient and uses less memory so let's
take a glance at that in code and see
what that actually looks like when we're
writing it in Python and what the
differences are
and to do this I'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported and so we'll do b equals a
range of one yeah 1000 is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
100 0 to 999 remember it starts at zero
and it stops right at the 1000 without
actually going to the 1000. and let's go
ahead and print
and we want system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to a thousand we'll
just throw one in there five it doesn't
matter because it's gonna whatever
integer we put in there is going to
generate the same value it's looking the
size of how how much memory it stores an
integer in
and then we want to have the link of the
B that's how many integers are in there
if we go ahead and execute this and run
this in a line we'll see Oops I did that
wrong comma if we multiply them together
we'll see it generates twenty eight
thousand so that's the size we're
looking at is twenty eight thousand I
believe that's bytes that sounds about
right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy and we'll go with C equals NP and
this is a range
so that's the numpy command to do the
same thing that we were just doing in a
list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
and then once we've created the C value
of C for NP dot a range let's go ahead
and print and we can do that by doing C
dot size
times C dot item size
well that's very similar we did before
we did get the size of so the C size is
the size of the array and each item size
just reversed so it's the size of an
integer five item size is going to be
the integers and C size now let's just
take a look and see what that generates
and wow okay we got 4 000 versus 28 000.
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array and then let's go and take a
look at speed let's do oh let's do size
we trade this with lower values and it
would happen so fast that the npra kept
coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off so size
and let's create an L1
Bulls range of size
and we'll do an L2
I'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on here there we go
and then we can do on A1
equals NP Dot
a range size
and then let's do an A 2 equals NP dot a
range we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them but let's go ahead
actually just load these up now we'll go
ahead and run this so those are all set
in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is and it will
do result equals and let's do oh let's
say we got an array and we're going to
say
let's do some addition here X Plus y
for X comma y
in and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're going to multiply
each of the individual things on here L1
L2
there we go so that should add up each
value so L1 plus L2 each value in each
array
and then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say python list took
and then we'll do
time
dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops I messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time minus the start
and we'll convert that to seconds so
we'll go to this in milliseconds or
times 1000.
and let's hit the run on there it's kind
of fun because you also get a view while
we're doing this of some ways to
manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bad typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually I have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
can go ahead and print the result in
here too
let's do that
and we'll run that just so you can see
what the what kind of data we're looking
at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straightforward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see python list took
46 a little different time on there
depending on what um core because I have
this is on an eight core computer so it
just depends on what course running on
what else is pulling on the computer at
the time and let's go back up here and
do our start time paste that into here
and this time we're going to do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is It's So
straightforward this is for a lot of
reason people started using numpy is
because it can add the two arrays
together by simply going A1 Plus A2
makes a lot of sense both looking at it
and a system very
convenient remember this slide we're
looking at fast convenient and less
memory so look how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see and
I don't know if we don't need to print
the result again so let's just go ahead
and print the time on here and we'll
borrow this from the top part
because I really am a lazy type
this isn't the python list this is the
numpy list or numpy array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out and we get 2.99
so let's take a look at these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to three that's a huge
difference that's that's like more than
10 times faster that's like 15 times
roughly at a quick glance I'd have to go
do the math to look at it and it's going
to vary a little bit depending on what's
running in the background the computer
obviously so we've looked at this and if
we go back here we found out it's much
faster yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
when we were looking at speed and size
let's dive into a little bit more into
the basic operations
and these are always nice to see I mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up Google is
your friend we did this we're the most
basic numpy dot array or NP dot array
and we'll go ahead and create an array
let's do pairs one comma two
and then let's do a three comma four and
if we do that let's do five comma six
let's go and if we go ahead and take
this and run this I can go ahead and do
our a down here so it's in line it'll
print that out you can see it makes a
nice array for us so we have a and if
you look at that we have three different
objects each with two values in them and
hopefully you're starting to think well
how many dimensions or indexes is that
and you'll see three by two so let's go
ahead and take a look and let's go how
about a dot in Dimensions speaking of
which we'll run that and we have two
dimensions for each object
and then we can do the item size so a
DOT we saw this earlier we looked up how
many items it was up here where we
wanted to multiply item size times the
actual size of the object so the memory
is being used versus the item size
and we should see four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from one
format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally I don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions I'm always
looking up this is nice you can automate
it so you might be converting something
you might need to know how many
dimensions are going into the next
machine learning package so that you can
automatically just have it send that
information over
so we looked at a shape let's go and
create a slightly different array NP dot
array let's go ahead and just do as our
original
set up here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do D type
equals in this case let's do NP
float 64. and so what we've done is
converting all of these into a float
when we type in a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values 1.0 there's no actual zero in
there just shows the one dot or the one
period two three period four period five
period six period
and this again data science I don't know
how many times I've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
it's going to work correctly in the
model I'm using so very common features
to be aware of and to be able to get
around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float64
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64. and it should be the same
three comma two so it all matches so
we've gone through and remember if you
really if this is all brand new to you
according to the Cambridge study at the
Cambridge University if you're learning
a brand new word in a foreign language
the average person has to repeat it 163
times before it's memorized
so a lot of this you build off of it so
hopefully you don't have to repeat it
163 times but we did manage to repeat it
at least twice here if not a little bit
more and let's go ahead and take this
we're going to go look at one more setup
on here and let me just take this last
statement here on the converting our
properties of our data and instead of
float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go and print
that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus 0 dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types better to go
to the original web page but pull up a
bunch of these you can see there's a
whole list of different numpy data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128 complex number
represented by 264-bit floats real and
imaginary components
one option on there float 16 float 32
float shorthand for float 64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic Edition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs but some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also the
shape probably one of the more used I
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
Dot
zeros
and we're going to do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if I do NP dot
zeros I create an array of zeros
this is really important I was building
my own neural network and I needed to
create an array where I initialized the
weights and I want them all to be the
same weight in this case I want them to
start off as zero for the particular
project I was working on and there's
other options that you can do on p1s
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that and you can see I've
created a an array of numpy ones in this
case it comes out as a float array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
Python and do L Range Five
and we'll print the L so there's our
list and if I run that
it doesn't create the range and tell
after the fact until you actually
execute it that's an upgrade in python
python 27 actually created the array
zero one two three four this one
actually creates the script and then
once it's used it then actually
generates the array and if we do that in
numpy a Range remember that from before
and if we do a numpy a range 5
and let's do a
l or we can just leave it as numpy
that's probably there we go just run
that
you can see there we actually get an
array 0 1 2 3 4 for the value of the
numpy range a range five generates the
actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic setup
and we're going to concatenation
concatenation out example
there we go we're gonna do strings let's
take a look at strings and what's going
on with there and let's do
oh let's see print
Let's do an NP character something new
here
and we're going to add and then here's
our brackets for what we're going to add
all and let's say
um let's do
hello
comma High
and in the brackets on there let's
create another one
and this one's going to be
ABC and we'll do
x y z so we're just creating some
randomly making sum up on here and then
we'll go ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here and of
course make sure all your brackets are
open and closed correctly and then you
can see in here when we concatenate the
example in numpy it takes the two
different arrays that we set up in there
and it combines the hello with the ABC
and the high with x y z
and if we can also do something like
print oh let's do NP character dot
multiply
so there's a lot of different functions
in here again you can look these up it's
probably good to look them all up and
see what they are but it's good to also
just see them in action let's do hello
space comma three
and we'll run this one
and run that without the error and
you'll see it does hello hello hello so
we multiplied it by three and we can
also let's just take this whole thing
here instead of retyping it
and we can do character Center so
instead of multiply this to Center
and over here keep our hello going
keep the space out of there and let's do
Center at 20.
and fill character
equals we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side and we keep going
um with that we can also in addition to
doing the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
so we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine I always like
to say Hello Universe and you can see
here we do Capital H with the world but
so we want to capitalize so capitalize
is the first one in the array so we get
Hello World on there and we can also
take this and instead of capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how are you doing instead are we able to
do you and let's run that
and you can see here because we created
it as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have Hello World all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that you get
a an array with Hello World lowercase
and hello lowercase and if we're going
to do it that way we can also do it the
opposite way there's also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have character Dot Upper
opposite there
python.data and we'll do python is easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the Python and the
scripting is very simple it's when you
put the bigger picture together and
starts building these puzzles and
somebody asks you hey I need the first
letter capitalized unless it's the title
and then we have you start realizing
that this can get really complicated so
numpy just makes it simple and we like
that and so in this case we did python
data it's all uppercase python is easy
like shouting in your messenger python
is easy and then if you're ever
processing text and tokenizing it a lot
of times the first thing you do is we
just split the text and we're just going
to run this in P dot character.split are
you coming to the party if we do that it
returns an array of each of the
individual words are you coming to the
party splitting it by the spaces
and then if you're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by lines
and just like we have the basic split
command we also have split lines hello
and you'll see here the scoop in for our
new line
and when we run that if you're following
the split part with the words you should
see hello how are you doing the two
different lines are now split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have Nina admin Anita
and we're going to strip a off of there
let's see what that looks like and then
you end up with nin dominate it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a more common would be a
space in there but it might also be
punctuation or anything like that that
you need to remove from your letters and
words and if we're going to strip and
clean data we also need to be able to
reformat it or join it together so you
see here we have a character joined
we'll go ahead and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
ESO letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things to have to always switch
around and manipulate depending on what
they're going into what you're working
with
and finally let's look at one last
character string we're going to do
replace if you're doing misinformation
this is good pulling news articles
replacing is and what in this case we're
just doing his a good dancer and we're
going to replace is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and it's gotten old
so there we go we've covered a lot of
the basics in numpy as far as creating
an array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in how do we know the
shape of it the size of it what happens
we convert it from a regular integer
into a float value as far as how much
space it takes we saw that that doubled
it item size you have your in dimensions
and probably the most used is shape I
will cover more on shape in part two so
make sure you join us on part two
because there's a lot of important
things on shaping in there and setting
them up we also saw that you can create
a zeros based array you can create one
with ones if we do a range you can see
how it is a lot easier to use to create
its own range or a range as it is in
numpy you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into doing strings and
working with strings and how to
concatenate so if you have two different
arrays of strings you can bring them
together we also saw how you can fill so
you can add a nice headline dash dash
dash we saw about capitalize the first
letter we saw about turning it into a
title so all the first letters are
capitalized doing lowercase on all the
letters upper for all the letters just
lower and upper nice abbreviation we
also covered how to split the character
set how to strip it so if you want to
strip all the A's out from leading A's
and ending A's or spaces you can do that
very easily also how to join the data
sets so here's a character join option
for your strings and finally we did the
character replace now let's go ahead and
dive in there since we're going right
into part two which is getting some
coding going under our belt and here in
our Jupiter notebook we can go under new
and create a new folder python3 I think
I forgot to do this last time but we
could just do the control plus plus
which in any browser enlarges a page
makes it a lot easier to see always a
nice feature another beautiful benefit
of using jupyter notebooks and let me go
ahead and show you a neat thing can do
in Jupiter this is nice if you're
working with people and you're doing
this as a demo on a large screen I'm
going to do the hashtag or pound symbol
array manipulation kind of a title that
we're working on and then I'm going to
call this cell cell type markdown as
opposed to code and you'll see it
highlights it here and then if I run it
it just turns it into array manipulation
and then we're specifically going to be
working on array manipulation changing
shape to start with and we'll go ahead
and Mark this cell also a markdown so
has a nice little look there and then it
comes up and you can see it just like I
said it just highlights it it makes it
very bold print just making it easier to
read not a python thing but a Jupiter
thing that's good to know about
especially if you're working with the
shareholders since they're investing
money in you of course the first thing
you want to do is import we're going to
import numpy
as in p and that should be standard by
now by now you you start a Python
program you're doing some data science
numpy is just something you bring in
there and let's go ahead and create our
array and we're going to do that as the
NP dot a range remember that's uh zero
well we're going to do 0 to 9.
and we'll print
a little title on the original array
we'll just print that array a remember
from the first lesson so we have our
array which is 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and
let's add a print space in between
let's create a second array B but we
want this to reshape array a and what
does that mean
and the command is simply reshape and
then we have nine items in here and this
is so important right now so be very
aware if I did some weird numbers in
here it's not going to work
and we want multiples of nine we know
that three times three is nine so we're
going to reshape our 8 array by three by
three and then we're going to print
let's give it a title let's add too many
brackets in there modified array and
then let's go ahead and print
RB and let's see what that looks like
and as we come down here you can see
we've taken this and it's gone from 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 to an array of arrays and
we have 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
and so we split this into three by three
and you can guess that if I tried to
reshape this let's just do a five by
three which is 15. that's going to give
me an error so it's not going to work
you're not going to reshape something
unless the shape all the the data in
there matches correctly
so we can take this nine this flat 9 and
we call it a flex it's just a single
array and we can reshape it into a three
by three array and first you may think
matrixes which this is used for that
definitely I use it a lot in graphing
because it'll come in that I have an
array that's X Y comma X Y 1 y 1 comma
X2 Y2 and so the shape of it might be
two by the length of the number of
points and I need to separate that into
X flat array and a y flat array and you
can see this can be very easy to reshape
the array doing that and we can of
course go back we can do B
print and we'll do B dot platin remember
I said it's called a flatten array
and if we run that you'll see this goes
back to the original one it takes this
zero one two three four five six seven
eight and flattens it back to a single
array
and then one other feature to be aware
of is if we flatten it one of the
commands we can put in there is order
let me just go ahead and do that order
equals
F strangely enough F stands for Fortran
they hold Fortran days I remember
actually studying Fortran programming
language in this case you'll see that it
uses the first like zero three six is
the order so instead of flattening it
like we had before zero one two three
four five six seven eight it now does
zero three six one four seven two five
eight and if you go to the numpy array
page you can see here that they have the
flatten and you just open up the numpy
and D array flatten setup to look it up
and they have three different options
they have c f and a and it's whether to
flatten in C which was based on how the
C code works for flattening originally
worked which is row major
Fortran which is column major or
preserve the column Fortran ordering
from a so whatever it was in the default
is the C version so the default that you
saw you could put orders equals c and
you'd have the same effect as we saw
there before you could even do order
equals a that would also have the same
effect because that's the default so
really the only other thing you need to
change on here is to change it to C if
you need it and you can see right here
or F I mean not C the only thing you
really want to change it to is to your f
for the Fortran order which then does it
by column versus by row and let's look
at here we go reshape so let's create a
range of 12
and let's reshape it
I will do 4 comma 3 for this one and
remember this is numpy I forgot the NP
there
NP dot arrange
and we can type in just a for print or
you can do full print a and of course
jupyter notebook you even have a little
extra print at the beginning we run this
we'll see we create a nice array of 0 1
2 it's reshaped it so we have four rows
and three columns or you could call that
three columns and four rows zero one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven
but this one is so important we'll do NP
transpose
a let's go ahead and run that
and it helps if I get all the s's in
there and don't leave an S out and
you'll see here we've taken our array if
you remember correctly we had 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 and we've swapped it so
we've gone from a three by four or a
four by three to a three by four
and this really helps if you're looking
at like a huge number of rows and the
data all comes in like let's say this is
your features in row one your features
in row two and this is x y z well when
you go to plot it you send it all of X
in one array all of one another one
array and all Z in another array
so it's really important that we can
transpose this rather quickly
this is kind of a fun thing I can
highlight it and do brackets around it
if you remember correctly
because we're in Jupiter it doesn't
matter where we do the print or not
it'll automatically print it for us and
you see if I hit the Run button it comes
up at the same exact thing and let's
play with the reshape and you don't want
to zoom this up a little bit here
make that even bigger so you can really
see what's going on and let's play with
the reshape just a little bit more we'll
do b equals
NP dot a range let's do eight
reshape we'll do two comma four
let's go ahead and print B
and then run that and you'll see we have
now the two rows this is a bit more like
so we have four maybe two rows of four
things so this might be all of our X
components and our y components so we
can switch it back and forth real easy
important to note here whether we do two
comma four or in the case of four comma
three this has 12 elements and so
however you split it up it's got to
equal 12. so 4 times 3 equals 12 that's
pretty straightforward same thing down
here 2 times 4 equals eight if I change
this and let's say I do two comma three
let's just run that in and you'll find
we get an error because you can't split
8 up into two rows by three
we have to pick something that it can
split up and arrange it in so let's go
ahead and run that and just for fun
let's go um
reshape our B again if I can type
reshape our B again and what else goes
into eight well we could do two by two
by two
so we can take this out to three
different dimensions
and then of course if we um because this
is going to come out you as a variable
we can just go ahead and run it
and it'll print it we can also do a
print statement on there just like we
did before and you'll see we have two
different groups of two variables of two
different dimensions so two by two by
two and let's go ahead and sign this to
a variable C equals B reshape and let's
do something a little different let's
roll the axes roll
axes
and we'll take our C and do two comma
one
and if we go ahead and run this it's
going to print that out whoops
hit a wrong button there let's do that
one again and you roll the axis and you
can see that we now have a set of zero
one two three four five six seven we now
have the zero two one three four six
five seven
so what's going on here we're taking and
we're rolling the numbers around and
let's just simplify this we'll just do
it with C comma 1 and run that and so if
we roll a single axis you get 0 1
and then it rolled the 4 5 up and then
we have two three six seven and if we do
two let me see what happens there and
this is one of those things you really
have to play with and start feeling what
it's doing
we've now taken 0 2 4 6 1 3 5 7. so you
can see we've now rolled by two digits
instead of rolling the one set up we now
rolled two digits up there and so if we
go back and we do the one
so we've rolled it up 0 1 4 5 and then
we're going to take the 2 in there and
we've rolled the 0 1 2 3 4 5 and 6 7. so
we start rolling these things around on
here there's a lot of different things
you can do on this
what's another way to manipulate the
numbers on your uh numpy
and finally let's go ahead and swap
axes we'll do c and let's just go ahead
and run that it's going to error on
there
that's because it requires a multiple
arguments left out the arguments so now
we can swap and we get the zero two one
three four six five seven so you can see
everything's been swapped around
so next thing we want to go over is we
want to go over numpy arithmetic
operations
how can we take these and use these let
me just go ahead and put this cell as a
markdown there we go we'll run that so
it has a nice thing all right nice title
on there that's always helpful
and let's start by creating two arrays
we'll do uh a is an EP NP
range a range nine and let's reshape
this
three by three so by now you should be
saying this reshape stuff and this
should all look pretty familiar we have
our zero one two three four five six
seven eight on there and let's create a
second one B okay this time instead of
doing a range let's do NP array we'll
just create a straight up array
but we'll do an array of three objects
so it's going to be three by one and if
we go ahead and print a b out let me run
that this is actually pretty common to
have something like this where you have
a three by whatever it is in a three by
by three array when you're doing your
math you kind of have that kind of setup
on there
and what we can do is we can go
MP dot add a b don't forget we can
always put a print statement on there so
if we add it you'll see that it just
comes in there and it goes okay we're
adding 10 to everything and we could
actually do something more oh make it
more interesting 11 10 11 12. so it's
change B's now 10 11 12 and let's run
that
and you can see that we have 10 and then
you had 1 plus 11 is 12. 2 plus 12 is 14
13 so 10 plus 3 is 13 11 plus 4 is 15
and 12 plus 5 is 17 and so on we'll put
this back since that's how the original
setup was let's do 10 by 10 by 10 and
run that and run that and get the
original answer and if you're going to
add them together we need to go ahead
and subtract
a b
and we run that
we get minus 10 minus 9 minus 8 just
like you would expect so we have our
subtraction 0 minus 10 is minus 10 and
so on and if you're going to add and
subtract you can guess what the next one
is we're going to multiply
and we'll multiply
a b
and this should be pretty
straightforward you should expect this
if we multiply 10 times 0 we got zero 10
times 10 is 10 and so on
and finally if you're going to multiply
let's
layout is divide
what happens when we do divide a by B
and we run this
we're going to get 0 and this is 0
divided by 10 is 0 1 divided by 10 is
0.1 2 divided by 10 is 0.2 and so on and
so on so the math is pretty
straightforward it just makes it very
easy to do the whole setup and again if
we went this and let's say let's change
this up up here instead of 10 we do a
hundred
and make this a thousand there we go if
we run that and then we do the add you
can see we got 10 plus 100 plus a
thousand same thing with the subtract
same thing with the multiply
and then you can also see the same thing
here with the Divide so a lot of control
there with your array and your math
again let's set this back to 10 oops
it's right up here wrong section
there we go 10 and we'll just go ahead
and run these and get back to where we
were
and this brings us to our next section
which is slicing and let's put in our
just make this a
of course it gives us a nice looking
slicing there and the slicing means
we're just going to take sections of the
array so let's create an array in p a
range
let's just do 20.
and if you remember if we do a we have a
0 to 19.
and then we can do a and remember we can
always print these this can always be
put in a print but because I'm in
Jupiter if you're doing a demo in
Jupiter that is it's just so great that
you have all these controls on here so
we can slice 4 on and this should look
familiar because this is the same as a
python and a lot of other different
scripting languages if we do four we go
0 1 2 3 that's the first four in the
thing and the skip sum and starts with
this one the first four Skip and then
from there on you can also do the
opposite
and go till the fourth one if we run
that we get 0 1 2 3 quite the opposite
on there we can do a single item so we
can pick object number five on the list
run that and five happens to be five
because that's the order they're in and
then this one's interesting so I can do
s equals slice
and let's create a slice here and let's
do two comma 9 comma
yeah let's leave a 2 on there so we'll
create an S Slice on here and then if we
take our array we do array of s we're
taking our slice in there and let's go
ahead and run that and let's take a look
and see what it generated here first off
we started with two so we have two at
the beginning we're going to end at 9
which happens to be eight so it stops
before the 9. remember when we're doing
arrays in Python and then we step two so
two four six eight we could do this as
three let me run that and you can see
how that changes two five eight
and we could do this as let's leave this
at three and if we change this to 10
oops let's make it 12. there we go
and we run that we have 2 5 8 11. so
that's pretty straightforward it's a
very nice feature to have on here where
you can slice it and take different
parts of the series right out of the
middle so now that we've accessed the
different pieces of our array let's get
into iterating iteration and this is
interesting because my sister who runs a
college data science division
first question she asks is how do you go
through data and she's asking can you do
you know how to iterate through data do
you know how to do a basic for Loop do
you know how to go through each piece of
the data and in numpy they have some
cool controls for that it just sends a
mark down there we go and run it
and it's called the nditter
sure what the ND stands for but ND it or
for iterator
so before we do that though let's create
an array or something we can actually
iterate through we'll call it a equals
NP a range let's do something a little
funny here or funky
and we'll do 0 45 5. I'm not sure why
the guys in the back pick this
particular one was kind of a fun one and
if I run that we do this you can see um
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40. that's
what this array looks like
and this is from our slice you could
this is just a slice that's all that is
is we create a slice of 0 45 0 to 45
step five let's see what we can do with
this we can also do a equals V shape
let's go ahead and take and reshape this
and since there's nine variables in
there we'll do a reshape at three by
three so if we run that oops miss
something there that is the a that
really helps so if we do the a reshape
and we'll go ahead and print that out we
get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40. and then
we simply do 4X in
our numpy ND enter of a
colon and we'll just go ahead and print
X
and let's see what happens here when we
run through this and we print each one
of those
it goes all the way through the whole
array so it's the same thing we just saw
before we got 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
so it prints out each object in the
array so you can go through and view
each one of these
and certainly if you remember you could
also flatten the array and just do for a
and that also and get the same result
there's a lot of ways to do this but
this is the proper way with the ND
iterator because it'll minimize the
amount of resources needed to go through
each of the different objects in the
numpy array and hopefully you asked this
question when I just did that
and the question is how can I change
this instead of doing each object so
first of all let's go ahead and take my
cell type and Mark that down run it and
so we're going to work on iteration
order C Style
C because it came from the C programming
and that's because it came from the old
Fortran programming so let's give us a
reminder I will do a print a and I'll do
four x and NP iterate a but we also want
to do this in a specific order and you
know what I'm a really lazy typer so
let's go back up here
this is the ND iterator I know I'm
missing the ND part of a and let's do
order equals
C we'll print X on there and let's do
that again and this time order
equals
f
whatever we got order equals F let's go
ahead and run this
and see what happens here and the first
thing you're going to notice our
original array 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
when we do order C that's the default 0
5 10 15 20 and so on and then when you
come down here
you'll see F order f is 0 15 30. so it
takes the first digit of each of the sub
arrays or the second dimension and then
it goes into the second one 520 35 10 25
40. so slightly different order for
iterating through it if you need to do
that so we've covered reshaping we
covered math we've covered iteration
we've covered a number of things the
next section we want to go ahead and go
over
is going to be joining arrays so we need
to bring them together let me go ahead
and take the cell and make it a markdown
cell type markdown there we go and run
that so let's work on joining arrays so
we can bring them together and what
different options we have
and let's do we'll do an NP array one
two comma three four
we'll go ahead and print
oops
first
these Rays aren't that big so let's just
go ahead and keep it all on one line a
if we run this first array one two three
four whoops I forgot it automatically
wraps it when you do it this way so
we'll go ahead and keep it separate
print a there we go and let's go ahead
and do a b
and we'll do five six seven eight and
notice I'm keeping the same shape on
these two arrays depending on what
you're doing those shapes have to match
let's go ahead and print
second array
print
B want to run that up
I've missed something up there let me
fix that real quick
and I was reformatting it to go in
separate lines I messed that up there we
go run all right so we have first array
one two three four secondary five six
seven eight
and we'll put a carried return on there
and the keyword we use is concatenate
and if you're familiar with Linux it
usually means you're adding it to the
end on there and we're going to do what
they call a long axis zero so we have
concatenate a b along axis zero let's go
ahead and run that and see what that
looks like
so we have one two three four five six
seven eight so now we have an array that
is four by two has a nice shape of four
by two one here
and if we're going to do it along the
axis 0
you should guess what the next one is
we're going to do it along the one axes
and let's see how those differ from each
other let's just go ahead and run that
and again all we're doing is adding in
the axes equals one so we have our
concatenate we have a b and then axis
one remember a couple things one these
are the same shape so we have a two by
two same dimensions going in there
you're going to get an error if you're
concatenating and they're not if you
have something that instead of one two
is one two three four five six with a
five six seven eight they'll give you an
error on there in fact let's take a look
and see what happens when we do that let
me just take this
one two three three four five and let's
run that and if we come down here up we
got there it says it says all the input
rate Dimensions except for the
concatenation axes M must match exactly
so it'll let you know if you mess up
that's always a good thing let's go
ahead and take this back here and let's
go ahead and run that
and so we have our zero axes which is
one two three four five six seven eight
and we bring them together and you'll
see a very different setup here where we
do it along the axis one we end up with
instead of uh four by two we end up with
a two by four one two five six three
four seven eight and this is changing
which axes we're going to go ahead and
concatenate on what I find is when
you're talking about the concatenate or
the joining arrays you really got to
play with these for a while to make sure
you understand what you mean by the axes
it looks very intuitive when you're
looking at it actually 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
axis one is then splitting in a
different way one two five six three
four seven eight
when you're actually using real data you
start to really get a feel for what this
means and what this does
so if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and look at splitting the array
and do that in a markdown and run it
there we go so you have a nice little
title there
and we'll go ahead and create an array
of nine let's do NP split
we'll do a and we're going to split it
by three
let's just see what that looks like so
if we split it we get an array 0 1 2 3 4
5 we get three separate arrays on here
now remember we're looking at let me
just print a up here
so we're looking at zero one two three
four five six seven eight and then we
can split it into three separate arrays
and let's take this we're going to do
this right down here I'm just going to
move the a split down here instead of
the three let's do four comma five and
put that in Brackets
and so we do it this way we have zero
one two three four five six seven eight
and that's kind of interesting I wasn't
sure what to expect on that but we get
when you split an a by four comma five
you get a totally different setup on
here as far as the way it split the
array
and to understand how this works I'm
going to change the 5 to a 7. and this
will visually make this a little bit
more clear so we had four and five I
went zero one two three four five six
seven eight and you see the markers four
and five when we do four and seven I get
zero one two three four five six seven
eight and so what you're looking at here
is the first marker is this is going to
go to four
so there's our first split at the four
the marker of four and then the second
split is going to be at position seven
and this is the same thing here a four
position five that's why we're splitting
it in those two sections we could also
do it seven let's just see what that
looks like run and you can see I now
have zero one two three four five six
seven eight
so we could split in all kinds of
different ways and create a different
set of multiple arrays on here and split
it all kinds of different ways and
before we get into the graphs and other
miscellaneous stuff
let's go ahead and look at resizing the
array I'm going to take the cell and set
the cells a markdown and run it
give us a nice title there and we'll do
an array an in Peru of one two three and
four five six here I'm just going to
just print
let's go print a DOT shape and we'll go
ahead and run that whoops hit a wrong
button there
hit the comma instead of the dot so we
have a shape of two comma three here
this is important to note because we
start resizing it it's going to mess
with different aspects of the shape
and so we'll go ahead and do a print
scoop in for a blank line there we go
let's do b equals
NP dot resize
we're going to resize a
and let's resize it with three by two
and then we'll just go ahead and
print
B
and print the period shape not a comma
I'll run that
oops forgot the quotation marks around
the end we'll go ahead and run that and
let's just see what that looks like so
we have one two three four five six
original array with the shape of two
three
and then we want to go ahead and resize
it by three two and we end up with one
two three four five six and we end up
with the shape of three two that
shouldn't be too much of a surprise
we got six elements in there we can
resize it by two three was the original
one and then we're actually just
reshaping is how that kind of comes out
as when you resize it like that
but what happens if we do something a
little different
and let's go ahead and just take this
whole thing and copy it down here so we
can see what that looks like
and instead of doing three two remember
last time I did the um to reshape it I
messed with the numbers and it gave me
an error well when you resize it you
don't have to match the numbers they
don't have to be the same dimensions so
we can instead of going from a 2 3 to a
3 2 we can resize it to a three three so
let's take a look and see how it handles
that and we come down here to 3 3 we end
up with one two three four five six and
it repeats one two three
so it actually takes the data and just
adds a whole other Block in there based
on the
and repeating it
all right now at this point you know
we've been looking at tons of numbers
and moving stuff around we want to go
ahead and do is get a little visual here
because it um
certainly you can picture all the
different numbers on there but let's
look at the histogram let's put this
into a histogram let me go ahead and run
that
and to do that we're going to use the
Met plot Library so from matplot library
we're going to import pipelot as PLT
that's usually the notation you see for
pi plot so if you ever see PLT in a code
it's probably Pi plot in the matplot
library
and then the guys in the back did a nice
job and gals too guys and gals back
there our team over at simply learn put
together a nice array for me 2087 4 40
53 with a bunch of numbers that way we
had something to play with and what we
want to do is we want to do plot the
histogram now remember a histogram says
how many times different numbers come in
and then we're going to put them in bins
and we have been 0 to 20 to 40 to 60 to
80 to 100.
you might in here with the matplot
library they call them bins you might
hear the term buckets or they put them
in buckets as a really common term then
we want to give it a title so the way it
works is you do your plt.hist for
histogram your PLT title and your PLT
show and we're doing just a single array
in here in the numpy array of a and
let's go ahead and run this piece of
code
taking a moment to come out there's his
finger size so it's generating the graph
and you can see we have and let's just
take a look at this and go down a size
there we go okay so now we can see we're
taking a look at here so between 0 and
20 we have three values so we have a 20
here we have a four and a 11 and a
fifteen zero one two three it's actually
Four values but they start at zeros
remember we always count from zero up
and from 20 to 40 we got 20 this is 142.
2 3 4
5 6.
and so you can see in the histogram it
shows that the most common numbers
coming up is going to be between the 40
and 60 range least common between the 80
and 100 this looks like an age
demographics that's what this looks like
to me and you can see where they would
have put it in the buckets of different
age groups which would be a nice way of
looking at this histograms are so
important and so powerful when you're
doing demos and explaining your data so
being able to quickly put a histogram up
that shows what's common and how it's
trending is really important and using
that with a numpy is really easy and you
know what let's take the same data and I
want to show you why we do bends or why
we have buckets of data I'm used to
calling it buckets why we have bins
let's do it instead of by 20 let's do it
by tens and see what happens
and what happens when you do it by tens
is you miss out on the you can see a
nice curve here on the first one and on
the second one it looks like a ladder
going up and a plummet a letter going up
and a plummet and a ladder going down
so the first would be more indicative of
an age group and the second one would be
what she would get if you divide it
incorrectly you wouldn't see the natural
trend
I don't know what this would be maybe
how much food they eat hopefully not
because I'm in 50 so I'm right in the
middle there that which means I eat a
ton of food compared to everybody else
but it's some kind of democrat maybe
it's mental maybe it's knowledge because
we we hit a certain point and we start
losing our marbles start leaking out or
something so you start off knowing
something and then as you get older you
grow more but you can see here we lose
that you lose that continuity in the
thing if you split the histogram into
too many bins or too many buckets
and if you actually plotted this by the
individual numbers it would just be a
bunch of dots on the on that wouldn't
mean a whole lot
and reflected graphs there turns out
there are a ton of useful functions in
numpy
I'm sure there's even new ones that are
aren't going to be in here but let's
just cover some important ones you
really need to know about if you're
using the numpy framework
one of them is Lane space function this
is generating data so you have a line
space we have one three ten and when we
do that we end up with 10 numbers so if
you count them there's 10 numbers
they're between 1 and 3 and they're
evenly spaced we get 1 1.222 but these
are all there's a total of 10 here and
it's right between the one and three
range
that could be there's a lot of uses for
that but they're probably more obscure
than a lot of the other common numpy
arrays set up
a real common one is to do summation so
we'll do summation where you do in this
case we create a lumpy array of one of
two different arrays One Two Three or
two different dimensions one two three
three four five and we're going to sum
them up under axes zero which is your
columns and if you remember correctly
columns is the one plus three two plus
four three plus five so we have three
columns and if we change this we'll just
flip this to one
we get two numbers so we get one two
three all added together which equals
six and three plus four plus five which
equals twelve we'll set this back to
zero
there we go since it said it was just
looking at zero
and these probably could have been some
of these could be able to start math
section square root and standard
deviation two very important tools we
use throughout the machine learning
process and data science and simply we
take the NP array we have again the one
two three four five six three four five
I don't know I need to keep recreating
it I probably could have just kept it
but we can take the square root of a so
it goes through and it takes a square
root of all the different terms in a and
we can also take the standard deviation
how much they deviate in value on there
and there's a gravel function we can run
that
and NP array is X we're going to do x
equals hey we changed it from a to x x
equals Ravel and this sets it up as
columns so we have one two three four
five this is all columns on here very
similar to the flattened function
so they kind of look almost identical
but we also have the option of doing a
ravel by column and then another one is
log so you can do mathematical log on
your array in this case we have one two
three and we'll find the log base 10 for
each of those three numbers there's a
couple of them they don't you can't just
do any number here after log but there
is also log base 2. log base 10 is
pretty commonly used on here I'm going
to run that there we go
before we go let's have a little fun
let's do a little practice session here
on some more challenging questions so
you start to think how this stuff fits
together right now we just looked at all
the basics and all the basic tools you
have so let's do some numpy practice
examples and let's start by figuring out
how do you plot say a sine wave in numpy
what would that look like and so in this
project we wouldn't have to do this
because I've already run these but we'd
want to go ahead and import our numpy as
NP and import our matplot library
pipelot as PLT so we get our tools going
here and then we'll break it into two
sections because we need our x Y
coordinates in here so first off let's
create our x coordinates and our x
coordinates we're going to set to an a
range
and we want this error a range since
we're doing sine and cosine it's going
to be between 0 and 0.1
and then we use our NP and we actually
can look up numpy stores Pi see how the
option of just pulling Pi in there
directly from numpy it has a few other
variables that it stores in there that
you can pull from there but we have
numpy pi and we generate a nice range
here and let's go ahead and run this and
just out of curiosity let's see what x
looks like I always like to do that so
we have
0.1.2.3.4 so we're going 0 to in this
case 9.4 3 times numpy Pi Pi is like
three point something something
something that makes sense it should be
about nine and we're doing intervals of
0.1 so we create a nice range of data
and then we need to create our y
variable and so Y is going to Simply
equal NP or numpy dot sine of X and then
once we have our X and Y and if we print
let's go and just print y you see all
that we'll do this let's do this so it
looks print
X print y
so we basically have two arrays of data
so we have like our X axes and our y
axes going on there
and this is simply a
plt.plot because we're going to plot the
points and we'll do X comma Y and then
we want to actually see the graph so
we'll do plot dot show and we'll go
ahead and run that and you see we get a
nice sine wave and here's our number 0
through 9 and here's our sine value
which oscillates between minus one and
one like we'd expect it to then for the
next challenge let's create a six by six
two dimensional array and let one and
zero be placed alternatively across the
diagonals
oh that's a little confusing so let's
think about that we're going to create a
six by six two dimensional so the shape
is six by six two dimensional array and
let one and zero be placed alternatively
across the diagonals
now if you remember from lesson one we
can fill a whole numpy array with zeros
or ones or whatever so we're going to do
NP I'll create a numpy zeros and we're
going to do a six by six and we'll go
ahead and make sure it knows it's an
integer even though it's usually the
default and just real quick let's take a
look and see what that looks like so if
I run this you can see I get six by six
grid so six by six zero zero zero zero
zero
now if I understand this correctly when
they say ones and zero placed
alternatively across the diagonals they
want the center diagonal maybe that's
going to stay zero all the way down
and then the next diagonal will be ones
all the way across diagonally and then
the next one zeros the next one ones and
the next one zeros and so on and
hopefully you can see my mouse lit up
there and highlighting it so let's take
a little piece of code here
and we'll do Z One colon colon two comma
colon colon 2 equals one and well that's
a mouthful right there so let's go ahead
and run this and see what that's doing
and so what we're doing is we're saying
hey let's look at in this case Row one
there's one and then we're going to go
every other row two so we're going to
skip a row so skip here skip here skip
here so we're going down
this way and we're going every other row
going this way it's hard to highlight
columns so you can see right here where
the that we're not touching each row is
like this row right here is not being
touched okay so we're going to start
with Row one and then we're going to
skip a row and another one and so we're
going every two rows and then in every
two rows we're looking at every two
starting with the beginning that's what
this thing blank means so we're going to
start with the beginning and we're going
to look at all of them but we're going
to skip every two so starting with Row
one
we look at all the rows but we do we do
it by two steps so we go one Skip One
you know one Skip One One skip one one
if you lift this out and do every one
this is just be once in fact let's see
what this looks like if I go like this
and run it you can see that I guess get
ones
so
this notation allows us to go down
each row row by row and we're going to
do every other row set up on there and
so if we're going to start with Row one
we also
control Z
try that there we go we'll start with
row zero again we're going to go each
row step two so we'll start with row
zero and we'll go every other row and
this time we'll start with one column
one and again we go every other one
going down
step that's what that step two is
skipping every other one we're going to
set that equal to one so let's see what
that looks like and you can see here we
get our answer we get 0 1 1 0 0 but it
has the ones going in diagonals on every
other diagonal and zero on every other
one
a little bit of a brain teaser that one
trying to get that one to work out so
you can see how you can arrange your
rows and here's your step in your
different axis on there
and then the next one is find the total
number and locations of missing values
in the array the first challenge is to
create some missing numbers so let's
create our array Z we're going to do a
numpy DOT random dot Rand 10 comma ten
and before we do the second part let me
just take the second part out
and let's just see what that looks like
so let's run that and there we go so we
have a 10 by 10 random array it randomly
is picking out numbers
and next we want to go ahead and take
our random integer size equals 5. and
then we're going to do a random random
10 size equals 5. so in the Z we're
going to select a number of random
spaces here and set them equal to null
value
now let's go ahead and run that so you
can see what that looks like and if we
look at the array
we've created one two
three four this should be a fifth one in
here my eyes may be filling me so we've
created a series of oh because zero zero
to five zero one two three four so we
got five there are different null values
on here and
this is kind of a neat notation to
notice that we can generate
random integers size equals five so this
generates five by five miniature grid
inside of this to tell it where to put
the nands at so that's kind of a cool
little thing you can do
and we want to look up and see how many
null values are in there
and this is simply just NP is Nan of Z
simple so if it is nand then we want to
sum it up so we're going to sum up all
of the different null values on there
now let's do one one more feature in
here which is really cool
let's go ahead and print the indexes so
NP argue where NP is
Nan of Z so we're going to create our
own another NP array and let's run this
and we'll see here that comes up with
the four indexes so we didn't count four
of them up there
it tells you where they are one nine two
zero four six five four
and then let's go ahead and run this
again run run there we go this time I
got five let's get for random numbers
another fun one that I always like to do
it's very similar because we have NP is
nand z dot sum so we're summing the
number of nands and we can get the
indexes and you can reshape the indexes
but you can also just do we'll do an
inds where NP is Nan of Z
and let's just print let's print that
print inds let's see what that looks
like
and it's very similar we have we have
zero one three zero six three eight six
nine three but I've split it into two
different arrays
so we have our X and our y kind of
coordinates going there and what I can
now do is I can now do Z inds
equals and at this point you can also
instead of getting the sum you can get
the means or the well the numbers and
that kind of thing you have or the
average as it is so be one thing you
could do and you could pick up the
average that's very common in data
science to get the average and just use
that for a value
but we'll go ahead and just set it to
zero and then let's go ahead and print
our Z and run that and you can see we
come down here we have wherever there
was a null value it is now zero and you
can set this to whatever you want this
is another way to replace data or help
clean data depending on what it is
you're doing
so wow we covered a lot of stuff so a
quick rehash going over everything we
went into there we looked at array
manipulation changing the shape
how to switch that around we even had
the flatten down there which remember we
have another command lower that's
similar we could change the order by F
remember F stands for Fortran very
strange connotation but there's C and F
C is the standard and F switches it to a
different order
to be honest I usually have to look it
up because I almost never use f but when
you need it you're like oh my gosh it
was the other order just do a quick
Google so we talked about reshape making
sure that the dimensions are the same
you don't want to have like something
that has 12 objects in it and reshape it
to C 11 and 5 because it doesn't work it
doesn't divide into 12. we can transpose
so we can switch them so we can go from
a four by three to a three by four Oops
I did that the other way around
three by four to four by three
we covered reshaping the array we did
the roll the axes you can do some weird
things with swapping and rolling axes
and transposing the numbers
we dug a little bit into the arithmetic
so we talked about adding we talked
about subtracting multiplying dividing
and you know at this point it's so
important we just look up the numpy
mathematics and you can see here they
have just about everything your
trigonometry
uh your hyperbolic functions rounding
sums products differences there are so
many all these different miscellaneous
mathematical connotations so you know
Google it go to the main numpy page and
look at the different setups you can do
on there so we covered that and we did
slicing I just break it apart we did
iterating over the array we covered
joining arrays and how to concatenate
remember concatenate just means add-on
to it so in this case how are you adding
B onto a is how you'd read that from
Linux you should catch the concatenate
because that's used regularly there
splitting the array we talked about how
to split the array in different ways so
you can split it in Array of arrays all
kinds of different ways to split the
array up how to resize it and remember
resize does not have to have the same
shape but if you resize it it will take
the data and begin at the beginning and
add new rows on if the size is bigger if
it's smaller it truncates it it just
cuts the end off
we looked at how to do a histogram and
how to plot that
we mentioned buying buckets or bins as
they call them in pi plot and then we
covered a lot of other useful functions
in numpy we talked about the line space
setup for doing uh numbers in a series
how to sum the axes up again that's part
of the mathematical formulas there that
we looked at there's a sum there's also
means and median all of those you can
compute in numpy and you can also do the
square root and standard deviation
the Ravel function very similar to the
flat
to be honest I almost always just use
the flat but you know the Revel has its
own kind of functionality that it does
and then we went into some numpy
practice examples we challenged you to
create a sine wave in numpy and how to
do that we're kind of looking for that a
range remember how we do the a range and
you can
have your beginning value your n value
which they did is three times pi and
then be pi and we're going to do
intervals of 0.1 and then y just equals
the numpy sine of x there's our math
from the math page we were just looking
at remember that it's right at the top
and finally we went down here we had
this kind of a little brain teaser how
to do diagonal zeros and Ones playing
with the different connotations of Z of
the numpy array
and then we did a random size and we
played a little bit with how to with the
null values playing with null values
if you're doing any data science you
know null values are like a headache
what do you do with them big sets of
data you get rid of them small sets of
data you have to factor something in
there like figure out the average or the
median there and then replace it with
that
pandas really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
that come off of it there's actually
sits kind of on numpy so if you've
already had our numpy array hopefully
you've already gone through the numpy
tutorial one and two So today we're
going to cover what is pandas we'll
discuss series we'll discuss basic
operations on series and then we'll get
into a data frame itself basic
operations on the data frame file
related operations on a data frame
visualization and then some practice
examples roll up our sleeves and get
some coding underneath there and let's
start with just some real general what
is pandas pandas is a tool for data
processing which helps in data analysis
it provides functions and methods to
efficiently manipulate large data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or Hadoop in Big Data so we're not
talking about Big Data here but we are
talking about pandas I mean there is
some connections there's like an
interface going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
Big Data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an Excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column when you have an index and
different that kind of setup and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as like a giant
Excel spreadsheet that's optimized to
run on larger data on your computer and
then I said it that it's a data frame so
the data structures in pandas are series
one-dimensional arrays and then we have
data frame two-dimensional array and it
really centers around the data frame the
series just happens to be part of that
data frame and here's a closer look at a
pandas series series is a
one-dimensional array with labels it can
contain any data type including integer
strings floats python objects and more
so it's very diverse if you remember
from numpy we studied they had to be all
uniform not in pandas and pandas we can
do a lot more and pandas actually kind
of sits on numpy so you really need to
know both of those if you haven't done
the numpy tutorials and you can see here
we have our index one two three four
five and then our data a b c d and e
very straightforward it's just two
columns and we have a nice index label
and a column label for the data and then
a data frame is a two-dimensional data
structure with labels we can use labels
to locate data and you can see here we
had if we go back one we had our index
one two three four five so in each one
of these series they would share the
same index over there the row index so
you have your row index DF dot index and
then you have a column index df.columbs
and this is like I said this would be
really familiar if you've done any work
with spreadsheets Excel so it kind of
resembles that this does make it a lot
easier to manipulate data and add
columns delete columns move them around
same thing with the rows so you have a
lot of control over all of this now
we're of course going to do this in our
jupyter notebook you can use any of your
python editors but I highly suggest if
you haven't installed Jupiter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on I
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or Ides for editing my Python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r dot org and then I always
let mine sit on anaconda anaconda.com
and just real quick we'll open that up
for you oops offline mode don't show me
that again but you can see here that I
have different tools that I can actually
install in my anaconda including the
Jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then I have access to the
environments and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one of the largest world's largest
snakes and then Jupiter notebook in this
case jupiter.org and when we're in our
I'm going to go in here to our Jupiter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a Python 3 and this will
open up a Python 3 Untitled folder
so diving right in let's go ahead and
give this a title pandas tutorial and
we'll go up to cell and we'll change the
cell type to mark down so it doesn't
execute it as actual code one of those
wonderful tools when you have jupyter
notebooks you can do demos with this and
let's go ahead and import pandas and
usually people just call it PD that has
become such a standard in the industry
so we'll go ahead and run that now we
have our pandas has been imported into
our jupyter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the Control Plus since it's Internet
Explorer I can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view oops too big
there we go and whenever you're working
with the new modules good to check your
version of the module in pandas you just
use the in this case PD dot underscore
underscore version underscore underscore
that's actually pretty common in most of
our python modules there's different
ways to look up the version but that's
one of the more common ones and we'll go
ahead and run that we get
0.23.4 and if we go to the pandas site
we see
0.23.4 is the latest release and of
course a reminder that if you're going
to an environment you need to install it
so you'll need to do pip install pandas
if you're using the PIP installer we'll
go and close out of that
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
the stuff you do in series you can then
do on the whole data set we need to do
what create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer right
into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go creating a series from
list
and let's just call this ARR equals and
we'll do 0 1 2 3 4. if you remember from
our last one we could easily do R equals
range of five which would be zero to
four what we'll do R equals zero to four
and we'll call this S1 and we'll go PD
and series is capitalized this one
always throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
got to watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do ARR so
we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series and then because we're in Jupiter
we don't have to put the print statement
we can just put S1 and it'll print out
this series for us now let's go ahead
and run that and take a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get 0 index row 0
is 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4. and because it's a
series it doesn't need a title for the
column there's only one column so why
title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created now let's do a
second series
PD and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order equals oh
let's do it this way
let's go index equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order equals and let's
do one two three four five so instead of
starting with zero we're going to give
it an order starting with one we're
going to run that and we'll go ahead and
print it out down here S2
and we'll see that we now have an index
of one two three four five and that
represents zero one two three four in
the series and we're still data type
integer 64. and very common as you're
missing with numpy arrays is we can
import our num b as NP remember that
from our numpy tutorials we can go ahead
and create a numpy at a random with the
random numbers of five and let's just
see what that end looks like so we can
see what our number looks like so we
have some nice random float values here
2.33 so on and this from our last
tutorial the numpy tutorial one and two
and instead of calling it order let's
call it index and we're going to set our
index equal to a b c d and e I want to
show you that the index doesn't have to
be an integer so it can be something
very different here and then let's go
ahead and create our we'll just use S2
again and here's our NP for numpy
series capital s
and N is our NP for numpy PD for pandas
there we go switching my anachronisms so
we have pd.series of N and we want to do
our index equals our index we just
created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like S2 is a print it and
let's run that and we can see here we
have a nice Series going on a b c d and
e for our indexes so instead of it being
0 1 2 3 or 4 we can make this index
whatever we want and you can see the
numbers here going down that we randomly
generated from the numpy array so we use
numpy to create our Panda Series right
here
and so continuing on with creating our
Series this one I use so often we create
a series from a dictionary so we have
our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of one B is 2 C of three
D4 EF5 so each one of those is a key and
then a value and then we're going to use
oh let's use S3 equals PD for pandas
series and then we want to go ahead and
just do D in here
print out S3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is one
B is 2 C is three D is four e is 5. and
it's still of integer 64 Because the
actual data is one two three four five
and it's all integers 64 type 64. and
the last thing we want to do in the
creating section of our series is to go
ahead and modify the index because we're
going to start modifying all this data
so let's start with modifying the index
of the series and if you remember let's
do a print this time S1
I'll go ahead and run this and the
reason I did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if I put
S1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take S1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously the
number of objects in our index has to
equal the number of objects in our data
and then because it's a last variable we
can go ahead and just do an S1 and let's
run that and you can see how we went
from 0 to 0 0 1 2 3 4 as our index we've
now altered it to a b c d and e so this
would be much more readable or might be
representational of a larger database
you're working with
So Cool Tools we've covered creating
database based on our basic array python
array we've showed you how to reset the
index
then we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in the pandas and
then we looked on changing your index so
now we have a new index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do S1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so I'd usually it doesn't
change S1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals S1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there I'll go ahead and take that out
but it's just a reminder that it's not
actually changing S1 it's just viewing
S1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append oops before we do
a pin let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the E of
course you can do minus two on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a 2 here c d e to the end so it
starts at the second one and another way
we can do this is we can do a minus 2
over here
and that looks at just the last two in
the slice so you can see how easy it is
to slice the data and of course there's
no reason to do this but you could
select all of them if you wanted to view
all of them on there oops 32 there's not
32 so it's just going to show the first
three there we go and then we can also
append so I can take and oh let's create
another series and append one to it and
if you remember we had S3 there's our S3
and we have our S1 I'm going to do S1
and let's go ahead and do oh let's call
it S4
equals S1
a pin S3
so we're just going to combine those two
into S4
and if we go ahead and print S4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one
so very easy to compend one series to
the next and if we're going to append
one series to the next we need to go
ahead and drop or delete one and drop is
a keyword for that and let's just do e
or index e and so if I run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
ABCD there's no e and remember all these
changes if I type in S4 again you'll see
that S4 still has e in it so this change
does not affect the series unless you
tell it to so I'd have to do like x S4
equals S4 dot drop e and there's another
way to do that which we'll show you
later on let me just cut this one out
there we go all right so we've covered
all kinds of Cool Tools here we have
appending we have slicing we did all the
creating stuff earlier as you can see
here on the setup how easy it is to
manipulate the series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series let
me go ahead and change this cell to
mark down there we go and
run so series operations what can we do
with the series and let's start by
creating a couple arrays we'll call it
array one and we'll do 0 through 7 and
array 2 6 through 6 7 8 9 5. let me
through the five on the end but let's go
ahead and run those so those load up
into Jupiter and we'll do this a little
backwards we're going to do S5 equals a
panda series of array two so I'm doing
this in reverse and then when we do S5
you'll see that we have zero to four it
automatically assign the index
67895 for our series and let's go ahead
and do the same and we'll call this S6
and we'll set this equal to PD series
for our first array and if we do an S6
down here to print it out
we'll see something similar I got zero
through six zero one two three four five
seven for the data so those are two
series we just created series six five
and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so I
can do S5 dot add S6 and let's see what
that generates and just a quick thing if
you've never used pandas what do you
think is going to happen with the fact
that this only has five different values
in it and this one has seven values
so let's see what that does and we end
up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it goes oh I
can't add this there's nothing there so
it gives us a null return very different
than the numpy that would have given you
an error this instead tells you there's
no value here because we couldn't
generate one so we can easily add S5 dot
add S6 and likewise we can do S5 Dot
sub for subtract S6 and we'll run that
and on the add the subtract and you
guessed it we're going to do multiply
and divide next again you can see
there's the null values where it can't
subtract the two because there's no
values there to subtract we can also do
S5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this and you can again you can see
how they're multiplied together and then
we can also do the S5 div three letters
again S6 and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
Infinity because we have 0 in the wrong
position so it actually gives you a
whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
null off of missing data and since we're
in data science let's do S6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply median sorry for those
who are following the three letters
because median is not three letters and
you can see an S6 is 3.0 and let's do a
print here and we'll do median
or average S6
and let's print Max
S6 and just like median there's max
value and if we're going to have a max
value we should also have a minimum
value so let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this and you're
starting to see something that would be
generated like say an R where you're
starting to get your different
statistics we have a medium value of
three max value of 7 and a minimum value
of zero and what it does when it hits
these null values if there is no values
in there because we could still do that
we could actually you know what let's go
up here and do
let's pick this one where we multiplied
let's go s seven equals
I'm going to print the S7 just so I keep
it nice and uniform so I still have my
S7 down there and run it and then I want
to take the S7
because S7 now has null values and an
Infinity value and let's see what
happens
this is going to be interesting because
I want to see what it does with infinity
and we end up with a median of six
maximum of 27 and minimum of zero which
is correct it drops those values so when
it gets to there and it doesn't know
what to do with them it just drops those
values and then it computes it on the
remaining data on there so that's
important to know when you're making
these computations you're looking at Min
and Max in median you're not going to
know that there's no values unless you
double check your data for the null
values that's a very important thing to
note on there so just a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our PD series and we've gone ahead and
done addition subtraction multiplication
division all those are three letters so
sub Min div add and then we looked at
median maximum and minimum so we're
going to go ahead and jump into the next
big topic which is to create a data
frame so now we're going to go from
series and we're going to create a
number of series and bundle them
together to make a data frame
there we go cell type markdown and
so we have a nice title on there it's
always good to have a good title all
right so our first data frame we'll jump
in with some stuff that looks a little
complicated we'll break it down first
I'm going to create some dates and you
know what let's just go ahead and do
this I want you to see what that looks
like what I'm creating here I've created
a series of dates PD date range and
we're going to use these for the index
okay so when you look at this you'll see
that it's just basically it comes out
kind of like a basic python list or
numpy array however you want to look at
it with our different dates going down
and we've generated six of them and it's
going to have whatever time it is right
now on your on the thing for the date
for the time that's that time stamp
right there and then you'll see we have
11 19 2008 11 20 11 19 and looking into
the future there so that's all this is
is generating a series of dates that
we're going to use as our index and this
is a pandas command so we have a date
range which is nice it's one of the
tools hidden in there in the handles
that you can use and next we're going to
use numpy to go ahead and generate some
random numbers in this case we'll do the
np.random.random and six comma four you
can look at this as rows and columns as
we move it into the pandas and of course
you could reshape this if you had those
backwards on your data but we want the
six to match the rows and we have six
periods so our indexes should match
along with the rows on there and then
you know before we do the next one let's
go ahead and just print out our numpy
arrays and see what that looks like here
we have it one two three four by one two
three four five six four by six so it's
a nice little setup on there and since
working with data frames can be very
visual let's give our columns we have
four columns and we're going to give
them names A B C and D so now we have
columns on there also and then let's put
this all together in a data frame and we
can actually you know what let's do this
since I did it with everything else
let's go ahead and do columns and you
can see there's our columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1 equals
pandas dot data frame and note that the
D and the f are capitalized series it
was just the S and I always highlight
this because you don't know how many
times these things get retyped when you
forget what's capitalized on there it's
a minor thing you'll pick it up right
away if you do a lot of it and the first
thing we want to do is we want to go
ahead and take our numpy array because
we're going to create our data frame off
of it's a numpy array and then we want
our index equal to our dates so there's
our index in there and then we also have
columns equals columns and then finally
let's see what that looks like now
remember we had all the different data
that just looked like a jumble of data
we have our column names and everything
else our numpy array kind of just a
jumble array over there four by six you
could sort of read it but look how nice
this looks I mean this is you come into
a board meeting you're working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe it's one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is if it's in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like
high of the temperature low of the day
humidity of the day whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one I use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data and let me just go down a notch so
you can see all the data on there we
have an animal in this case cat cat
snake dog dog cat snake cat dog we have
the age so we have an array of Ages we
have the number of visits and the
priority was it a high priority yes no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what I want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.net numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a the first cat B
the second cat C the snake D the dog and
so on so we'll go ahead and create our
labels which we're going to use as an
index and we'll call this DF let's do it
this way we'll call this df2
equals PD for pandas data frame and then
we have our data just like we did before
and then we have our index equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that and another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very Visual and
easy to read animal age visits priority
and then a through J cats and all the
different animals so on and so on and
then when you do programming a lot of
times it's important to know what the
data types are so we can simply do df2
D types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float 64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go df2 head and if we
print that out the df2 head Returns the
first five and we can change this you
don't have to do five you might want to
just look at the top two maybe you want
to look at let's see now let's do six so
maybe we'll look at just the top six in
the database in your data frame and you
can actually this creates another data
frame so I could have a df3 equal to df2
and this now takes the df2 and just the
first six values so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tell it's the same thing
DFT you can look at the last we'll just
do the tell which by default does five
the last five and of course you can just
look at the last three of those real
quick just to see what's at the end of
the data and this is the tell I love
doing the tell of one because I'll have
like the index or something like that
and it will just show me the last
whatever the last entry was looking at
stock values and I might want to look at
just the last five days of the stock
values I can do that with the data frame
tail
and some other key things to look up are
the index so we can do df2 dot index
and I want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if I put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there so we do df2 dot
index there's also columns
so we can go ahead and let's do uh let's
print this remember the first one is not
going to show unless I print it and then
df2 columns so now we can see we have
our indexes and we have our columns
listed here df2. columns animal age
visits priority that tells you what kind
of object it is or what kind of data
type it is and they're both object
and then finally df2 dot values and
again there's no brackets on the end of
df2.values because this is an actual
object it's not a callable function so
we'll go ahead and run that and it
creates this displays a nice array a
very easy way to convert this back to a
numpy array basically so before I go
into the next section let's just take a
quick look at what we covered so far
with the data frame we came up here we
created our data frame we did it from a
numpy array first setting the columns
and the index the index is setting it up
is the same as when we set up the series
so that should look very familiar so is
the whole format the numpy array the
index dates and the columns columns and
remember in our numpy array we're
looking at row comma column so six rows
four columns is how that reads in the
data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with the data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up D type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick we also did index and
columns and values and note these don't
have the brackets on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go ahead and
describe the data so we have def2 dot
describe to do that and we're going to
manipulate it in just a minute but let's
just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits so looking at our data from
up above let me just go all the way up
here animal age business priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value 25
or in this group 50 75 and your maximum
value so this should look familiar as a
data science setup with your describe
for a quick look at your data Frame data
so let's start manipulating this data
frame and moving stuff around and we'll
start with transposing and it is simply
capital T for transpose and when we run
that it flips The Columns and the
indexes so now the indexes are all
column names and the columns are all
indexes animal age visits priority so if
we had come in here with our data shaped
wrong up above where we had a four by
six we can quickly just swap it if we
had it backwards not a big deal and we
can also sort our data so something that
you can't deal which is more difficult
to do with a lot of other packages and
the data frame is really easy to do take
our data frame df2 and we're going to
sort underscore values buy equals age
and so when we run this you'll see the
default is ascending so we have 0.5 to
2.53 and everything else is organized so
if you look at your indexes they've been
moved around because each index it moves
the whole row not just the one piece of
data is not being sorted so a very quick
way to sort by age are different data in
the data frame and in addition to
sorting it we can also slice the data
frame so I could do df2 and this should
look familiar from earlier we'll just do
one to three so we're going to pull out
oops it does help if I use the DF
instead of just D and we're going to
pull up just between one and three so we
have not zero which is a we have B which
is 2 or B which is one and C which is
two so one two and then it does not
include 3 which is the standard in
Python and we can even do something like
this we can combine them which is always
fun because remember this returns a data
frame so if I take df2 dot sort foreign
values and we'll do by equals age this
is just kind of fun and then I'm going
to slice it there we go double check my
typing and run it and now you should see
fa because F A are now 1 and 2 on there
machine very quickly create a whole
string on here which narrows it you know
that you can sort it then slice it and
do all kinds of fun things with your
data frame we'll just go back to the
original one run there we go and if we
can slice it by row we can also query
the data frame so we can do df2 and this
is a little different because I'm going
to create an array within an array and
in this case we're going to look at oh
let's do age comma
visits so look at the different format
in here we have one to three so we've
done this by slicing by an integer value
and then on here I've done df2 age comma
visits in an array and when I run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get agent visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is I location
which uses the integer location one
comma three there's a push in pandas to
move to this particular setup instead of
doing just a regular slice and that's
because this can be confusing when we
slice one to three and then we select
age and visits so there is a push to go
ahead and move to an eye location which
does the same thing you can see here BC
it's the same as up above there's also a
copy command so we can do df3 equals df2
copy we're just going to create a
straight copy of it and if we do df3
that'll be the same as a df2 on there so
df3 equals df2 dot copy and then let's
do df3 dot is null so we're looking for
null values and this will return a nice
map and you'll see that everything is
false except when you go up here under
the cat or H they had a null there and
so if we go to have a couple up here
also underneath of let's see the dog
okay there's a bunch of nulls in here
there's D up here so let's look at D
down here and you'll see false true
there it is there's our null value so we
can create a quick chart of null values
you can use this to do other things we
can leverage that null value to maybe
take an average or something and fill
those null spaces with data and we can
also modify the location so here's our
df3 location
and notice this is location not I
location I location has I for integer
location uses the in this case the
variables on the left and what we can do
on here and we're going to set this
equal to one five and
some I'll pick a spot let's go back up
here where we had let's do F A just
let's see what were they looking at oh
here we go let's do F and age and up
here f is set to age of 2.0 and we find
out that that's incorrect data so we go
ahead and switch to df3 equal and then
we go and print out our df3
and if we go to F and H it is now 1.5 so
we're just changing the value in the df3
and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice and like it returns another data
frame this changes the actual data frame
and that value in the data frame
so we've covered uh location and I
location is null making a copy here's
our I location which is equivalent of a
slice and also selecting columns so now
we want to dive just to take a little
detour here and let's look at df3 means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if I run that there's our age
but if I take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal well those
are not integers so it's really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average I guess you could do a
histogram which probably will look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have the average or the mean on the
age is 3.375 and the mean on visits is
1.9 and let's do df3
visits we'll go ahead and still the
visits again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we can also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is 1 Max so all that
functionality is here so we'll just go
back to summing it up and adding it all
together so real quick we've shown you
how to take the series operations and
put them into the data frame and then we
can actually this is interesting one we
can just do df3 sum run and you'll see
the different summations on there it
just combines them I like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals PD series
and we just put it right in there we
have a c d a a b a c a popped in a null
value cow and Al I don't know why they
picked Cal and Al in the background
someone must like those animals and of
course we can just do string if we run
that you'll see leave the r out we'll
get an error but if we put it in there
you'll see that we have a simple series
0 a 1C 2D and it automatically indexes
it zero to eight and then we can go
string dot lower so when we're talking
about our data frame in this case or our
data series string in this case we use
the string function Str and we're going
to make it lower and we go ahead and put
the brackets on there and you'll see
that we've gone from capital a Capital C
so on to ABC and Baka CBA cow Al they
were all lowercase already and of course
if you want to go lower you can also do
upper and we'll go ahead and run that
and you can see we now have ACD AAA
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null all right
so we looked at a few basic string you
can see that string functions upper and
lower we're going to jump into a very
important topic I'm even going to give
it its own header on here because it's
such an important topic what do you do
with missing values Panda has some great
tools for that so we'll dive into those
we'll call we'll work with df4 and if
you remember the DF copy from above
we're just going to make a copy of df3
and let's just take a quick look at the
data we're working with oops df3 forgot
the three on there there we go so here
we have our cat snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll go at the value 4. so I can
run in here and you'll see now that df4
now has where the N A was is filled with
the value of four same thing down here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so I might do a mean page equals
df4 and then we want to go ahead and do
age
dot mean
and then I'll do something like this df4
I only want to select the age and I want
to fill that
with the mean h and I run in there and
you'll see that our df4h now has the
means in there just a quick way of
showing you how you can combine these
let me go back to our original one there
we go and run that and keeping with good
practices df5 equals df3 dot copy
a little printer df5 which should be the
original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
so I'm going to Simply drop in a and
we're going to use how equals any so I'm
going to drop any row that has missing
data in it and you'll see we had D here
with missing data and H and then let's
go ahead and see what df5 looks like
when we do that
there we go and there it is D is gone
and so is H so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power of the data you
got so just a quick look at processing
null values
or missing values you can fill them
usually with the means some people use
medium or the mode there's different
ways you can fill it one way is means
and we can also just drop those rows
those are the two main things we do with
missing data
here we go uh we're going to cover next
this is I so love data frames for this
file operations it saved me so much time
because they have so many different
tools for bringing data in and saving
data so we're looking at the data frame
file operations it's really streamlined
I don't know how many times I'll go on
to different data downloads and they'll
have Panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a CSV so we have df3 to CSV or animal
and let me just show you the folders
going into right now I have some
Untitled and a few things in here but
nothing labeled animal so we go ahead
and run this and this is now save the
animal to my hard drive and you can now
see the animal folder up here and if I
let's do edit with a notepad oh let's
open up with just a regular notepad
there we go or wordpad if I open that up
you can see it's comma separate did our
titles they don't have an index on the
categories on the top in the index comma
then all the different data is separated
by commas
standard CSP file on there and if we're
going to send it to CSV and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore CSV and it's
just the name of the file we're sending
it to you can also put the complete path
by default it's going to go whatever the
active directory this program is running
on that's why those other folders are in
there so we have our df3 to CSV and then
if we're going to put it in there we
want to also get it back out and we'll
call this one DF underscore animal
equals PD read underscore CSV I always
have to remember is two underscore CSV
and read underscore CSV I always want to
do like a capital in there and not the
underscore so we're going in here again
it's the active directory so if I now do
print out my DF animal
and let's just do the head we only want
to look at the first three lines so if I
go ahead and run this we'll see the
first three lines and they should match
up here what we saved to our CSV so very
easy to save and import from our CSV
files on here
and it turns out DF
3 also has a two Excel they actually
have a lot of different formats but you
know old school Excel was real popular
for so long still is we can go ahead and
save it as animal dot xlsx we're going
to call the sheet named sheet1 and then
I can also do DF we'll call it animal 2.
two and this one's going to come from
and the same format on here there we go
so we still have our animal xlsx
the sheet 1 that's where it's coming
from index columns equals none so we're
not going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign that zero one up on
your indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because null
values in here and we want to just make
sure that they're marked as n a and
we'll go ahead and just print out the
animal animal to there we go and let's
run that let's make this let's just do
the whole thing so we'll go ahead and
run that and it probably doesn't help
that I completely forgot the read so
animal 2 equals PD dot read
Excel there we go Excel so now we go
ahead and run it and what we expect is
happening here we have the same data
frame on here and if I flick back to my
folder you can now see that we have the
animal one of these is in Excel and one
of these is a CSV on here and so there's
our two file Types on there and they
have other formats these are just the
two most common ones used and I don't
know how many times I've had stuff from
Excel I need to pull out if you've ever
played with Excel it's a nightmare on
the back end because of the way they do
the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an Excel spreadsheet so we
looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there put your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where a really important part of data
science is so let's go ahead and bring
in our tools we're going to do import
numpy as NP we want to make sure we have
our Amber sign matplot library in line
this just lets Jupiter know that we're
going to print it on this page if you're
using a different IDE you don't really
necessarily need that but this does help
it displays correctly in Jupiter
notebook and if you remember for earlier
we could create a we're going to call it
TS we're going to create a pandas which
are cute cuddly creatures versus pandem
short for pandemonium no so we have TS
equals PD series and we're just going to
create a random setup of 50. we'll do an
index we'll set it equal to the pandas
date range today periods equals 50 so
the 50s should match and I want you to
notice something here I did not import
the matplot library why because it's
already in there pandas already has its
built-in connection and interface with
matplot Library so you don't have to
import it and we'll go ahead and do TS
equals TS dot cumulative sum we're going
to do the cumulative sum
it's a little reformatting there and
we'll go ahead and plot it and let's
take a look at what that looks like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus four to looks like about two maybe
or one minus four and one so what we've
done here we've plotted a basic series
just a single row of data when we've set
indexes on there but we can also do the
whole data frame on there and let's see
what that looks like so first let's go
ahead and create the data frame we have
here random number so we're going to do
50 by 4 and then we'll go ahead and
create columns a b X and Y just because
we can index is a ts.index on there so
we're going to use the same index as
before just to keep it nice and uniform
we've already generated the dates to go
with it and then we can do just like we
did with the series we can also do with
the data frame
DF equals DF cumulative sum so we're
going to sum the whole data frame and
then we'll do simply DF plot and this
puts that in and let's go ahead and run
this and look how easy and quick that
was to generate a nice graph with all
the different data on there so we have
our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh I think I mentioned
stock earlier because they've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a Stock B stock X Y
whatever it is and you could put them
all on one chart and see how they what
they look like next to each other and
this isn't too far off from what some of
those graphs looks like and this is just
randomly generated so stock has a lot of
Randomness in it which is one of the
reasons I actually play with it for
doing some of my models on for testing
them out
now there are a lot of features in
pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there's some of the
things like I didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a CSV and from an Excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
changes to a mark down and run that so
how would you remove repeated data using
pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's feeding
from one location and in instead of
noting that it's repeated the date like
oh let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have the stocks from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down so let's
start by creating a quick database our
data frame not a database I keep saying
databases the data frame and we'll just
make this data frame has using our
dictionary going in this data frame only
has one data Series in it which is fine
so if we do DF to print it out you'll
see a one two two two two four five six
seven and so on and so how would you
remove that well there is a neat feature
in data frames called shift
along with another feature that lets us
select just certain information and
we'll go with the location function put
that in Brackets remember that from
above location and then in the location
let me just spread this out a little bit
so it's really easy to read in fact I'm
going to go upscale on that since we're
doing some a little bit more complicated
here
what you can see on this on the location
is I have DFA dot shift so this is going
to shift up one by default you can
actually change this to two or three you
could even do a minus one and it shifts
the other way but it's going to shift up
by one by default that's going to say if
that does not equal DF of a then we want
that if you look down here we had one
two two two two when we run this Logic
on here and we do the shift it now gets
rid of all the duplicates so we went
from one two two two two four four five
whatever it was here it is one two two
two four four four five five five six
six six two one two four five six seven
eight and you'll see on the index it
just deletes them out of there so the
index stays the same obviously you don't
want the dates to change if you're
working with an index dated setup so it
just deletes those duplicates out of
there this is just a quick way to
introduce you to one the fact that you
can add logic gates into here and two
the I location allows you to use shift
so there's the shift function and then
the I location selects that based on
true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame how to index rows how
to slice how to plot hopefully you'll
take this beyond that and start
combining these different things and you
can create long strings and really
explore your data generate some nice
graphs if you're in Jupiter notebook
it's a great demo to show others and I
didn't know this about Jupiter notebook
you can do this in Jupiter notebook and
then you can download and I always I
never really look too closely at all the
downloads but you download as an HTML
and post it to your blog so it's got a
neat feature in there but any of this is
really powerful tool all of this is
really powerful tools for doing your
data science try giving a short to
Simply lens postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning in collaboration
with the IBM the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete audio
of the program being offered with that
we have reached the end of this Advanced
python full course if you have any
questions please feel free to comment
down and we'll have it answered for you
as soon as possible until next time
thank you for watching stay safe keep
learning and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you